hello everybody hello hello we are on the screen today
because uh they are setting up for the tournament and i'm
supposed to be like like a camera a specific camera for it
anyway today is sleepy bird day um because it is 12 p.m and
i am sleepy yeah they were like prepping and they just
Everyone's like, you know, their face, and then you just see
me in my pajamas.
Yeah, I, yeah, you see me, you see me in my pajamas, my
little jammies, ready for the draft phase, so we're just
waiting for a draft right now, so we're just chilling.
I, I am like, so tired lately because my cough has been, let
me, sorry, let me get my Oh
Do you have a plans on who to draft?
I don't have I'm just a puppet.
I'm the puppet captain I don't have the plans my pros have
the plans.
They're gonna feed me like the info there I do not have my
own free will.
I'm literally like Like for appearances Oh, does that sound
a bit different?
I fucking knew it.
I was on...
I've been on...
Oh my god, since when?
I've been... I was recording.
I was recording stuff.
Oh my god.
I don't even know how long I was on that mode for.
No wonder people couldn't hear me.
I was so quiet.
Yeah, I'm the puppet.
I'm just a proxy.
Yeah, it was my recording mic.
Yeah.
now can you guys was i really quiet earlier yeah i always
forget that uh i'm like uh i always forget i'm on my
recording mic yeah yeah i'm okay now i'm okay uh i even
realized i always forget to swap whenever i'm done recording
stuff um yeah it was kind of quiet yeah no wonder people
couldn't hear me.
No wonder.
Like, when we were doing, like, audio testing and stuff, no
one could hear me.
And I was just like, hello?
Hi, hello?
There's no one listening to me.
Why is no one, like, listening to what I'm saying?
But, um, it should be okay now.
yeah they hate me i knew it uh love the pjs for the skin so
you drop merch for pajama we technically already have merch
for this uh the i'm but it's sold out i'm sorry it was like
a one time drop i'm sorry maybe if there's extra when the
new drop comes out uh when the the the pre-orders from the
last pajama stuff comes out uh maybe if there's extra if
there's extra uh you might be grab it, yeah.
Uh, she, they use Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, where was that?
Yeah, even the, you know, we also had the tomato plushie
tool and the tomato eye mask.
Um, you know, yeah, you know what?
You can't, though.
Not yet.
You have to wait next year.
Not next week.
Sorry, next week.
You can't even get the dog shirts right now.
You gotta wait next week.
Because the what the fuck do you mean?
I don't know.
What?
What the fuck?
Okay, so I gave the job of drafting to my pro players.
And I was like, um, okay, so who do you want to take?
And then he was like, I don't know.
You had three days!
What do you mean you don't know?
I'm just the puppet!
I'm just, I'm just the proxy!
What the fuck do
you have the people in this tournament?
I don't even I mean I was like So what do you want for tank
Do you have the draft list because like you know I got a
draft And then he's like I don't know I fell for it again
Why do I keep falling for it again It never stops I keep
falling for it Again and again
Um And I'll keep doing it.
I'll never learn.
I'll never fucking learn.
So my assigned pros is trust me and speedily.
So yeah, and I was like, here's the list.
You do it.
I was just like, I don't know, half the people that's termed
it.
Here's the list.
Do my homework for me.
Do my homework.
I said I didn't want to be captain, but then Bulger told me,
he was like, oh, don't worry, the captains will be around
your level.
And then he listed Flats and Big Puffer, and then Puffer
couldn't make it in the end because he had something because
of the ice storm apparent, let's know, storm.
So he couldn't make it in the end.
And then so I was just like, wait, the other captains were,
and then when all the other captains got confirmed, I was
like, wait a minute.
These captains aren't my level.
but he did say my pro players will do my homework for me and
i'm just i i told him straight up i will be a puppet i'm
just i'm just here for appearances i'm the proxy leader i'm
not the real leader i did tell him that um i did say that so
um so like i've said i no accountability
I was like, no accountability, yeah, I'll do it.
If only I get zero accountability.
So if my team loses, I can be like, I didn't pick the
people.
My pros, pros, pros.
I'd be like, actually, my assigned pros picked the team and
not me.
So in the end, is it really my fault?
Is it really?
accountability um yeah what why no this is like a this is
like 90% pros like no matter what meet my skill level
compared to a pro player is like a fucking Grand Canyon uh
because uh I do not play as much I do not eat sleep uh drink
uh sadly unfortunately I know it's actually by how much I
love Marvel Rivals.
I know it's actually crazy, but like, I need to break it to
you guys.
Marvel Rivals might not be my entire life, maybe.
Just, it might not be my whole life.
Just maybe, guys.
I might have a life outside of Marvel.
crazy to think about but i do have a life outside of marvel
rivals um abelian thank you for the five gift that ships
thank you thank you my rivals vtuber is a variety streamer
unsubscribed how fucking dare you uh patria said they even
super chat thank you thank you oh oh they're doing a
countdown two one and you are
do i i can hear you they can hear you oh can
someone okay
i don't think they can hear me now I don't it's cuz the
application where I was showing my camera feed to the crew
it was unmuted so the crew was listening to me I see the
microphone now I was like oh no
Hello, ladies and gentlemen, I see a lot of people here.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Everybody hear me?
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
We have everybody here.
Very excited to do the draft.
We already know the order here.
And we're going to begin with Flats.
Flats is going to pick the tank.
Hopefully, we have a graphic to showcase everything.
And people have some visualization.
um necro's gonna be last pick i think if i remember
correctly from the top of my head it's flats then we have um
then we have sk then we have doki then we have j team
captain uh is it craggy or kg afterwards can someone remind
me i'm seven so it's kg so so it's kg craggy and necros
beautiful okay so let's just begin the draft i want to waste
too much of your time it's late for you know let's see what
you guys are going to pick all right well we're starting off
with tank uh for the number one pick we want to take crimso
beautiful choice beautiful choice crimso is very solid and
uh i've been i've been reading up on your chats on
everybody's chats you know i've been like buying with my big
eye and almost all of you want to take crimso first so that
says a lot that's the goat right there that is the goat okay
next up we have sk i want techie okay just give us a second
to update the graphics here remove okay sk gets techie um
beautiful why techie is there is there a decision here is
there like big big reasoning sk he's the goat he's the goat
okay okay okay dokey what are we getting uh i am taking drp
okay drp is a very good choice he's very flexible oh yeah he
plays yes i don't know who he is but that's what my pros
told me he's a new player i'll i'll gas him up for you thank
you thank you i'm just a puppet leader here very flexible he
can play any role at the 500 so you guys can definitely do a
lot of funky stuff with drp okay all right cool nice next up
we have jay my team and i are gonna get lugia the goat
you're gonna get lugia the goat oh any particular reason why
you guys are gonna pick lugia uh that's just what you know
that's what your pro said that's what our pro said man all
right i won't i won't pry i can't do the secrets man all
right all right i won't pry okay i won't pry we're going for
the vibes going for the vibes i hope the vibes are very good
with this team roster that you're cooking team captain i'll
be pecking madara oh madara he he is the one i think the one
that was replacing guru or one of the original tanks that
was supposed to play so he's kind of like our last pick here
that we invited to the bober bash and uh you know i've heard
a lot of good things about him and i've heard a lot of
people hyping him up so i'm excited to see what he can do in
the booger bash next up what do we have we have uh kg we're
taking andrew you're taking andrew okay we're taking andrew
yep okay you're taking andrew all right any particular
reason why you're taking andrew he's kind of like a dps
player do you need a squirrel girl player because i want to
i want to see necros cry this way oh okay do you think he
was aiming for the andrew pick yeah they love each other
husband wife i need to separate this relationship yes i
agree gotta look for divorce now now we have craggy well
well well there's only one right pick here and that is the
person that picked me in the first booger bash imperator
come to me the content team the content team all right all
right imperator right he's gonna lock in for you bro he's
gonna lock in for you okay he's gonna go above and beyond
okay i trust this guy he's gonna do some crazy stuff all
right beautiful and necros who do you choose what's your
choice necros tell me hello he's deafened can we can we
undefin this guy he's deafened this guy's like can somebody
tell this guy to undefin on discord is this guy stupid death
is during the draft he just i'm muting myself so they can't
okay okay wait wait it's good it's okay guys i don't want to
talk when they're having your conversation guys okay i'll
definitely yeah yeah the uh only person that's left i don't
know i'm just saying who is it who is it uh it's gonna be
snake case beautiful you're gonna get i mean he he might be
better than andrew you know you might be like you might be
looking for new husband right here you might be like be
married can we can we do a little venom swap for that like
synergy you know like the team shmungy synergy uh kg no i'm
trying to strike a negotiation here nope nope nope nope all
right all right necros first pick yes i'm gonna take delena
oh i'll be honest just like crimson i've been spying on
everybody's chats everybody said delena or melio first pick
actually so uh i think i think there is a clear winner here
i think it also benefits you because he is an a so if uh
with like biggest servers are gonna be north in virginia he
won't have high ping so that's very good next up we have
craiggy hopefully craiggy isn't deafened he isn't craiggy
what do you pick oh oh i get to pick a very solid dps player
here there is only one right pick and that is to pick the
same dps first, Bouguer Bash, Emilio.
Oh, beautiful.
You're assembling the same team as the first one.
All right, all right.
Very solid choice.
Now we have KG.
Okay, we want to take Malinia.
Still a very good choice right here, I'll be honest.
Next up, we have Team Captain.
Team Captain, what do you pick?
I might have a suspicion who you might pick.
Give me a day.
they oh i knew it i knew it i mean they and you you have
some history right you won the tournament that shouldn't be
mentioned right together oh yeah we're winners we're winners
they are winners unfortunately the winning has been
overshadowed by certain events but next up we have what do
you pick oh we can't hear me it's gail oh solid choice gail
okay beautiful next stubdoki what do you pick uh give me a
sec i'm i'm waiting for uh my my sources to tell me i'm i'm
waiting i'm waiting what sending brainwaves yeah yeah yeah
she's cooking up i'm getting i'm having a prophecy right now
an oracle coming to me charles davier himself professor
professor x is like i think okay i think they didn't do
their homework like who is open left i don't know who's oh
left wait who's left who is left let me check let me check
the dog we have you have kingsman for sure you have
donatello and moxy all right all right i'm i'm give me a
second it's buffering right now it's buffering uh we're
gonna get moxy beautiful choice very flexible place tank
place dps probably play support too okay so you guys can
definitely you know some very interesting positions with
Moxie.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
SK, two choices here.
Make the right one.
Hi, we're currently debating with the sources.
The sources are debating.
We're having a very thoughtful discussion between Kingsman
or Donatello.
It's very difficult because Kingsman is not there on the
first day, so you can't build as much synergy together.
That is true, that is true.
Wait, who is his sub, anyway?
It's an EU player.
Imagine EU Kingsman.
Oh, okay.
Place magic.
Oh, is it healers?
Place more nice.
Luke the Ninja 10 times better than Kingsman, okay?
He just hasn't had the time to shine, okay?
He was going band for band with craggy last tournament,
okay?
He was locking in.
I saw it.
It was like...
But he was the reason they lost.
He was the reason they lost.
So he's the anti-Kingsman.
It's like anti-venom.
Anti-venom and venom.
Beautiful.
Okay.
blackmailed I'm picking Donatello okay beautiful and then
Flats you get Kingsman slash slash I got the goat Kingsman
let's bring him in two Kings two Kings two Kings in the same
team okay beautiful okay Flats first big support big choice
here for yep uh we we may have already made the decision uh
we are going to be going with the Adam goat Korova himself
Korova very flexible
with that guy probably one of the best adam players so very
solid choice next up what do we have next sk uh last night i
messaged flats and told him that if he chooses armory first
i will go to his house um i would like to choose armory
please beautiful choice the the girlies reunited okay very
very solid uh you guys already have synergy built up and you
love each other and that's your wife so you guys are gonna
do great dukey all right um i'm receiving my brainwaves
right now i am charles saviors dmming yeah yeah charles
saviors dmming me i don't have fiver for this so it is very
it's buffering a lot i'm i'm still waiting it's it's still
loading for some reason i'm question marking him right now
i'm with this
Tell me on typing, whiny, whiny, whiny, yes.
Yes, yes, beautiful choice, beautiful choice.
I think it's an EU player, somebody correct me if I'm wrong.
I think there are EU.
He's EU.
But EU, right, correct.
And very solid choice, very good support player.
Next up, Jay.
Lock in, what do you pick?
I believe I think we are gonna go with Mash.
Mash is a very solid choice.
i love playing with mashing rank very vocal very flexible
very smart and wins from comps i like your choice a lot i'm
waiting for the voices to tell me what to say beautiful
beautiful team captain i'm gonna take woofos woofos the rank
one luna the rank one luna right there i think this is a am
i a pure eu team did i actually i'm excited to see how am i
like the token na am i i don't even know no speedily's n a
okay speedily amir n a i was gonna say am i like the mash
got picked winnie got picked carova and woofos got picked
right is that all correct yep i think so okay i accidentally
just drafted a eu team i and your goat desley hold up okay
we're taking lynn storm lynn storm is a very very good
choice i'm surprised he wasn't backline kg and lynstorm
scary next up we have raggy we pick it so there is only one
right pick here okay and that is to form the danish trilogy
i pick maluki oh the danes reunited you guys are you guys
gonna speak in danish ignore everybody else just lock in
common danish oh my god that's not that's roasting me be
like why didn't the captains do their homework because i
honestly think it's a very good thing for you know because i
outsourced my homework i wait what's the word i i delegated
my homework to people who have more knowledge than me you
know i'm excited that you guys are playing together i told
someone else to do my homework and remember correctly As it
continues his tradition of being the last pick, the absolute
very last pick in Vogue or Bash.
I delegated my homework to my pros.
They're vastly underestimating the skill.
And they have more dollars than me.
Yep.
It's going to be high-fivered by...
I went to chat GPT and be like, who should I get?
Good teams.
I'll be honest, I know who to cheer for because I think
everybody has a really good team.
But, you know, I think you guys can find...
yeah a good captain surrounds us with people that can do
what they can exactly figure out your comps figure out what
you're gonna play and we're gonna start setting up lobbies
and uh you know may the best team win don't stress too much
uh but remember the vibes need to be good and this is not a
for fun tournament okay it is competitive at the end of the
day and uh you know i hope the pros give you a lot of good
comps a lot of good coaching and I hope all the streamers
perform really, really well.
If there's any big issues, always contact the staff and good
luck, have fun.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
W vibes.
Beautiful.
All right.
Now I can leave the cam.
I don't even know if I'm supposed to have the cam on still,
but whatever.
I need to restart my Discord too because I have to put it on
admin mode.
Give me a sec, guys.
this on admin mode guys i just don't know the eu players as
much as na because because like i don't know i'm na and i
trust trust me because his name has trust in it so i should
trust him because yeah time zones guys time zones all right
let me swap my scenes real quick uh
i'll make sure everything is good to go all right
oh yeah i'm really proud of myself because last night i
didn't play rivals after the j3 tournament and then i went
and did a small boot camp of rivals last night um this is
why also i didn't stream last night because my pop was so
bad it was so fucking bad um i was just not having a good
time um and i was like super exhausted from coughing all
night and then um but then i went on and i'm gonna close the
cam i don't know if i'm supposed to i'm i'm not i'm gonna
close the camp but i closed the the cam for the tournament
thing because i don't know if i'm supposed to be on it still
but whatever they can notify me if i'm not yo actually my
play spider-man yo yo wait playing spider-man i think we
have to play spider-man i've seen you play it before i know
you can play it i believe you can play it no i can't play it
i didn't believe last in the last night when you were
playing spider-man moxie but i i believe today let's see
let's see wait you didn't see because you weren't you
haven't because you only because i only what you didn't
believe yesterday because you didn't hear about you only
heard about you didn't see it yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah true that's true i didn't believe it until i see it so
today i'm gonna see it exactly oh so you didn't see it
yesterday okay yeah yeah i heard about it and i was like
that's not my moxie there's no way i got it check check
check check check i'm excited all right let's hit it guys oh
my god look who's our first opponent we don't know but we're
gonna find out guys speeds a demon on the comms oh yeah but
look for that he's a demon Look, I had, I started at
Grandmaster Wood, and I'm like, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, we
don't talk about that, bam, we don't talk about that, bam,
bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam,
bam, bam, bam, bam, these don't exist, bam.
And a quick play MVP
That's right and a quick play MVP
Um Any highlights not really I just played I would not
really make our synergy Oh, I'm just getting yeah, yeah,
let's know let's do it I mean imagine a six stack quickly
just roll out Wait, is that map on the map?
The map was in the info version.
What was it?
Info and rules.
Yeah, it's domination, Hell's Heaven, Spider Islands, and
then Hall of Tachala.
Okay.
Oh, there's three map sets.
So you can pick Hell's Heaven set and then B is Cracoa,
Midtown, Symbiotic, or in Central Park.
Wait, Winnie, are you here?
Yeah, I'm here.
I chose you because I need you to play Jeff.
You need a Jeff player.
Are you going to play Deadpool then?
I mean, we're going to play Deadpool, guys.
Oh, V.
I think it's actually not bad, yeah.
Well, well, we picked you because you're a top 10 god.
Yeah, yeah.
I picked you because trust me told me to pick you.
Because you're the goat.
I'll pick that.
I believe
All right I believe guys Not last That is my goal today Well
I believe everyone else has a different goal from me But for
me it's not last I always go in with low expectations Go Go
in with low expectations Because then everything will be a
surprise Brew up some full dive synergy We can make it work
Alright guys I could tell you what's on the line for me if
you want if you want to know what i'm capable playing all
right all right got hawkeye all right okay i got i got well
you don't come out don't come out trust me uh spider-man all
right cap okay i still got a cap it's okay okay mantis if we
ever really need it you know maybe even the loki sometimes a
daredevil sometimes a bucky is a staple
i got a namor yep namor can we can you add a phoenix to that
arsenal i've played phoenix before that's good that's good
enough for me that's good enough i've had a season can you
can you beat tara on phoenix moxie do you think you could do
it if it was like bayblade time like i feel like i could
have pressed the buttons just as well as he did but the aim
i don't know it's a little weird
maybe maybe you get fully pocketed by two supports maybe you
got it maybe yeah maybe it was like a 2v1 he was like yeah
yeah 2v1 i think you can single like well not
single-handedly but like you know yeah maybe he's a funky
player i'll tell you that much it's okay we can do this guys
i forgot to get my cough drops i ran out last night we might
have to is he better now yeah he's pretty he's pretty good
oh no i think we banned phoenix and things we also want to
play dive yeah i think last band maybe do you want to leave
loki open and ban mantis instead i really like mantis burn i
really don't want to play into mantis i think we're gonna
play full dive then loki's not that big of a deal no i think
it's okay loki's easier to dive than mantis personally yeah
they're they're cooking right now i'm just existing wait no
this is not the right is this i already said why did the
captain do her homework it was like i'm like um as a captain
i surround myself with peep i was told that i can delegate
my homework and I can just be like the face of the team.
I was told I could just have zero responsibilities.
I'm just here to look pretty.
Good for one.
Yeah, leaders don't need a tank.
We act.
Well, I don't know.
I don't think that's all yet.
But you guys see these like map sets though?
They're kind of interesting.
like the first one in my opinion yeah i think if one to play
full dive the first one is probably the best
it's going to be either a cap venom cap angela or venom
angela or venom deadpool we have infinite tanks to play and
you can always go magneto and aimbot them on controller
honey it doesn't say who gets two picks the map sets so i
don't i don't know how that's going to be done yeah i don't
know either yeah i'm reading the rules it just says here are
the maps this but it doesn't say who gets which team picks
first maybe it's just like you play them in order of that
first game is always going to be a second game b c and then
it goes back a b c maybe i don't know
oh i'm gonna say i'm gonna ask who Which team which so what
should I be practicing in the range spider-man the map
That's all right.
I think you got to look at some hella This is our face of
our leader.
Yeah, you might have to play hella I will be honest.
I I'd much rather play Phoenix than hella But like that also
works for me If I have to it's very likely that I'm trying
I'm not this maybe that would also be op i promise that's
okay all right what about talks about a hawkeye i need to
fix the audio right now for everyone i've just seen your
tweet talk about how the hawkeye is hawkeye is no hawkeye is
op bro but i'm i actually think people might ban it versus
us yeah that's what i'm banking on why we should be winning
like in the draft if they think i'm uh trust can come up a
bit all right i'm pushing trust a bit higher and then i
don't think you're an otp speed can come down a bit okay
you've seen me play cap all right there you go how the vibes
looking chat
Thank you for the super chat.
Reaver, thank you, thank you.
I hope that answers it for you.
I hope that was the answer you seek.
You know what?
We should have just ran a six stack of equipment.
Oh.
I'm doing my tech on Spider-Man.
are you actually good is it like i i watched the first game
please map set
no i never said it in that context i said second matchup hey
that's different games different games different vibes one
one me
in the range mate
i wanted to get lucia gold originally but i think the rp is
better not only i i kind of wanted to get lucia goat for the
hero pool how good is your thing lucia goat uh not lucia is
supposed to be hard he's like my plan was to not pick he's
so german by the way trust me it's german and you're like
damn that's you're like he's german by the way that's crazy
that's I actually wanted to pick this guy, but then I
thought maybe you have your bed.
Maybe you are a little better.
I'm telling you guys, worst comes to worst.
Like if every, let's say, let's say for some reason it's not
working.
The hot guys gotta be the craziest pick to just throw in
there.
You know?
I actually think you're right.
I think we should probably play it.
Okay, it's actually crazy.
I actually think Hawkeye is not bad.
If we can force a matchup where they go cloak and we get
Hawkeye, okay, I'm down to play.
It's actually funny because he was like, and then we just go
DRP.
He was like, he messaged me and he was like, oh, I think I
have an account on range, right?
Oh, wait, let me see.
I was crazy.
I was, I literally messaged back.
You're so fucking German.
Because I was just like, that is such a German thing to say.
Like, okay, wait, let me see.
uh bad yeah bad all right here you go okay okay he was like
i showed him in a cap in range around uh around diamond i
played my low account high i placed placed my played my low
account high because i want to play with my streamer idol
it's not you but this guy and then i was just like bro
you're so true
or flank luna
that's crazy he's like I played by low and care how because
I would play with my favorite streamer right I was like aww
and he's like not you but this other guy like he named this
other guy he's like they don't know does that sound mean lol
you get what I mean I know because I know your accounts I
would know the band jazz he's like oh but you get what i
mean right my favorite not you don't worry but you're
listening to give it the super chat thank you thank you so i
asked the the the organizers they said the first set of
games will be on map set a and then the second will be b and
then third will be c so we're playing hell's haven first the
map set we play every opponent just like last time right
yeah first to one right it's i'm looking at the info yeah
it's first to two i think it's best of three yeah it's best
of three every opponent today yep best of three how long is
it gonna take what the god that's true we just like that's
why it's two days it's just a calm world 21 oh wait 18s will
be split in two groups of four so it's just yeah so we're
playing three other teams i thought i read something we only
have to play three games yeah oh okay okay okay bro i
thought like we have to play like seven games today and
that's too much i mean not for me but oh yeah not for you
guys yeah not not for a gamer like you hot trust yeah yeah
yeah
moxie we gotta do something together again i swear we have
to play like the funny game what is that breathing i think
it's moxie i'm pretty sure but you never have time for me
you're not a good friend i swear wait why is he not a good
friend yeah i feel like i'm an okay friend all right when
was the last time yeah he only messages me when he needs me
oh my god you own you're using him you're you're using he's
taking advantage of you yeah yeah he's not even cooking the
food that i suggested okay my bad my bad i'm not a big cook
hook dude how are you gonna make up to him you gotta win
this tournament now i missed you every every every now and
then every like few days maybe every week when was the last
time you messaged him moxie look at your dms okay and what
were you asking i started the i overstarted the dialogue
yeah i the last time he started the dialogue was oh actually
on new year oh okay never mind that's
there you go and on the december damn all right okay we're
actually good friends all right all right thanks for
clearing that out
yeah i'm cliff farming i'm trying to clip farm right now
another turn another cliff farm i mean black panther what
are we gonna play with it just hey i think it's not that
good right now that has to be like the worst here on the
game though yeah yeah i was gonna say when was the last time
we saw a black panther them you haven't reversed me yet
all right when was the last time you pulled out a black
panther i kind of want to ban phoenix would you want to ban
how long just go hawkeye like surely hawkeye just destroys
shingle yeah all right i'd rather not play into a hell of
anymore i feel like that's gonna be yeah yeah i mean then we
have full dive it's fine wait what do i play for the full
dive if why he is playing jeff i play rocket oh nice or
inverse or adam oh okay wait adam who's the third support no
no i don't need three supports oh you don't need three
supports on adam oh yeah you just play for your life oh i
mean i lost i lost words to adam support with jeff to be
honest and we're gonna do it again but to other people not
not us learn from our mistakes yeah yeah this guy's wise
we're we're just waiting we're just waiting for um we're
just waiting for them to set up the stuff because they're
they're setting things up it's gonna apparently it's gonna
be a wine can come up a little bit okay i'll push him up
i'll push them up a little bit oh my god also like we've
been trying to set up the vr chat meetup for a while now but
our skin it's so hard to coordinate schedules because we're
like what about this week and then like it was like it every
time one of us just has something so most likely the meetup
might be at the end of february um for those who are
wondering we just been having trouble uh uh landing on
schedules Oh, but next week, next week, we're going to be
playing Yap Yap.
It's like, it's like that wizard game, but like, we're
working together instead of against each other.
And we're exploring dungeons.
And we're going to be doing sloppy sisters with a sad and
Nini fries next week on release date on the third, February
3rd.
Yeah.
It's called Yap Yap.
I organized that collab because I was like, oh, it's five
people.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
We're going to be working together for real.
It looks really cool.
It's like, it's like, um, it's like where you yell out
spells and stuff and explore, explore dungeons.
It's a rare five people game.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, captain's chat.
Um, our info for your lobby will be posted.
We'll go in the team chat when.
ready okay we're just waiting on we're just waiting on the
thing waiting for our lobby info i just hope not last yay
that's all i want do i just play like this head empty head
empty zero accountability that's how i like like it yes
please yeah but then won't see my raw reactions not last you
can do it it's my dream it's all right i didn't pick the
team anyway i'm sorry i didn't mean it like that i didn't
mean it like i'm just just trying to make a joke i'm just
trying to make technically i did but I was controlled by my,
the voices.
I was, I was going to keep police.
Zero accountability.
I think if my mic dies, I think I need to go headset mic at
one point.
Definitely will do it.
Wait, how bad is the headset mic?
How bad is it?
It can't be that bad.
It's pretty bad.
I mean, we listen to Moxie all the time.
It's fine.
Yeah, it's actually Moxie.
It's a little bit more Moxie.
A little bit.
I think Moxie's mic is pretty alright.
Well, I think people overplay this.
Like, it sounds great to me.
Okay, you don't listen to yourself though.
Maybe.
Alright.
You can't.
Yes, I can.
I will delegate all responsibility.
Oh my god, stream together, Moxie.
Yes, sir.
I need everyone.
Ooh, I need to do something then.
i will all i'm saying is that i had because cheating
accusations i've seen them i i haven't looked into anything
i actually watched so much yesterday everybody was well yes
everyone was watching i actually think he's cheating as a
pro you think he's cheating yeah i think that I think people
were saying People were saying that It was very suspicious
because he had Other hackers in his chat Talking with like
he's friends with other Hackers so that's really sus That's
a little sussy In Overwatch an example I played with former
cheetahs on the team Usually the cheetahs are also good
aimers Like Like the There's some There's definitely some
truth to it You know like if you If you're not a bad aimer
to hide it it's like if you're very good chess player yeah
you can like cheat one or two moves you know i mean that's
like apex too yeah as long as you have the movement and like
the game sense you can hide cheese very well yeah i think so
too it's just like impossible to like actually prove that
he's cheating though nowadays unless like you like have him
play on like have him play on land or something like that's
why he doesn't want to go pro he's also very young yeah
he's worried that he'll get caught i don't know about that
but i mean i know back how it was in overwatch you know like
it's actually very hard to prove someone is cheating oh like
yeah now nowadays though it's like literally impossible yeah
i know with like dma cheats and like oh yeah because the
cheats are more defied now yeah they're like expensive as
hell aren't they they're like you have to pay a monthly
subscription the good ones yeah the good ones really
expensive how much would it cost um yeah how much would they
cost speed yeah yeah yeah
well i have spoken with like some guy who's like involved
with that and he said like it is like probably like more
than like 15 i don't know it's like at least a thousand
dollars a month holy this is like rich kid shit yeah
actually would be these people are what these people like
cheat in like tournaments and shit to like get the winnings
to like you know yeah i mean that makes sense or the boost
you know yeah yeah then they can text it off you mean oh
yeah it's a business expense that's so smart pretty much so
funny oh my gosh cheat developers must be like crazy rich
description.
There's also ways to get it for free, I think.
But those are more detectable, aren't they?
Unless your friends with one.
You'd be like, hey, homie, hook me up.
Yo, bro, I heard you developing a cheat.
Yeah, that side lock was a little too good.
Yeah, let me 0.25 that real quick.
Well, we know.
Yeah.
Well, I did play on land, so I'm cleared.
Wait, what place did you get placement did you get in land?
But you had it turned on, it would have been first, right?
Oh, maybe.
If Torch wasn't bent.
Oh, yeah, true.
Torch wasn't bent.
That's true.
Colin, yeah.
If he had his hacks, he could have got first.
Team Craggie, who's on that team?
uh alex Vinny the also the lobby's up now guys What other
Vinny is there?
There's no other Vinny.
I don't know.
Oh, I said Vinny.
Why is the lane?
What the fuck?
What question mark?
Yeah, we have a Winny though Yeah, what is it?
Okay, all right lobby's up wait Winny or Vinny?
What how do you?
Winny, Winny, how do you?
check not gonna lie
did you yeah me too moxy i'm i'm confused oh he's trying
delane is trying to see who's a who's a real one that'll
accept his invite
yeah it's like okay don't invite me again
damn and that's crazy not a real one apparently all right
booger bash lobby name booger bash 2026 2.
i don't see it's oh tournament room oh yeah tournament room
password vibes one two three six seven booger bash oh booger
bash i have a webcam looking at keyboard so i think i might
just leak the password gg nice well maybe now all right join
do you ever wash your mouse pets i just buy a new one i feel
like we should do that i just buy a new one because i feel
like when i wash it it just scrapes the thing off maybe well
mine's not cloth mine's like half glass like the material in
mine is like it's not like a cloth either yeah i think yeah
wash it with water and it's manly we got so lucky in china
we got like an insane mouse pad he got like a 400 euro glass
mouse pad and he got a gifted i want to but they wouldn't
gift it to me wall heck no well um is that supposed to call
it right oh it's not i don't know what it is but it is yeah
those should glass pads tend to be I don't like glass pads
too smooth.
It's way too fast.
Good for low sense.
Yeah.
My sense isn't that low.
I think like I had sponsors gift me glass pads and then I
use it and I didn't want to waste it so I just gift it to my
friends.
W front?
Yeah, W front.
I resell that, fuck that.
You would resell it?
No, no.
damn i'm gonna remember that when you get sponsored by a
mouse pad i'll be like i had like one like teammate a long
time ago that had a glass pad that just seems like a pain in
the ass to carry around like it's like fragile too isn't it
a tournament or something it's just yeah yeah you gotta be
careful with that it can it can break oh they're doing
balanced latency balance latency see no it says northern
virginia i don't want to play on 130 ping thank you very
much yeah i think that's good wait art yeah wait i thought
it was north virginia no i think it's probably on a wait
their team is just mostly eu on on i think is unplayable
yeah i know it's it's it's the useless i had i had necros
earlier and i think he was yeah he was playing on na and he
legit went like i think he was like one and seven or one and
eight At the start.
It's not playable.
It's just so cooked.
I think they set the server as like...
The East Coast, I think.
Yeah, it should be North Virginia.
Oh, yeah, I get good ping, too.
That's what they said.
Yeah, because their team is just full EU plus Vinny.
Vinny's like their token ending.
He always does this, man.
Wait, what placement did he get on Bulger Bash 1?
Cheating his way to the end, huh?
With a ping.
Any objections to the auto select server?
We have very, very major objections.
I'm here to speak for, I'm here to fight for Vinny.
What is, what is, what is, what is auto select server?
They definitely just chose this.
See, I'm such a, see justice for Vinny.
Yeah, I'm not for ulterior motives, guys.
Not for ulterior motives.
I wanted... I wanted...
I wanted Vinny to have a good time.
I wanted the guy to have a good time on his team.
Yeah.
Surely not.
It's not like I'm on a hundred ping or anything.
I'm...
off tokyo server damn what are we doing here bro i'm not
even gonna cope na to other regions it's not it lags too
much compared to the other way around i'm just gonna say it
all right i think you're just weak no i played i mean you
played marvel it's not the same it is so weird moxy lived in
you he mourned in you want is that a word more not mourn
what what Like, like when wine ages, you know, it turns
good.
You earned.
Ripened.
Yeah, now you, now we yield the rewards of the grant in the
EU.
Holy ferment.
You're fermenting in EU?
Frankfurt and Warsaw.
I thought, I thought it said like on the, in the rules of
the servers in North Virginia.
I thought it was.
I was told that.
We have to do mandatory Virginia person I don't know how to
spell I don't know how to spell Virginia.
Give me a sec I'm gonna pull up I'm gonna rulebook.
Oh Nice nice.
That's good.
Pro player has more value than me.
I agree Well you say you don't know how to spell Virginia.
I don't know how to spell Virginia.
That's not good I have auto-correct, but there's no
auto-correct in Rivals.
The only text Virginia?
I'm not American.
I don't need to know American states.
Damn.
That's Loki's selfish of us.
Yeah, my bad.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
I don't know if you know this, but there's more than just US
and NA.
to become a state.
Craigie and Green ping, huh?
Are you streaming, Pete?
Yeah.
Mark, you invite him to the...
Don't you have to?
I don't think... No, no.
Bougar was like...
No, Bougar was like, I don't care.
He's like, I don't care if you stream or not just have fun.
He was like, if you don't stream, I'm going to get the
viewers.
It's fine.
because i was like do i have to stream on twitch he's like
you can stream on youtube stream if you don't stream you get
kicked always kick from a fifty thousand dollar oh my god
get that video made right now call your editors oh did my
editor drama bro i've been trying to get a good editor for
the last two months it's hard it's hard to get it yeah
especially when i don't really have a lot of salary to offer
but i do have some but not enough i guess i mean as you're
offering like a cut of the channel right yeah that and a
base salary of 1k can you not use like a nabi editors or
something i have not thought about that oh yeah maybe just
ask your org
yeah i don't think they play marvel rivals though Yeah, I
guess that's true.
Are you ready?
Yeah, I'm are.
We're all here?
Yeah, we are.
Wait, who's doing bands?
Moxie's the band leader, by the way.
Give it to- No, give it to trust me.
See, we're on top of things.
Question is do we do group in here?
I don't think we should.
I trust the process.
We have DRP he can he can ult us I can yeah, or I can play
good.
He has the second place MRC icon I trust you
When wait when which season did he have it but does he have
this though?
Does he have the third place?
For the top 32 that's aura.
That's aura.
Does he have that one?
No, that's the beta.
Yeah.
do we all have the way i don't have one i does everyone else
have one oh my god i have a different one my mrc one yeah
the mrc icon i i don't have one i've never played i think i
got seconded one mrc you get one for ignite or no no like so
that's so sad you guys should get something i'm waiting for
the day to make a trust me venom skin oh so you're Yeah,
you're talking game.
I get it.
Okay.
Are you guys putting comms and everything on?
Or off the one face?
Okay.
It's always on.
Okay, okay.
Be away with it.
Okay.
Guys, I also...
I also fixed this audio guys.
I adjusted audio guys.
There's no way they'll stream snipe.
That's messed up.
Yeah.
I don't think they'll seem to say.
Loki safe.
Mantis safe is actually a problem, unironically.
Hmm.
That's actually not too bad.
We're saving Daredevil, right?
Yeah.
I'm not giving back to a Benton this year.
I've been Mantis for sure.
But I need to get cough drops.
No, I don't want.
I think we...
Sorry, I actually am muting myself when I said that.
I was just trying to say that to you guys.
I didn't get cough drops after this game.
I think that makes more sense.
Give me safe DD.
trying to tell that to you guys like defeat in this now we
can't defeat in this tomorrow so we should try to defeat it
now yeah let's see they ban
let's see let's see if they're thinking
oh so that shouldn't matter for us right yeah it's pretty
good for us honestly yeah it's always been loki uh that is a
question Phoenix or thing?
I actually want to ban Phoenix.
I think it's much stronger.
I don't think themes will last say theme, too.
Yeah, last ban thing.
I think if they don't save it, then you can always spend
some time.
I think they will save thing if they see a DD save.
They just fucked up.
I think they're going to save it, isn't it?
That's my bad sound guy.
I accidentally lowered Discord and upped my game volume.
And then upped my game volume.
should be so you might never eat balance because my discord
i accidentally lowered it to my game volume i did i miss red
yeah there it is i miss red so my game volume is normal now
and then w
that's my bad i have to keep at this though because all my
my other collabs are at this Wait, what is my audio?
Is it 9.5?
9.8?
They're gonna go, they're gonna, yeah, actually I think.
I don't remember sound guy.
I wrote it down for you.
You have it.
You have the record.
But I think it's fine.
Wait, what do I play?
Yeah, what do you want in the bug line?
I think we go...
Do we go full dive?
We can't try it.
If you play Hawkeye, I don't think...
Yeah.
Now, if we want to play Hawkeye, then not, but otherwise we
can.
Like, I would want to play probably can we go triple it's
open.
I think we should play it.
I think we should play Mantis, Adam, Invis and then should I
play?
Well, I play.
Alright.
You know, I'll play Mantis.
Yeah, I think you go Mantis.
I think on this map we try this.
Next map we can go full dive.
If it's the open map, it's pretty bad for Arco.
Or Sound guy, quick!
Quick!
Fix this!
Fix this Sound guy!
I'm sorry!
I think you got Adam though.
You can go Cloak as well.
I gotta fix this!
I messed up!
I think Loki Cloak is better.
Go Cloak.
Instead of Adam.
I will bring...
Yeah.
Okay.
Do the team up solid.
Yeah.
Just saying.
All right.
Okay.
If they play Hella anymore, I'm just gonna match their
Hella.
Yeah.
People's always fun.
Just red.
You need to see.
Okay.
Can we break this?
Yeah, what they have?
Oh, pause.
My FTP actually.
Actually, pause.
Sound guy, you're saved.
Fix this.
Do you want me to do an old truck and old stuff?
No, no.
Fix this now.
We're paused.
I'll ask.
I'll ask for her.
I'll always ask after ult every fight and then I'll make a
plan for the next one.
All right.
I lowered.
I lowered it.
I lowered the discord and then we'll fix it later.
Let's see it.
Melio internet.
not good
wait do I do initiate confirmation or wait for them wait for
them you gotta wait for them I can't click continue but I
don't want to do that I can also initiate it too we can
initiate confirmation I
mean this is kind of weird to be honest sound got fixed no
are we saving the dive for the second day can't fix the game
we can go dive after this i just think on this map we can't
really play dive oh i knew something was weird i mean we can
take above them but it's like still super i hope you guys
could have heard me i think uh what did we last bend again
in this i guess i guess i mean that's a good last bend
they're gonna be on loki cloak sorry i just didn't know how
to read all right i've lowered the discord i don't think
they will go i think cloak is better i'll lower that discord
and one who figures this out yeah very important is when
they have cloak and we play full dive is that we like
respect each cloak we can we can't kill through so we just
like in this matchup we can but in the full dive i don't
think we do yeah don't we just play for rocker yeah yeah
sorry guys i'm illiterate i can't stop to have to protect
moxie i just know it starts with virgin and then i don't
know how it goes after don't worry more pressure is good it
makes you lock in more right
may need to be a bit lower all right i lowered it even more
there you go i don't know i'm not american already yeah
we're good
I think that's it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Keep me damage boosted.
That's good.
We have increased pressure.
The Hella, Neymar's going to play.
Yeah, I'm playing Hella on the right.
Wait, I want him.
I want him.
No big wall.
Can we walk?
Two, one.
Kill thing, kill thing, kill thing.
Yes.
Thing one, thing one, thing one.
Hello me.
No way.
Go on.
Yeah.
Oh, think it's low.
Think it's low.
We can chase him.
Pink is one.
Yeah, just wait.
All right.
I mean, just.
Go bunk up.
Go bunk on point.
Okay.
Yeah.
Can you, can you deny it?
I can match.
Yeah, I can match.
Yeah.
But I want to deny it early if they take high ground.
I'm scouting that side.
I don't see anyone coming down.
I think they go high.
Yeah, they go high.
They have Hella.
They have Hella no more.
They saw Hella no more.
We can play the Booper, I think.
Okay.
They're having walked out.
What the fuck are they doing?
I hear a main.
They're all dead.
Main, main, main.
Hella top.
Okay.
I have a...
Break lamps.
I have a Hakao.
Okay.
Neema going bottom left.
Can someone match?
Yeah, I can't, I can't.
Match him, match him, match him, match him, match him.
Just Hella main on me.
Yeah.
Breaking switch.
i'm holding i'm holding i'm breaking big wall big wall dead
i have i have the little orb for you name one name one one
yeah okay i can keep it for hell if you want to be burning
actually i'm gonna keep it for good actually i'm gonna keep
it No, I think we get, I think we need to get Glocal for
Grutals.
I'm 83 right now.
Yeah, play for Grutals.
Glocal.
Nice.
He's one.
Just chill.
Just wait.
No.
I have it.
I use it for Grutal.
I'll use it for Grutal.
Just wait.
Yep.
Wolf is coming.
Wolf right side.
I can eat Grutal probably.
Can we deny Wolf?
Right side.
Can we walk into him?
Looks like I'm in the wrong way.
Wolf's up and up.
No, no.
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
I hit the back up.
Hey the wolf, get the wolf!
Kill the wolf on the right, wolf on the right!
One, one, one, one, one.
He's gonna name all.
He's gonna name all, yes.
Yeah, I want to hold aggressive here to call something.
Yeah.
A kill, kill the wolf.
We have one, the wolf one.
We're ready.
They were there.
Three, two, one.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I'm not even leaving.
Nope.
I have to leave.
Yeah, yeah.
I have to leave because I'm mad.
We killed.
Just killed.
We got you.
Let's go.
We don't cover much.
Live it.
I touch.
Just live.
I'm one.
I'm dead.
Oh, you're dead.
I'm always like a mental.
It's like a mental assault.
Yeah.
Maybe the RP can kill you.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I think we die.
Yeah.
They have marked them.
They have nothing.
I think we go high ground and we just drop on them with
mental assault.
All right.
Don't think we need more.
They don't have any more ult.
Yeah.
They have no more ult.
They have a name.
Okay.
They stack up and walk up together.
Use both support ults.
I'm pretty sure.
I think we just go with his net.
It's not.
Can we just go left?
Okay.
I think we go top, go top.
Come on.
Go top.
Yeah, I'm the last one.
I'm the last one.
Here, wait, we're going.
We're going.
Go top, go top and then drop on Nebuchadnezzar.
You have to go left or right?
Left, left, left, left.
They're gonna flip.
They have Luna now.
Go drop on them.
Oh, mid.
Come on, come, come.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Oh, there's more apps.
I blind the...
I blind my egg.
Where's Chris left?
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Oh, he's right.
No more, no more.
I actually need to win.
Yeah, it's really good.
I blinded.
I still have Cloak ult.
Thanks, we did it.
Go to Adam.
Go dive now.
Surprise them.
I go dive with Cap, I think.
Do I stay Cloak or we lose all of them?
I think we stay for ult.
Okay.
If the inside map, it's good for Hawkeye too.
The outside is really bad.
Actually, just stay all together, I think.
Yeah, I think we still.
I only go Angela.
Wait, oh wait, is Discord better sound guy?
Give me one second.
Yeah, yeah.
What did Craigie's team get last Bougar Bash?
What placement was he?
30 seconds before you attack?
I think last.
Oh, wait.
Six, six places.
I think it was fifth or sixth.
Oh, yeah.
Six places, I think.
I think Nevix got last and also.
No.
I don't know.
I mean, Nevix team was kind of cooked.
I think they're like 60 on Groot.
Yeah, I might just keep my ult for him.
Okay.
I mean, I have my ult.
Yeah, I mean, I'll try to do it if I don't use it.
Oh yeah, okay.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
I can play it to hit.
We should let that Groot walk up though.
Let them walk up through the choke, okay?
I hit when they're a tanker touching point.
They go dive too.
Yeah, they have Jeff.
They have Hawkeye.
They have Hawkeye main.
Yeah, we can push Hawkeye and then we can close.
That's my friend.
Thanks.
Shark is in top right.
Random half.
Okay, Jeff.
Okay, I'm on Jeff.
Yeah, I'm going Hawkeye.
Two, one.
Hawkeye in.
Kill Hawkeye.
Can you cloak out and you push Hawkeye?
Yeah, I'll cloak out right now.
I'll push back then.
Oh, they do not.
Okay, Hawkeye.
Don't get me.
Oh, I tried.
Oh, you got res.
Yeah, I didn't realize you got res.
I was trying to get out.
Back then, no.
I break, I break bubble.
I can't.
I need to go back.
I'm one, I'm one.
I kill Venom, Venom one.
It's winnable, it's winnable.
I can always after.
He's dead after.
He didn't get anyone.
Two, one, just one.
Winnable, winnable, winnable.
Just play slow.
We will stop.
No, no, no, wait.
They're off Venom.
They're on Angela.
They're Angela's coming back.
Live it right now.
Wait a minute.
I'm just living.
They're off.
Rocker 100.
Rocker real one.
Micah, I'm fine.
Rocha, heck okay.
Just hit.
Just hit, just hit, just hit.
I shoot a Hawkeye, 2, 1.
Hawkeye, it's out, feel.
Hawkeye, Hawkeye right, Hawkeye, Hawkeye, hotter right.
I'm chilling.
Get them a headshot.
Get a headshot.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
I got you.
I go grab someone, ready?
Three, two, one.
I should good for next Yes.
One on against one.
Yeah.
Two, one.
I'm not with you, no, it's just me.
I can't.
I'm glad it's Tor.
No, no rest.
We're close to defensive holds.
I'm dead.
Okay, one.
Point, point, point, point, point, point.
I can't, I can't.
Go next fight.
I'm just living by them.
I tried to shield.
Can I go Tor here?
Low key, Tophie.
After my health.
Can you lift?
I'm behind them.
Just lift.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yeah, I'm good.
I can go rocket whenever.
Yeah, wait a minute.
Better go.
Ready?
We're going.
I'm going.
Not going.
Rocket one.
I can't.
I'm playing slow.
I need hiding.
Oh, my God.
I couldn't react in time.
Can't break.
Go back.
I can get the old moxie.
Just chill, just chill.
And they use...
Go group up.
Rocket off, rocket off guys.
You should try to swap to rocket after.
Okay, I'm set up on the model then.
No, no, no, no.
After all, after all.
Because I'm quotes.
Might go back on DDO, whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna use my...
There's a Tor mark here.
There's a Tor mark.
I'll go in the corner.
I'll kill me too, actually.
This is a super ace.
Because you want to go?
You want to go?
I'm just dead.
I can't even do anything against him.
Am I going?
I'm killing.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
No.
I'm spamming it.
Can your ult?
Can you ult?
Yeah, I can.
I can.
I'm trying to get...
No!
I'm just trying.
I'm trying to leave.
Three cells, one.
Three cells, three cells, three, three.
That's fine.
I'm over.
Angel low.
Maybe we would have lucky.
There we are.
Angel lift.
Huck I want.
I hit him too.
One.
I see where my Twitch.
Mac, Mac, Mac, Mac.
He has to hold.
He's off the map.
Ah, we got Backland.
Backland hit.
All hit, all hit.
I'm on Liran.
Only Rocket, only Rocket.
Only Rocket support.
Come on, I'm on.
Yeah, I'm on it.
You'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
I'm back with Holt in five seconds.
Rocket one, rocket one, rocket one.
I can't even point, I'm on point.
But the rocket's on me.
or not rocket thores on me it's okay do these like moving
walls like had had we have like no angles pretty useless
though I don't even know mag with our mag I think we go full
dive I think we go underline I go cap I actually think that
I think we need to go Jeffy I will we need like some damage
on the backline anyone Any additional damage there kills
them, by the way.
We just take map control and we just take it.
Think of Phoenix, Moxie, or Starlord, or Ciloc, or anything
that can shoot the enemy.
Yeah, just shoot them.
Not Spider-Man.
Destroy Rocket.
No, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
This matchup is good.
I don't know how I could dodge that hot guy.
I, like, I like save, try to save ult, too, and then he
still killed me.
Go this.
I think Phoenix is good.
I think this is definitely better.
We have to play this.
Go away.
I go around.
I can scout.
What ulcer do they have?
They probably have...
They probably have rock floor, yeah.
They have full.
They have Luna.
Luna and main.
I can develop for the Luna.
Ignore everyone and just go for Luna, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hit background soon.
I can go.
Nora's beacon.
You want to go?
You want to go.
Can you lift?
They're all going up.
Yeah, I'm chilling.
I'm better going.
I'm dead.
Aren't they all dead?
We have a rez.
He's on point alone.
Good one, good one, good one.
Need to lift, need to lift.
Go next right, go next right.
Alright.
It's a good action.
Go next, go next right.
Can we kill the...
Oh, shit, too.
And two, three, two, three, two, two, two, three, and two,
one.
Just wait.
Oh, ho, ho.
Rocket.
Rocket, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Need to wait.
I can hit them soon.
I'm looking for a beacon again.
Yeah.
I go around.
I go top.
They're in main.
They're all in main.
I can hit them.
They're on point.
They're like left side.
They're left side.
Can we go?
Wait, max on me.
Max on me.
I'm going.
Luna low.
I need to play.
I'm ready to play.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, one,
rocket one.
Oh, we can't.
Lift, lift, lift, lift, lift in.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket,
rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
I can't.
And I'm just dead.
I can't move.
Yeah, mag flank this from behind.
Save no heals, save no heals, save no heals.
I'm back in three seconds.
We have rocket ult.
We can maybe play it.
Maybe next way, next way, next way, next way, next way, next
way.
They have four, they have mag.
They're on Starlord now.
Just wait, just wait.
They're on Starlord.
You're on Starlord.
You're ready for it.
Thanks for the boost.
Just great, just great.
You should have a hard time stopping our development.
Just play slow in main.
You just have two people in main and just play slow.
Don't need hard development.
Only three people.
I go back line.
Luna on me.
Can you come?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Luna, one, Luna one, Luna one.
Red, rescue on the way, way, way.
I can't, I can't.
Oh, okay.
They left.
Okay, nice.
Just two, just chill.
Good, good, good.
Kill the four, kill the four.
We should have a bot.
We have two nil or...
Good thing no.
Yeah, not cloak.
They should have a lot to just shoot us.
We should just play slow.
We can go with rocket ult on point when they want power.
walk up okay they're walking right they're walking right i
see six right i see six right yeah i can really deny it i
can't really deny it we need to wait until they drop we need
to wait until they drop yeah yeah i can i'm about to go on
their backlash trust me they're like isolated right side i'm
about to go right now i go free i don't know me they're
going for a res because i don't care they're feeling they
look like i can't can't i broke my res i have to broke my
res angela was on looking for it i go i'm gonna stop i'm
gonna stop i'm gonna stop i'm gonna go back in with Yeah, I
need help.
I need help.
Can they look at him?
Okay, break it.
Break it.
Okay, good, good, good.
Live it.
Do we have anything?
Oh, come on.
Cook it.
Just live.
Rocket it.
There's no heals.
Just wait.
I hit back then.
I want someone.
I touch.
I'm very much.
Kill a thing.
Kill thing.
Thing, thing, thing, thing.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back now.
Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor.
Tor, one, one, one.
Can't, can't, can't kill Angela instead.
Angela, one, two, one.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I can force Gokul here.
Okay, they can, just chill, just chill, just chill.
Okay, they have Gokul.
They have Gokul.
They use Rokul.
Yeah, we need to force it early.
Can we go?
Yeah, yeah, they're going.
Yeah, they're right side.
They're like main right side.
Two, one, going in.
I'm on rocket.
I'm on rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Yeah, I'm going on, I'm going on.
Live it, live it, live it.
You want rocket.
I see rocket.
I can go rocket.
Okay, okay, rocket.
Don't rocket.
Rocket one.
Don't die.
Just live.
No bubble.
Don't go bubble.
I need help.
Come to me.
Look back there.
I got hit.
Rocket one.
I left.
They died.
Nice.
Just chill.
I'm rest.
I'm not rest.
Oh, they see nine.
They see nine.
Nice.
Need to try to kite better there.
The path thing, like the cloacal, the only goal is to kill
you there, Doki.
You should play to lift.
Go on the wall, go high and try to lift.
I think the map like fucked their cloacal.
I didn't even see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They were so bad.
They were so far away.
Oh my god.
This is hell.
There are like mutual fights that we need to look over.
The definitely first fight was kind of cooked.
We need one guy in main that just hours from the rocket We
need all of the rocket to be able to play in main so we get
the peers to push their back line and our Angela should also
play Toward main because you want to play to scoop only me
Jeff and should I just be shooting out the Angela like the
whole game For sure you just need to dish out damage so you
create opportunity I think I think I hate that I think I
hate it I don't know I think I saw you guys dive in the I
think I hate dive
That's pretty I mean dive is great for people who kid dab
but Bro, I hate dive Bro, he just goes four Yeah, I was on I
was on like three different roles.
He was on yeah, they started Jeff and then went Guys, I
think dive is fun I don't know.
It's just a crazy theory.
It's kind of crazy.
The door's pretty good into our comp spoken like a true NA
player.
Me and name, me one bra, me one unga bunga.
Me one safety from my tanks.
Me, me, me one safety and sit in back and go ha ha here.
I think Drew is, I think Drew's hired to play against.
Me and name, me no thing.
I think so too.
I think he uses me for the kind of stuff you felt and then
uses like...
Yeah, I think so too.
safe we can go torch thing if we want play dive hey you want
to i play no no no no bro i do i do it i did that show with
vinnie one game it's actually not bad if i'm not expecting
it yeah
definitely need better priority yeah first sprawl is stall
game and poke is just boring it may be boring but i get to
live it's just very risky against hawker hawker is such a
cloak punish i get to be alive yeah they're about to get
headshot it's very easy no no we can't bend it we should i'm
saying they're gonna bend it maybe yeah but me no die it is
a good spider-man map but yeah wait you don't trust moxie
you don't trust him why why are you so against the
spider-man here yeah because i played with you in the rank
game yeah but then then speed like one it was like half a
cough around her you looked it looked like decent look at
the air he's good enough bro said decent bro you know what
it means i thought you picked moxie for for his spider-man
yeah is it not we did pick him we did pick him for
spider-man yeah it's my second most played this season also
are we ready yeah we're ready i just remember one time guru
yelled at you because you were playing spider-man wait
didn't you actually had an o5 at one point i think i was
playing i think i was playing human torch oh yeah i remember
the the last time i tuned on your stream when you're playing
spider-man you actually had an o5 record it was crazy and
then you were like um guys it's actually oh nine yeah it's
not necessarily always the score is not that's fake which
hero do you think you want to be today all right this is a
good hawkeye map just saying yeah yeah it's crazy he was
like um guys it's actually oh now and he's like they were
like a final push on the spotter map this on this exact map
and then he was like he was like guys my The entire team has
two kills.
It doesn't mean nothing.
That hero is Thanos.
Yeah.
Okay.
Loki, can you play Loki or something?
Are there one of them?
Yeah.
Yeah, I can play.
Okay, I'll go.
Where are you from, Vinny?
You're actually so fake.
It's actually fake.
Wait, do you think so fake?
It is so fake.
It is so fake, you know?
I was thinking the same thing.
It's insane.
Wait, where?
I'm Spanish.
Spanish.
Are you from Spain?
No, no me hablo espanol.
I told you he's so fucking German.
Bro, where are you from?
You sound like you don't exist.
That's the thing I learned in class.
That's crazy.
I did like four years of German and I don't remember
anything.
Yeah, it's funny.
You don't sound real.
I'm sure everyone's gonna have AI anyway.
Yeah, I'm kind of like hard German to be honest.
But yeah.
I need to, and Phoenix here again, no?
come down a little bit all right i came if i lowered their
volume a little more hawkeye moxie they both buy phoenix
just saying guys i saved jeff again by the way i'll go i
need to because we we gotta hope they don't ban fucking
hawkeye there's no way we can they have melio his hawkeye's
crazy too what else can we ban I mean, Invis again?
I think Invis is good.
I think it's either Invis or Namur probably.
No, I think let them name or it's not that good.
Maybe on that map actually.
Yeah, Invis is good.
Invis is good, Ben, I think.
I think I like this.
I actually like this.
I mean, that's fine too.
I think this is very hard for them to play now.
They're gonna go Invis though, but I think for us...
I'll be on Invis Loki.
For us, I want Jeff.
I need Jeff.
because they can ban any tank in the game we can still play
the game so it's like we're quite flexible can say the same
about the enemy whoa you don't think they're flexible
shots who is the most unflexible player on that team oh yeah
trust me yeah call them out besides them raider i mean this
is the situation no we have angela and venom know questions
who wants to play what i mean we could also play deadpool
with venom i think that i want to try that with venom was op
i think so yeah i think it's strong i think i just pushed
backland and we just kill them all they don't they have
inverse loki most likely yeah i think so i think if we get
jeff set up then it's very hard for them to defend it
question is what does moxie go spider-man i can you can hawk
i feel like hawk is just i hockey snooky like you cannot
play it i think it's rocket chef again yeah i think okay or
spider-man we could go we could go where you go spider-man i
believe in his spider-man i definitely
okay okay do one life one life definitely you want to play
triple tank triple support okay every character open that
makes it good uh do you want me to use the double team ups
when you dive or you just use it for myself yeah we can use
it in the enemy backline if you want but you should use it
for yourself and for uh hawkeye maybe like it depends on
where you are it's quick they have three i think they're
they have like phoenix loki they're gonna have triple tank
at them i think i can go go around i can't go around okay
i'm looking i'm looking up one adam adam adam adam adam one
come on loki my loki uh am i Okay, let's farm.
Go back.
Oh, I got one shot.
Yeah.
And we're pushing fine.
I can go again.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm throwing my orbs out.
They have triple tank, triple support.
We need to swap.
Yeah, you need to swap.
Yeah, you need to swap Moxie.
You need swap.
Swap to Bucky?
Spiderman?
I think Wolf actually.
I think Wolf.
Wolf.
Play to punish, play to punish.
I can go back then again.
I don't think they have lamps yet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait a minute.
Hey, I can go.
I can go.
Three, two, one.
Kill a man.
We play two lives, play to hit.
We low they are going.
All bottom, all bottom.
I have another cooldown soon.
We have one on there too much.
We played to lift, played to hit, played to hit.
Artim 1, out of 1.
They're down, they're down to support.
No, Ray, Z is gonna risk.
They only have atom kills.
All right, all.
Thank you, man.
Mag one.
Mag, Mag.
I can blink.
Mag one.
Mag one, Mag one.
Sigma one, Emma one.
I can die WPix.
I have...
I'm 22 old.
He died.
I'm going to ult first model, okay?
Okay.
I want to go early into them with my ult.
Okay, yeah, I'm looking out, looking out.
Yeah, yeah, I want to go now.
They're walking left, they're walking left.
Can we do it now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're inside the room.
You're walled.
You're walled, you're walled.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Adam, Adam, Adam.
Do we get rest?
I'm just kidding.
Yeah, you get rid of you guys.
Nice nice.
Adam, Adam behind.
Adam here.
Adam, go on point, go on point, go on point.
Adam, resume.
No, he's right.
He's just chilling.
No, no, no, no.
He's chilling.
Nice, nice.
Always try to go early.
Yeah, that's huge that they use.
I don't think no.
Yeah, that's that's good.
That's good.
We can just set up top right.
You can swap back moxie.
Yeah, I'll swap after all.
I think go with my old bedevil then.
They're walking me.
They're walking me right now.
Can you go early?
I'm going three, two, one, one.
Lucky one.
Can you lift?
I'll grab the grab.
Yeah, I live, I live, I live, I live, I live.
We lost Jeff.
There is a Adam.
I don't want point.
I can rehab too.
I'm on point.
Lucky one.
Everyone, give someone.
Nice.
Emma, Emma, Emma, one.
Emma one, Emma one.
Cap point, cap one.
Yep, I'm sure.
Yeah, Adam should have res.
Loki won.
Loki won, dead.
Just chill, just chill.
Just chill.
I hit the fallout after.
Get ready.
Look Emma, look Emma.
Look Emma.
Go, go, go.
I know, I know.
I just contest.
I'm with you.
You want me to ult, or no?
Yeah, you can ult just.
Okay.
I'm on.
I'm pushing up to Alphas.
Oh, no.
I almost hit him.
I don't want.
I don't want him.
Oh, fuck.
No lamp, no lamps.
I have four lamps.
Yeah, we can kill that.
We can kill.
We can kill that.
Yeah.
Face popping.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm living.
Emma's still port.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
I got it.
Oh, come.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma,
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, back one, back one, back one, back
one, back one, back one, back one.
Can I go back to work?
Yeah, thing on me.
Thing on me.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
This is the Diddy all right.
I want Loki...
I'm on point, thing on point!
I'm on one, I'm on the one... one, I'm just one, Liv, Liv!
Loki on the outside.
I can, I can't, I can't.
Do we have anything to do?
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good.
I can go back in with DDO in one.
I can push Ryu at two, one, push in.
Nmossi, Mossi, Mossi, Mossi.
Loogi one!
Oh.
One, looky, look.
One, looky.
Fine.
All one, all one.
Lucha, all one, Lucha!
Emma!
Emma quit!
Emma quit.
Shoot her, shoot her, she's on!
Come on, black one.
Ah!
No res, no res, no res.
No res.
Breast in one?
Yeah, try to chill, try to chill, try to chill.
I need to group up, need to group up.
Next fight.
You need to lift?
It's good, it's okay.
They have goats.
I think they went, like, all three.
Like, I mean, I think they use all three support Yeah, they
did their tank.
Yeah, honestly.
Just wait.
I'm on Adam, Adam's twirling on me.
I hit soon.
I break the Loki clones.
I killed him.
I'm gonna go.
I'm going far right.
I hit Loki.
Two, one.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam!
Adam that.
I'm back.
Yeah.
Oh, no!
This is real.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam.
I kill Invis, kill Invis.
Okay, Invis one, Invis one.
Can, can, can, can, can, can, can this.
Can you look?
Yeah, I can.
I'll kill him.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Look at it.
Play in my ult.
I need care.
I'm on my server.
You're fine.
You're back here.
We need you alive.
I'm on Ibis.
We got point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
In this one, in this one.
Is anyone's lagging or just me?
Just you.
Instead of lagging, I guess it's me.
Too many cooldowns in the back then.
They have Bucky now.
We can just...
Yeah, fresh Bucky.
They're playing Torantella.
Thor Venom.
It should be fine.
You want to go early?
I'm set up.
I'm set up for the character.
Yeah, I can go early.
I'm on point.
I'll stay on card.
You should raise.
You should keep it.
Very good.
Angela's on point.
Don't die.
Just live.
Yeah, I'm tired.
I'm tired.
No res.
I'm fine.
I'm back.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor.
Thor.
I'm with you in a second.
Just wait.
I'm checking my oils.
Yeah, I'm trying to help you.
I got team moving.
I got team one.
I got you one.
Back you one.
Nice.
Just lift.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm living.
Don't worry.
The cart's coming over.
I hit him too.
Ready?
I got I got a hog out.
I have all here too.
Oh, one.
Oh, one, oh.
Focus on John.
You're going to win one.
Invis will bring one.
Oh, you don't get res.
You don't get res.
Throw one, throw one, throw one.
Throw one, throw one.
Come out, come out.
I go through it, I go through it.
I go through it.
I have ult here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna reload again.
I'm gonna reload here.
Yeah, you can reload.
Can we pause it?
Yeah.
That's it, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that,
that, that, that, that, that, Invis, Invis, Invis, Invis.
Yeah, multi, multi, multi, multi, all's gone, all's gone.
Yeah, Invis, Invis.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Door have.
Door one, door one, door one, door one.
Door one, door one, door one.
Wait, there's a silo behind him.
Cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
I hook cap, cap, cap, cap.
Cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
Four, four, four, four, four, four, four, four, four, four.
I need help.
Four, four, four, four, four.
I killed the back then.
I'm breaking, break, break, break, break.
Top one, top one, top one, top one.
Back to all, back to all, I can't move.
I'm gonna look back then.
I'm looking, I'm on lowkey.
I can't.
I'm looking back.
I'm on Logie, I'm on Logie, I'm on Logie.
I'm going down.
Use them.
I'm on back then.
Angel one.
Look you one.
Look you have rest.
I have one.
I'm stacking.
Look you one.
Look you dead.
I'm ulting.
Keep me up.
Oh no.
I'm staying on.
I have to be on.
That's okay.
It's okay.
Scylip one.
It's like all one.
That's okay.
We need damage for the Angela.
I think if you go name out there, we just wipe the points.
You just need more resistance.
You need to hit the enemy tanks that are on points.
What is that?
What does the most damage on points?
Back to Wolf there, I guess.
You don't want me on Star Lord, I don't think.
Star Lord, maybe.
I can go Emma if you want.
Go triple now.
Go triple.
I think go triple.
Yeah, let's speed go.
what do we go triple with with that thing we go we go
annoying triple we go dive triple it should be very hard for
them to deny it you're gonna play angie yeah i think that
i'll play angie and db go veni and i think we get jeff and
what is it us mantis mantis jeff i guess venom or am i well
go adam go go adam go adam oxy well i'll have a first time
in it basically you want to do any other support that has
better you want to do rocky support that is different you
can go mantis can go anything just need to go quick all
right very important guys play for cycles okay we hit then
we get out we hit we get out i need uptime with jeff okay we
need uptime with jeff and uptime with rocket don't get
pushed just play infinite range and just heal okay you guys
should be unkillable the battle starts in five four three
three Jesus.
Dave, Si, Si.
And they have Si Salv, Si .
Sa Tolossi.
Si on the left.
Got him left.
Let me know when you want to go, Tress.
Si going around.
I need to deny it.
Captain on us, too.
S ops, Si.
Si, Si SLIP, Si, Sisi, Sisi.
21, 2, 1, 1, 2, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
I'm lucky rocket.
Just play to touch point.
Just play.
Two there.
We'll see there.
I need a turret.
I need a HEAL.
I mean, he'll heal.
Just two, just read.
just wait there's siren they're i'm on point there one point
yeah i was going united i'm dealing with you when you're
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
You should get reds.
Okay, they can, can, can, can, can.
They're on the wall now.
They're on wall.
One, two, one.
I'm on two, I'm on two, I'm on two, I'm on two.
I can, I can, I can, I can.
I can, I can, I can.
I'm on two.
I'm on, I'm on.
Guy going in with the plate, guys.
Oh no, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
We're down on support.
Side one, side one, side one, side one, side one, one, one,
one, one, one, one, one, one, No passive.
Sank, Sank, Sank, Sank, Sank.
I won.
Make it.
Break it, break it, break it, break it, break it, break it,
break it, break it, break it, I'm out, I'm out, I'm out, I'm
out, I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
It's good, it's good.
Kite it, Kite it, Kite it, Kite it, Kite it, get out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need K, I need K, though.
Oh, I'm dead, I think.
Okay.
If you just slim in, I can maybe help you.
No, I can't.
I'm fine.
I'll just die card.
They use everything.
They only have Sai and caps.
Yeah.
Sai will just going to be a problem.
Wait, this cap is low.
I almost killed him.
We can go back to Td now, I think.
Yeah, I will, I will.
I will.
Sai is all to do.
I'll just say one for all.
I can alter back one.
They don't have any support .
Just combine.
I'm pushing Sai.
Ready?
Need?
Can we look back with my ult?
You look back on my ult?
I'm back with my ult.
Yeah, I'm going.
Ready?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Three, two, one.
Oh.
Swear, shwear, shwear, shwear, shwear.
Things left.
This one.
Cive, I need care.
I can't kill it.
Just live.
Yeah, I'm living.
Can we have...
Vinnie, can you hold your life?
I dive.
I'm on.
Sive.
mens.
Okay.
I got rocket.
Wolf, wolf, wolf, wolf.
Sive's gonna have all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look at wolf.
No, no, she's used, she used.
They don't.
They don't fight.
Kill side together.
Yeah, yeah.
We got touch.
Walk on side.
No cooldowns, okay?
Yeah, I'm on side.
I'm on side.
Oh, you're probably dead.
I'm getting like ball.
Yeah, you don't have res here.
It's okay.
I'm in the back.
I'm in.
I'm trying to help you.
Stay in the place.
Keep going.
Yeah, we're all covered.
Yeah.
We have one res.
In this, in this.
Oh, I got wall vaulted too.
No, no.
I'm good.
I'm on rocket.
I can't I can't solve with my own rocket one rocket one
rocket one rocket I got a miss.
Nice.
I can't.
I'm window on one roll.
They have no heals.
They have no heals guys.
No more.
Wolf no cooldown.
Come on.
I'm out.
I can go back then.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm on.
Rocket, rocket.
Shoot that.
Break it.
It's one.
I threw it.
One, one, one, one, one.
Yeah, Wolf one, Wolf one.
No more, no more, no more.
Linking points, I'm linking points, I'm linking points,
think, think, think, think, think, think.
I'm off the map, I think.
I'm dead.
I got me.
We can win, we can win, we can win.
I have mine, I have mine.
I have mine.
They're TPing back.
They have one healers.
No healers.
That's here.
One one, one.
That's cool.
They have no healers.
They have no heals.
They have started TP now.
They started TP now.
I'm throwing my thing.
I'm blinking point.
Cep one, Cep one, Cep one, Cep one.
There's Red.
Change, change, change, change, change.
Back soon, back soon.
We're here.
I want, I want, I want, I want, I want.
Cep one, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep,
Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep, Cep.
One, two, one.
Wolf one, wolf one.
Wolf one.
I'm grabbed.
Oh, I'm robbed.
It's over.
Nice.
Let's go.
DJs.
Told you, bro.
Safety first.
You're strong.
Yes, you're so close.
Another epic victory.
Big win.
Oh my god.
Is this what winning feels like?
Someone said duck needs lessons.
Oh my god.
I'm literally like brain off just just rocket brain off
right click brain off shoot gun right click brain pray chuck
res throw res right click all Yes, thank you for the 20
gifted shares.
Thank you.
We're playing next.
Guys, please.
Cap.
Cap and Venom.
Playing Kovacs.
Bro, am I not a...
That's crazy that I'm only known for that.
I used to be a Mac player.
I guess not anymore though.
Yeah, what are...
You're now a Deadpool player.
True, but you need to aim on that hero too.
Oh, yeah, I'm just...
I'm just a shadow.
I'm like the puppet.
Trust me.
It's the one controlling me.
I'm just a puppet leader.
The rest of my team is the Illuminati.
I literally exist to be like the pretty face of the team.
To be the woman of the team.
Trust me, it's the Illuminati.
I'm the president.
We will start banning Jeff, I think.
Yeah, I think so too.
The timers have the timers in the eye again.
I probably have to watch what happened on the third point.
We need to have better target prior there.
they can stall the point forever they had zero support sub
we need to have better target pro it took five minutes to
kill the personal point i think it was angela touching oh i
know like the psy was like shooting uh whiny and me on the
side the entire time it was like one inch field then because
i think this is the tournament if there's a solo psy lock
and we have very mobile all we need to do is just three men
walk into the guy and he just always has to give space and
then he can never set up late you know so we need to
properly push him more of the especially when we have mobile
characters if we have slow characters then we need to play
to hit survive the hit but um if we have this characters we
need to walk into a more apparently i see captain beat sk's
team and wait there's a third map i thought it was like best
did you no it's just best of three yeah it's ggs already
flats and terrors still playing wait let us know when we're
ready for yeah yeah but they they uh forcing us to the third
map what what do you say oh wait i thought it's best of
three unless we play the third map unless it's like i guess
like for day two it's high breaker maybe like i don't know
maybe day two is best as three maybe i would rules wrong i
guess Best of free, but all maps will be played.
Oh, okay.
So we have to play this map.
Okay.
So it doesn't matter if we lose?
No, it doesn't.
It's just to determine the seating.
So it's like a tiebreaker thing, I think.
Yeah, I feel like there's every team that's 2-0 or whatever,
3-0, and it'll base on the third map wins as well.
Yeah.
All right, are we all here?
yep okay ready
I'm just scouting out my opponents right now to see this is
a great spider-man maps defense just saying what is it I
didn't see oh my god it's a great spider-man defense the
signature trust me go spider-man first point defense try to
pull someone off jump off the map and come back on venom it
is the signature for that it actually is we need to ban it
it's also a good it's also a good hawkeye map if if the
hitscans are banned and likely so okay i think maybe mantis
safe also plaques team beat kg's team uh yeah not surprised
that's team is pretty good i think it's the second best team
i think cypress team is maybe a little bit better i'm not
sure cypress team is losing too Yeah, I think they're
losing.
Yeah, the Jade 3 team.
I mean, Jade 3 team is not bad, no?
Yeah, it's not bad.
It's not bad team.
Phoenix save.
Interesting.
This is a question now.
This is like an annoying situation.
Because now we have to take Invis.
Invis Mantis, I guess.
Need to try to beat it.
Definitely have to ban Mantis.
I'm not playing against Phoenix damage boost.
I don't really mind playing against Invis on, I mean, just
in general.
No, no, no.
We just ban it.
We just go Hawkeye now, because they're going to have to
play Loki cloak into.
Yeah, that works too.
Super 8s.
Mantis plan is good.
I like those plans from them, abusing it.
It's not Batman's.
This might be the Winnie Deadpool situation.
Maybe we have to first save.
Maybe we actually have to first save Jeff.
in the future.
I want to try it.
Why don't you play another match?
Yeah, I know, I know, but like, I feel like Jeff is more
important to the dive than DD.
Really?
I think Jeff enables the dive.
I mean, I think the problem with that is like the second
best dive DPS is like Scythe lock and like that shit is...
Yeah, I know it's still... Star lore is not like, but like
Daredevil is like... Yeah.
I could bend this.
Can we just go Groot, no?
Do we just go Groot Deadpool, maybe?
Both?
can go good if you want i'm thinking i i've never tried it
because rajav doesn't really play good that much i mean he
does good that's cool i don't think he's i mean actually
maybe something i mean i don't know i don't know the theory
you play it as a like a disrupt maybe no just like the
annoying i think we go triple though i think we go cloak
inverse and
deadpool yeah we can try that oh yeah let's try it with that
250 or do i have more like i think i think you can go hybrid
like uh that pool and dd oh that's bad haki yeah i have to
like play in super super save i have to play into phoenix
and he's just gonna have every every fight is just gonna
have phoenix so it's so it's a long time how do we stop it
though the phoenix still we can't we can't really stop it i
think we just don't give a just gotta cloak shift it to be
honest oh okay well i'll try i'll try yeah i need to play
group what wait we're confident i think we played dd and
deadpool no i think so hybrid hybrid though yeah i think so
all right that's fine yeah i think we can go cap two we can
go cap two yeah yeah yeah
TD more.
I can't ever want to do this one.
Just play this.
It's fine.
Okay.
Okay, we don't have that many missions.
If nothing works, we go back full dive.
We go back full dive.
They have Angela.
Yeah, I see a Hela with, like, three low-key clones top
right under Angela there.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, no more top left.
No more top left for now.
Yeah, yeah.
I can contest the blade in.
I'm going to go with this no more, okay?
Ready?
Yeah, I'm going to run.
One, one, one, one, one, one, one.
I gave you an orb.
Kenny, Kenny, Kenny, Kenny.
They're on top right.
They're down.
They're down Loki, by the way.
Oh, I got one.
Hello one.
Hello on top right.
Top right.
He's one.
He's wearing no heels.
No heels.
I'm looking one.
Nice.
Shoot Angela.
Angela, Angela, Angela.
You guys are down too.
There's a hell is still behind us.
Oh my god.
She is.
I can go on Hella.
Can I can I can behind behind behind behind?
Come back.
Next.
There's three servers there.
There's TP.
They TP.
Okay.
I think so.
They're gonna be close to close.
Okay, they have no TP.
I have no ult.
I can play for my ult, right?
No squids.
I can push the enemy Hella, okay?
I'm not here yet.
Yeah, he's on main.
He's on main.
Bottom right.
I better walk.
I can go whenever.
Okay, can we look?
better go bad guy three two one i'm on lucky you two need to
go back you need to go back you need to go back
so he's out he's out he's out he walked away watch out first
me or
Hello, no bird, top right.
I see her.
I'll kill her.
You can move whatever.
Okay.
Yes, Angel.
Angel, I'm using her inside.
Yeah, I can pop Nimro.
I better go behind them.
Can we go?
Three, two, one, three.
I can go.
Kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it.
It's left.
It's up, it's up, it's up, it's up.
It's up.
Yeah.
I'm in the lamps.
I'm still looking for you.
A little bit.
I'm on low.
Go back.
No, no, no, no.
Next fight.
That's nice.
Yeah.
This is it.
Go pull that.
You need to go wait.
Hela.
Yeah.
I can go cap if you want, but I don't think you should.
You should just go star or something.
Or Phoenix.
It's Phoenix.
All right.
Swap the rocket.
Yo, there's two on me and son.
Two on me and the response.
Can't get any.
Can't get it.
No, no, not yet.
We're waiting.
Go.
Okay, okay.
I'm going back.
We need to walk with Walter.
Yeah, goodbye.
I'm talking about that one.
I threw a rest.
Three, two, one of my helmet.
You should get raised.
I'm rest.
Ied.
How about I'm at looking and Neymar?
We're even.
You guys are even also.
Yeah, yeah, I can walk on stage.
Kill stage.
Strange one.
Kera Kera Angela.
Just chill.
Give me sorry.
Give her Angela.
Wait, Invis was behind us.
Invis was behind us.
Name one, name one, name one, invis, invis.
Invis, invis constant.
Three, two, one.
They used coffee.
They come name one.
That was so welcomed.
Okay, matchup is fine, I think.
They're hell up Boston after three other events.
They're hell up on the ground.
I'm lucky, lucky, I'm a lucky, three, two, one.
I'm a lucky, lucky, lucky.
I'm trying to save you.
Lucky one, lucky one, lucky one.
Lucky one, I try, I try.
He's one, he's one, he's one, still one.
Okay, I'm reload.
Name him in the bubble, name him.
Kited, kited, kited, kited, kited, kited.
And go back.
Bro, I can't.
Oh, that's too late.
Just wait.
They wasted.
I'll save Phoenix for hello.
We can go in after.
Wait and wait and no, wait and no, wait and no.
You should say what?
Sing calling!
Sing calling, be on you, be on you.
Thing, thing, thing, thing, thing.
Get that vehicle moving again!
I'll Phoenix, I'll tell you.
Thing half, thing, quarter.
I am dead.
I just, okay.
Thing, thing, thing, well.
Thing, thing, thing.
Oh, here they are.
Push, push, push, push.
There's no one's our card.
No one's our card, no one's our card.
Push card.
Just abuse the card.
I'll deal with them.
I dropped it.
Two, one.
I'm dropping.
Angel, I have.
Okay, they're all on you.
They're all on you.
Yeah, I know.
No res.
I'm moving my res.
Kind of cooked.
He's on me.
No more top right.
No more hit.
Yeah.
I'm on.
Think, think, think, think, think, think, think, think,
think, think, think, think, think, think, I'll kill him.
I'll kill him.
Shoot him.
One.
We can't, we can't live it then.
Limit, we can't.
Three.
Two.
Enjoy me, enjoy me.
So close.
All one.
They're low, they're low, they're low, they're low back.
I can.
I need to hide.
Need to hide.
Just live, just live.
Just live.
One more.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have mine.
Thing one.
Oh my god, bro.
I got touch.
You need TP by me?
Yeah, I got it.
M1, M1.
Nice.
I'm almost out of my own.
I'm shooting Angel, Angel out.
I'm shooting Angel out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna get dropped.
I touch, I touch, I touch, I touch.
Let me touch, live it, live it, live it, live it, Moxie.
Yep.
That'll go with mine.
I'm going with mine.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, no, no, no, no.
Hello, no, no, no.
I got hit.
I'm res, I'm res, I'm res.
I'm res.
I am good.
wait wait strange one strange one i had to i had to look go
strange one strange one strange one strange one strange one
angel behind angel is still behind you guys angel is behind
you guys one more one more one more that we're done i'm okay
i'm okay i'm okay I'm on the green tree.
I'm on the back.
Hello, one.
Try to live, try to live, just live, just live.
Allow them to get infinite glow kills, that's a problem.
We need to really confirm fights much clearer.
We can't allow them to farm that many glow kills.
They're really bad matchup to deny the full dive though.
Like Loki is very bad into full dive.
Just need to hit hard and then I just go cap, I think, and
we just win.
I think I'm getting better at dodging, guys.
I still hate dive.
We have to play super smart.
And we need to dive the angles more.
I still hate dive.
I think I'm getting better at dodging.
You can let me match the death of you or top right.
That's so fucking sucks.
I don't know how it's going to be better.
You're sure?
Shipper, how can I top right?
I can play top left.
I should put my like high ground, but like I'm panicking
too, so I can't really pick and choose where I want to go.
Because I'm like, like I'm literally hanging by a thread and
I was like, and then I ink.
Wait, were we on, were we on Deadpool Venom?
I mean, like, you know, they're like, I'm like, ah, ah, and
then I just chuck it in front of me.
I can't think to chuck the high ground.
I mean, this is fine, but we just need to.
we just really need to hit them hit the people outside of
the healing like if they have cloaky healing have one guy
shoot the loki clones like moxie just shoot the loki clones
and the rest just hit hit the people outside of the healing
okay like the hella the namo when they're flanking we can
scout where they go from securing the mission area go
straight yeah they'll scout they have strange strange i see
angie strange going angie angie going left loki hella left
Loki hella left.
There's three left, three right.
We can all go for them.
Five left, five left, five left.
Three, two, one.
Good man.
Handula one.
Slam, slams, slams.
One, low kill him on, low kill him on, low kill.
He's checking my balls.
Whoa!
I need help, I need help.
I need help.
The name where, uh...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're up to you.
Go back, go back.
Match the point.
Go strange.
Wait, kill these.
Kill these on the right.
Kill the right, kill the red.
Wait the dome, wait the dome, wait the dome.
Hit after, two, one.
Go in.
I'm dead in main.
They're back, they're back.
And, uh, I'm on.
Ne-1, Ne-1, Ne-1, Ne-1, Ne-1.
I'm down.
I have the little.
I can TP.
Yeah, UTP, UTP.
Yeah, my RIS is too far.
Give it, give it, give it.
They're gonna push further.
They're gonna push just so you.
Wilt him.
I'm destroying my RIS.
Okay.
It's on Nara Grend.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
I can go back and you guys ready?
And we can go three one-to-one I'm on the support point!
Kill him or after him?
Yeah.
I'm on him.
I'm on him!
I go back then.
Oh yeah.
Hello.
Hello?
I'm living.
I'm living too.
I'm living!
Thank you for it now but there is an Angela on me.
Live it live it live it live it.
I have TD all after.
Good.
No, contact.
Can you talk to me?
I'll talk to you.
I have food.
I will too.
Come here.
I helped you.
I have Luna.
We have Luna.
Chill.
You touch.
You can't.
Do not tonight.
Do not.
I'm not.
Oh my god, what?!
Come back, come back, come back.
Come back, come back, come back, come back.
I didn't think that was Ringtun there.
All the way!
All the way out.
Let's go back.
I didn't think the splash damage was left 5!
I was like, I'm bad.
points soon okay give flake to look oh fenix look fenix o
establoin no tp no tp i will go point 3 2 1 first open just
go hard first open fy no bird no bird absolute a i don't i
think we should let's go back in come on hella i i can't
even know why yeah go go go go go come one fenix you're just
following around on him fenix one fenix one wait Brock Loki
one Loki one Anti one everyone Okay, we hit in the open we
hit the open okay Their anti is legit just following me
around the map like the entire game.
I know I know I know They're just playing anti dodge.
I'm going under hello all the way You can always you can
always Phoenix them from far and we can just hit Okay, okay,
okay, I'm chilling.
I'm chilling.
I'm chilling Think on me think of me.
I'm going back now two one back one okay yeah Phoenix
Phoenix Phoenix Phoenix no fade no fade no go back Vinnie go
back happy happy happy I don't believe I'm sorry Kill the
cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak They got the
rose here Gnome gnogue dice, cloak dice?
I killed no rose no I'm with you on Loki, I ult him, I ult
him.
Kill Loki, kill Loki.
Phoenix one, Phoenix one, Phoenix one.
I kill Phoenix, don't worry.
I'm about right, in the tunnel.
Thing one, thing one, thing one.
We can't kill, we can't kill, go back, go back.
I vote, I vote.
Do they use, do they use one cloak roll, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They only have copy and he's with mine, he with mine, he
with mine this fight.
I'm set up top left, I'm set up top left.
I can go whenever, we can go.
Yeah, I can go.
Three, two, one, multi, multiple thing.
I killed a Hela, Hela, Hela, Hela, Hela.
Can we lift?
Live it.
Always lift it.
We can't shoot it and we can't break it.
Just lift.
Can you lift?
Can you rest?
You get rest.
Go far.
Go far, Moxie.
You're dying.
Go far.
I just got respawned.
Go come back.
Come back.
Go group.
They don't have any support.
I can touch the point.
I can't go back.
They're like all on point.
I got you.
I want, wait, Phoenix, Phoenix.
I'm here.
I'm all here.
Ninja have DLP.
I lost it.
Let's go in.
Get out of there.
I'm trying to keep you.
I'm on lucky.
I'm trying to keep one.
Angela.
I'm tipping.
I can't touch.
Come on.
I'm going touch.
Yeah, it's okay.
Need to play more to live, guys.
We're dying too often.
We hit and then we live.
We cannot match Glocult, guys.
I say it all the time.
They Glocult, we need to get out.
There's no fighting that.
We have nothing that can kill through.
We have nothing that can kill it.
Just need to respect it and go back, okay?
Let someone else touch.
It's fine.
I can always touch.
Venom can touch.
It's okay.
We understand now.
They got a bit lucky on the...
It's like round robin too.
On the tank.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's super annoying, the Angela thing.
I literally can't play the game.
He's just on me, like, he hasn't hit anyone else except me.
Is it first to free now?
No, it's not, right?
That was just a...
That was just an extra match for tiebreaker.
That was like a seeding match, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just a tiebreaker match.
Yeah, it's fine.
it's already map two it was three two right did they cap
first the three one they never cap first point right two
zero map two score i think we yeah we fell hold so it'd be
two zero because we didn't cap third point
apparently our second room is up now all right let's go as
booger bash one should have probably went hawkaii there
that's why looking back at it should have played good
hawkaii i think we also i think we also need angie i think
angie is just so big against a cop like that like hella
phoenix or hell in a more i think so too at least we learned
from it for for the next time we fight them probably angela
cap and then we just yeah something like that
this is so boring
enough charm arrivals i was on doomkey losing i'm one yay i
did it now you're gonna start losing because we lost our
match i mean we still won against that team i was like you
know he's like respect the hell don't touch i was like i'm
fine i'm like don't worry guys i'm fine and then i get like
double tapped i have i'm in my little hole try to stand on
all engage always like try to take range maybe we can like
one shot the loki i did not respect it okay check check
check i'm sorry i didn't have my old like ever further hell
and it just like was just i'll be like there's no way she's
gonna kill me i'm in my little hole when they have like
cloak loki it's also fine to just hit it while you're back
you're not killing through the lamp we're not killing
through the dome most of the time it's very hard to kill
through i would rather preserve cooldowns and then hit
future you're talking to me not everyone everyone oh yeah i
mean i lose a lot of we lose a lot of cooldowns during it so
i would want to play a bit safer doing it buddy just tell me
i got what i gotta do on phoenix all right press e when you
guys engage yeah because i have time i feel like i'm just
like shooting angela or you need to mark the dps like yeah
mark the dps so i help us stage the hits right if it's free
to stand that backline it does so much for us it won us a
world championship back then with naga stand the feet stand
the back line with phoenix
wait what did i look like when i'm afk i gotta see maybe
with band angela honestly angela band is not too bad i think
actually the bun is winning he's probably winning oh my god
just dying someone save her okay trust me he's doing the
work bro Yeah, I just can't.
It's like a fish.
It's like a fish trying to breathe.
Oh, yeah.
It literally looks like a fish trying to fucking breathe
right now.
Oh, you said the...
I think it sounds similar.
I like took me out of the wording.
We have a unique voice, bro.
Oh, thank you.
It's completely fruit.
Yeah, I'll be back to you.
Someone invite me.
Bobby's up, right?
Yeah, that way's up.
I can invite you whenever.
They have Gail and J3 DPS.
R-R-R-R-R-G.
It's fine they have TTK tank line.
We just go full dive and we avoid them.
No?
I do that.
Yeah, but we don't.
What is their backline?
Cooper and Mash.
Cooper the Mash.
Free backline to dive, no?
Well, they're getting Jay on Mantis some games.
In the Godcom.
Mantis.
They can save it for us.
They're banning his bucky.
I'm back.
Kill, bite size, Papa, Solid, Medi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jump club.
Versus Necros team.
Does someone save it?
I spilled water on myself.
I'm thinking how am I real?
What background does Saipa have?
How am I fucking real?
There's only one hole here and I still missed.
What background does Crook have?
I need a caretaker.
I don't even know how to drink water.
At least.
did you know crova plays on a finger mouse bro that guy is
like six four or something like insanely tall he has huge
hands you know like so one of those like mini like those
mini mice they use on like a macbook or something yeah yeah
that's what it's called yeah he has like only it's like it's
like maximum five centimeter long or yeah it's like a so
small you measure it on a mac that's pretty the people with
big hands they have big stuff that guy didn't have that oh
yeah that guy big hands big hands it's above average the
mouse yeah the mouse what else would i be talking about yeah
how do i know it i tested it damn did you did you grip it
did you grip it the mouse was good
You're having a little tooth or something.
Don't you please.
He's German.
With two hands.
Don't you please.
English is not his first language.
Alright.
I'm ready.
As ready as I'll clown be.
why you gotta make it what did i say i was talking about the
mouse guys he said the mouse was really tiny and i was like
um it's above don't don't mouth shame him he was mouth
shaming him that's the problem monitor do you have a 240
yeah 24 no there's no there's no good monitor don't don't
like 27 yeah exactly it's not the size of the mouse it's how
you use it it's how you grip it right it's how you grip it
it's how you grip it i know that the monitor is on the
ladder 24 i'm pretty sure so i would rather play on 24.
yeah but i definitely would need an upgrade i only play 180
hertz right now not even 240.
jesus wow yeah you need an oled yeah you need the msi oled
monitor legit it has q led and um what hashtag yeah hashtag
i'm actually i'm sponsored yeah yeah use my referral code
and you get like 15 off that's value that's value yeah yeah
right there yeah yeah i can buy infinite food with 15 off
that's true that's a lot 15 off for a thousand dollar
monitor that's that's like 200 right i don't i'm bad i
failed math yeah that's pretty that's about it kind of like
150 yeah imagine how much you save might be 150 yeah
okay that's so natural i'm such a natural show and like I
weaved it into a very natural conversation Craigie and Melio
I think one of the strongest in tournament I can't lie I
think I think you said every team I can't tell if you're
being sarcastic yeah you said every team was the strongest
now I don't sure I'm gonna be honest I didn't feel them that
much but that's just me playing Phoenix you're feeling them
full dive in a hard winning matchup so it should be like
what team do you think can pull out full dive no no team no
team no one has a jeff player maybe crook's team can if
let's go maybe i think i think i think fate can they have
team captain and madara oh yeah you're right oh tria i mean
they yeah they lost to sk's team i mean no no sk lost to
team captain's
as well like i think they purposely went full depth yeah
they also do our stretch just save spider-man first but we
have the name our specialist here oh oh yeah me yeah that's
me yeah season zero at the back line for the ice squid in
the back line at afk they're not that is like the boxy
special against sk's team they weren't playing full dive
though They went Mag, Phoenix, Invis, Spider-Man, Thor,
Loki.
Everyone is playing four, I can't.
It's actually not a bad hero this season though.
Thor?
Thor is like legit just buffed every single patch.
I know, it's like silent buff and one buff, it's gonna be OP
as fuck.
I already think, I legit think it's OP already, like, but
it's just like only Thor one tricks that are good at him.
The problem is the punish windows are just too high.
like you just get like one shot if you like ever misplay
once the enemy team is very coordinated i mean i feel like
it's pretty maybe but like yeah i think the only champ that
like hard the counters them is bucky but otherwise he's
legit final boss the dude just gets a shield with every
ability cast by the way test the guy that plays dead he also
can he also has like a wolf grab basically like a mini wolf
grab that doesn't have a cooldown but they're having a
conversation i'm listening i'm being a good listener throw
in the bag no i've seen it play it i'm listening like the
one tricks i'm trying to learn from my sempas that's that
pool one trick and then i'm going for four i usually i play
every character at least i try but it's very hard to get
better at the one tricks to be honest i just need to watch
them and just like copy their and then once I'm at the stage
where they had I just individualized myself obviously I want
to do that before as well but that is good for one tricks I
guess there's like one controller guy that just has aim
assist every dragon rock oh that guy's a problem every every
4f is just like free to connect on the enemy backline yeah
it's so big bro he doesn't even have to aim it is true i
mean on a melee i'm not sure you need aim assist though i
think they should ban aim assist anonymically in pro play i
said it multiple times and i agree until i die that's why
there's a lot of uh really good dps player on aim assist or
what yeah i mean not on not on dps like i i i get it like
controller like i i get that you know i had this discussion
all the time controller without aim assist is unplayable at
pro level like i get it it's it's unplayable thank you thank
you for the super chat thank you thanks for the sponsored
message i can feel the brand engagement suddenly influencing
my future purchasing decisions already oh my god have you
guys ever played fortnite before i've been enjoying fortnite
so much especially the skids and if you want you can check
out my you can get but you can use my code dokey for
fortnite skins you don't get anything out of it but like you
know it's to support your favorite streamer i mean me as
good as he is normally
consume my consumers consume i mean it makes sense because i
do have a feeling they will ban it i'm not sure did you know
the regular show is now a fortnite skin and also ed ed ready
and also the same problem um there was one more i forgot
what the other one was i was like holy they've been just
fucking non-stop releasing skins now it's actually a bit too
much i actually it's it's i have to actually admit that
they're actually going wild with fortnite collabs yeah i
think so too i'd be missing i mean see you guys are naming
so much and i'm like yeah all of this yes that's not good
oh now it's too much luck they've been really it's they've
been releasing so many skins and oh I'm ready I was talking
about Fortnite to my chat thanks for the quality content my
new board feeds off the chaos of dive cop avid out they give
the super chat thank you thank you what really I'll take
your entire stock thank you for the super chat unleash thank
you Thank you.
Yeah, I think it's just, it's like, it's like they haven't
stopped.
I felt like before it, they would, there was like a buffer
period in between.
But then they realized Fortnite Epic finally realized
they're like, wait, we can just keep going.
They're like, wait, guys, FOMO works.
We just, we can't just, we can't just keep going.
Like you're saying very publicly that we need to ban, they
need to ban Jeff against us.
the broadcast your problem i mean he has a point it's good
ban against us we cannot serve first save it if nothing
works i think that's the next best thing i mean we first
just first save jeff they realized they figured it out and
then we completely like now they'll never stop they only
took them like four years but now they figured it out yeah
oh wait jokies on bans jokies on bans oh my god okay okay i
got it I got this.
I didn't even realize Okay, we want to play DD.
Yeah, we need to be in the backline 24-7
What do I do next?
Wait it first.
Let's see what this is.
Okay, then we decide to ban Mantis.
Yeah, or Mantis ban Okay Okay.
Mentipen.
Then let's see.
Phoenix I guess.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Looks good.
What are you trying to last ban?
Yeah, that's the question, right?
Because I was thinking, I was thinking, I was thinking how
lower and a more.
Or Angela.
Yeah, I had on a more.
It's good then.
I don't think it should be hella.
Hella is very easy to die.
But the ult was very strong.
against us like it's yeah it's just annoying like we have
nothing to break it yeah i could be saving phoenix for it
but like that was that was kind of hard because they're not
so long why are we banning let's see it look hella is not
that they do they have dead every player they don't no j3
gail i think we ban i think we ban hella okay hella's fine
yeah what do we save We save They're gonna go bucky most
likely we save Jeff Okay, yeah, Jeff Yeah, I did my job
Yeah, it's okay.
That's 90% of the work.
Yep got it Clocking out doing it for the vibes now.
Oh, he's the guy that said You can go Jeff cloak if you
want.
Oh, yeah What do you want instead?
Luna or Cloak?
Luna, you have to play super passive and super slow.
Okay.
Go full dive, go full dive.
Go cap, cap Angela or cap Venom.
I think cap Venom for Luna.
Do I do Cloak or Luna?
Have you guys played against that one duo, like Monarch and
someone else?
They play like Adam Luna and just perma flank.
Like the guy's snowflakes himself and just flanks.
I think you can do that too, yeah.
Wait, you want me on Cloak or Luna?
I'm Luna Snow.
We are.
Ah.
Luna?
I think Luna's better, yeah.
I think it's gonna, I think it's like hard to heal us.
All right.
We want me to give the first flake too.
Okay.
All right.
And Winnie and me and DAP just flank and roam the map.
DAP you play above Moxie and Doki, I think.
I play with Moxie.
Do you want me to play with you guys or play with the speed?
I'm going to create opportunity for speed for you to get a,
to get a grab on the enemy or grab on the enemy backline.
So said Winnie fell with me and with speed.
Should be helpful to them to stop it.
No sparring.
Did you say?
2, 1 I said have three people split, me, Speed, and Winnie
and we go back.
I'm gonna try to go top left, like far top left.
I'm playing top right.
Okay, I play with you, Moxy.
I play bug key, sing, and aim more top left.
Yeah, I see.
Yeah, I see looking at his top left.
Yeah, okay.
When they drop, I can go.
When they drop.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
Three, two, one.
Maloki, look, look.
CC'd stunned.
Yeah, I need, I'm living.
I'm living, I'm living.
Can we lift?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I can go.
I can go.
Three, two, one.
Go now, go now.
Throw a stun in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Throw on me, on me, on me, on me.
I hit back then again.
What?
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm
on, I'm on, I'm No, I'm living, I'm living, I'm living.
I have to reload.
I have to reload, sorry.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, we can win.
We can win.
I can go back then.
Oh, no, I can't.
I can't.
Ringmark.
Or I'm on.
Ringmark, ringmark.
I don't think I can play Angeline to this, bro.
Yeah, you need to go Venom.
You need to go Venom.
I think Venom is tough.
Yeah, Venom, honestly.
Venom's good.
I think I have.
No diamond.
But you want to go, you want to go Emma.
I'm going not to.
Just wait.
I'll go behind.
Yeah, they're back on the bottom left or not.
Yeah, I'm going behind.
They're all coming back.
I can go.
Yep.
Can you finish on the side?
Yeah, I'm going.
Three, one.
Okay, visit, visit, visit, visit.
This one, in this one.
Yeah, see what?
Two, one, two, one, two, one.
Lift, lift, lift, lift, lift.
No, lift, no, lift.
I ain't out there.
Three, two more.
Wait, no ammo one, ammo one, ammo one!
No more one, no more one, no more one, no more one.
No key, no key, no key, no key.
I have all, I have all.
I have the ammo.
He's got a combo.
He's got a damage combo.
Nemo, Nemo is coming.
Yeah, just limit, just limit, limit, limit, limit.
Kill it, kill it.
Three, two, one.
Nemo one, Nemo one, Nemo one, Nemo one, Nemo one.
Yeah, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
I have DDO.
Yeah, yeah, reset DDO.
Can we, can we go now?
Can we go now?
Yes, I can.
Three, two, one, go.
Okay, I need y'all.
I'm out.
I froze.
I'm hitting.
I'm trying to.
I come in.
Then go back land too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh no.
I don't think I'm on.
Everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone.
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look,
look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look,
just wait, just wait, just wait.
Yeah.
They use them though.
I'm never going to hold the gate.
They just save your name.
They still have things.
We should go early again.
Before they get to the point.
Yeah, I can.
Wait, we look soon.
They're top right.
I'm better go.
Better go.
I froze the thing.
Okay.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look,
look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look,
look, look, look, think, think, think, think, think, Stagger
think.
Stagger, Sagger.
Stagger, don't fight.
Don't care, don't kill.
Just live.
Come here, jump out.
Feel?
Jump out.
It's focused.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I'm walking up.
Look at the top left.
Yeah, I still have Seed.
Yeah, I see three top left.
I see three top left.
I can go now.
Ready?
You gonna go now?
I can go down.
Yeah, no, Ki'd had just kill.
Khaed, just kill.
Yeah, chill, chill.
I'm out.
Go.
They've no left.
I can go back in.
I'm on.
I kill the more.
Bucky.
Troll.
I'm dead.
I'm on.
Bucky.
Bucky outside.
He grabbed me instead.
I'm fine.
I'll go.
They're all low.
No more, no more no more.
No more, I'm also ice.
T's T's, T's, T's the one, T's, T's, T's!
T's one!
Yeah, yeah.
T's, Kuss, K's, K's, K, K!
T's, K's, K's, K, K's, K, K's, K, K's, K, K, K's, K's, K, K,
K!
Let's heal him.
Boo.
I think they use- Its copy at the end.
Yeah, they did.
They used Bucky, copy, um...
You still have Emma, right?
Okay.
I think they're, yeah, they should have them though.
You can tell my life.
But what if it be fabulous to have an all-screen?
let's see the emerald is going to be a problem i kind of
want to hold early i think you keep toky bird for safety we
can go you need to save it when we go on points i like this
matchup that we're playing red okay so i don't all when
emeralds are you and just save it i think we're going i
think we're going with capital and they should okay yeah we
go with okay we go emeralds behind it and then we go after
okay we can maybe kill through i'm not sure I need to play
risky, I think.
Oh my god, there's disco lights when I ride.
Oh my god.
We just keep on doing that.
It's very hard for them to stop it.
They might go cloaky.
If they go cloaky.
Stand left.
Go right side.
I think if Coco's right side, we go left.
Yeah, right, right, right.
And I'm going to die.
Me and Trace may go top left.
Yeah, he goes up left.
I'm kind of slow.
I fucked up my shift.
Yeah, I'm chilling.
I'm chilling.
I see Star.
I see Star on point.
Star on point.
I'm with my...
Oh, they saw me.
They saw me.
They see us.
Oh, they see us.
Oh, yeah.
Three, two, one.
Baby, go, go, go, go, go.
I hit you.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Kill, kill, kill, kill.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Back to one, back to one, back to one, back to one, back to
one.
Back to one, back to one.
I'm chasing with you, excuse me.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
I was dead.
Just chill, just chill.
Good luck.
You should, Moxie.
Come on then.
One.
Just wait.
Angela, Angela.
Yeah.
And Vinny also tried to stun him.
Like if you stun him with right click, he's like always in
problem.
I'm going to play above the choke.
I see.
Let me scout.
Let me see.
I see four top left.
Yo, can we hit top left?
I see Luna.
I can't.
Let him walk.
Let him walk first.
I'm going to go soon.
Three, two, one.
They're all on me.
I'm up.
Yeah, just chill.
We forced cooldowns.
I can't find you.
I don't really have a good angle.
I can go back in.
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, you're so far from me.
I'm dead.
Okay, chill, chill, chill.
I got it.
Keep up, keep up, keep up, keep up, keep up.
Live, live, live, live, live, live, live, live, live, live,
live.
Four, three, two, two, one.
I got hit, I got hit, I got hit.
He looks to a point, looks to a point, looks to a point,
trust me.
Look to a point.
Two one!
Two one.
One, one, one!
Starlot!
Starlot one!
I killed Starlot!
Emma one, Emma one, Emma one!
Emma one!
Yeah, Emma dies.
I need heal.
Angelou, Angelou.
They use Cloak, they use Starlord, they use Bucky.
They might take TPH.
If they TP, I can fight it with DDO.
Where's... okay, yeah.
That wind is, no?
Let me, let me go with mine.
Let me go with mine.
I can force it.
I'm playing on this like tree thing.
Top left.
I'm going for the whole thing.
I'm going for the drooling.
Five top left.
Two out.
Yeah, I'm shooting.
They're TPing.
TPing.
TP's out.
Can we go?
Two, one.
Oh, I got to pull.
Can you live?
I'm dead.
I got pulled.
It's fine.
Help me.
They used Invis.
They have no Cloak.
Just don't spam them, OK?
There's 60 on Starlord all.
We can kill, we bait Dom, okay?
We bait Cloak Dom and then we hit after.
You just run it down with Kat.
They don't have any spores.
Don't poke, don't poke.
Don't do damage.
Speed, you don't take the CV.
We don't take it.
We hit you.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll go main with you.
I'm ready to go whenever.
You guys ready guys ready?
Yeah, I'm back.
Three, two, one, cloak.
This one, this one, this one, this one.
This one, this one, this one.
Pokemon, Pokemon, Pokemon, Pokemon, Pokemon, Pokemon,
Pokemon, Pokemon, Pokemon.
Nice, nice.
I'm pushed back then.
Push back then.
No, I'm not.
I can't kill him.
Need to live it, need to live it.
Shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot it.
I want to live it, I want to live it, I want to live it.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Respect, respect the TP.
Kill the Phoenix, kill the Phoenix.
I have all in three.
Emma one, Emma one, Emma one, Emma one.
Okay, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill,
chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, I can't.
Just chill, chill, chill, chill.
I want you, I want you, I want you Hit after 3, 2, 1 Kill,
kill, kill, kill I'm getting shielded I go back, 1, 2, 1
Invis 1, Invis 1, Invis 1, Invis 1, Invis 1, I'm dead, I'm
dead Next one, next one, next one, next one Yeah, that's
fine Go next, go next, go next, go next We have Invis all, I
think Respect the cloacals guys, just kite it, okay?
Every cloacal we can fight, we are not killing food, will
not happen, just go chill They should have imbezole, I
think.
They do, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they do, they do.
Just wait, just wait.
They're on three tanks.
No, three tanks.
I can pinch.
I can pinch from right side.
Let me pinch and force points.
I can go, I can go, I can go, I can go, two, one.
I go, cloak.
I go cloak.
Come on, two, two, two, two, two, four, so I'm gonna kill
you.
Just leave it, just leave it, leave it, leave it, leave it.
We can hit after, we can hit after.
Can we hit?
I can pull back.
I'm there right now.
Okay, okay, okay.
two um instead of no uh need to get out need to get out
there's nothing they have nothing we just go after and we
killed yeah yeah i think sue here so here so here they're
all coming for me guys sooner jump i can go see i can go to
i can touch i can touch Not yet, not yet.
I'm better go soon, better go soon.
I'm not there.
I have an Angela on me.
Going in.
Oh, he pooped me off.
Oh, back down, or back down, or back down.
I'm just living.
I'm slipping.
Okay, we're safe.
We're safe for next run.
It's okay.
I'm back in the fight.
Yeah.
Need to play more safe, guys.
Angela is a problem.
Holy shit.
He just falses so many mistakes.
It's crazy.
Should I go Bucky?
No, no, no, no, no.
Please don't.
Just stay this.
Okay, okay.
This hero is so good that you're playing.
Either go Starlord or go or stay this.
Both is good.
Starlord is also great.
On this map, no.
This map being stealthy better.
I'm saying they use Starlord.
You have ult.
You don't want to.
We just go with my ult.
They can't defend it.
Okay.
The cloak bubble is a problem guys.
Wait, they use Emma and Starlord.
They use Emma and Starlord.
Yeah, yeah, I think so.
This is a good Spider-Man pull map.
I mean into that matchup you're not pulling anyone and then
Angela is just gonna kill Doki with every fight I'm not I
don't want that It's super pointless Check check check all
right That's great The battle starts in 5 4 3 2 1 All you
need to do is capture the mission area I don't know, I want
a forced dome and then we hit after Honestly, I didn't like
snow growing up That's great They might have clear filters
Yeah, they should.
They're close to it.
I'm with Marcy.
I can force it too.
Wait, Sarum point.
Sarum point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can go back then.
I'm holding it.
I'll kill you.
Leave it.
Get out.
Just chill.
Live it.
Please play to live when they're cloaked.
We cannot match them.
Just shoot.
I'm gonna go back.
We need to regroup.
Yeah, I'm back.
I'm back.
Yeah, next situation.
Just wait.
Wait everyone.
And you top left.
And you left.
And you left to me.
Yeah, we can go around.
Yeah, I can hit whatever.
I can touch the point.
I'm forcing point.
Alright, can you walk in me?
You walk in me?
Two, one, forcing point.
Wait, I'm on this Emma.
I'm on this Emma.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry,
sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm looking back.
I'm back.
I go back into my ulcer.
Yeah.
Could we go DL?
I'll go DL.
Three, two, one.
I'm also holding.
Yeah.
It's a Vicky.
Just protect the chef.
Protect the chef.
I know.
Nice
You can't get up and that Go back in after go no no no no no
next next
Need one good fight
Or group up.
We have one more point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think Angie left.
The back one's bottom left.
The back one's like bottom left.
Point.
Yeah, I go around.
I can hit you.
I'm going right.
I'm going to hit you.
Yeah, I connect you.
I connect you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three, two, one.
I focused Invis in this small round.
Look, look, look, look.
We need to help him.
Trying to help.
Yeah, hear me.
Support, support, support one.
Support, support, one.
Invis, invis, invis, invis.
Yes, invis, invis, invis.
We need to TP.
Yeah, I will, I will.
Angela's on me.
Angela, Angela, you kill us.
Yeah, yeah, she's out.
She's out.
I can try to touch.
This matchup is so it's, oh my god, we need to ban Angela.
It's also just the cloak ult.
It's also the cloak, yeah.
It's legit 14 seconds.
It's just 14 seconds of strength.
It's really awesome.
Should I play cloak next?
I mean, I don't think that's about it.
I think what we have is a very good matchup.
We just need to really respect the Globals.
We're not killing the food.
Just respect it, okay?
And shoot the Angela more.
We need to ban it.
The Angela's, like, nowhere near us, like, half the time.
He's doing infinite.
Is he marking you this time?
Because I didn't see him on me.
No, he's never on me.
He's never on me.
But I don't know where he was other than that.
It's just legit stomper hero for uncoordinated gameplay.
it is really good like in this in this tournament angela is
too good because any mistake that we do like it's not even
on us but he just gets infinite punish windows speedily
because we don't have any opportunities so either we ban
clove or we ban angela i i really feel like angela is kind
of unbeatable in dive and i think we need angela to that
game i don't know i feel like dp you need to go here that
does more like on the map i know you do a lot but like maybe
more more pressure in the back then
but the problem is they just put counter pressure on us so
we have three people in the team not playing the game like
just by the angela flying around he's not even playing the
game he's just flying around wasting everyone's time it's
too good on a hero to not then oh yeah i get what you mean
speed we can also ban cloak the problem is every cloak dome
we can't kill fluke as i said right so it's like it waits
more time and more investment to clear i mean i feel like we
should be able to mag ulta in theory because like i know
they don't have a mag yeah i know but then they have
startled also wins the fight it's like super annoying i feel
like like maybe i'm not in like the right position when you
guys are diving like i feel like i'm always like more
towards like doki in the back like i'm trying to 100 yeah
i'm just following the first one was way easier because i
can like just reposition really easily and everyone's out in
the open i can just throw stun in when you dive yeah but
when you guys are like on the second map high ground i'm on
low ground point like should i be playing far left on our
side of spawn i don't know that was weird i think barring
angela also solves the problem because then you like play
more free because then blocking doesn't have that much
pressure i mean the only way to counter it is to if they go
cap but i don't think they get that also lugia go to cap
it's kind of so it should be fine can't really do that we
should just ban angela i think it's just too good of a hero
i'll type uh i'll type r yeah i'll do that i'll ban angela
now i think i give phoenix i'm not sure like the phoenix is
a problem though that bands are also not bad i don't really
see either of those two playing phoenix a lot i don't
doesn't gail play phoenix a lot i see him play it a lot i
i'm pretty sure he does play it a lot but honestly like you
could have stayed but we needed to swap and we could should
have went like oh we can't go into this it's bands we need
to play this We don't have anything to go.
There was one fight in the second round that was, like,
criminal for us to lose.
I'm not going to lie.
Like, the fight where both their supports were dead, and
they TP'd back.
That fight was unloosable.
I know, I know.
We had it in the back, to be honest.
We just gave it up.
I'm just a sheep.
I just listen.
I don't do.
Good Hawkeye map.
I have no free will.
Bro, it's a good Hawkeye map.
Hawkeye honestly would have maybe been okay that last map,
because you can kill Cloakote.
Oh, dude, you're actually right.
That's why I said, like, we should have maybe went brawl,
honestly.
But I do not want to give up on the dive.
I think we should keep playing it.
This is going to be 8, though.
They're going to bunker inside with triple tank.
Triple support.
Flock, I flank.
Oh, so trust you're the bad leader now.
Well, you'd rather play Storm, right, speed?
I feel like JetSafe is more important than DD Safe here.
Because they'll just go thing under and bunker as well.
free supports now or do you want these well if they're if
they're if they're like spawn holding i think i should play
storm yeah we just go storm and prove moonlight i guess yeah
do you have time on moon night i listen no i've never played
him in my life okay hey you got that i mean surely not that
hard you just like shoot the tanks yeah yeah surely and then
onk their back line maybe sometimes and this okay while
they're while they're banning i'll get my cough drops i'll
be right back oh i actually i actually think i banned this
it's too good of a hero i just i'm really glad and i lost
ben angela i think i don't think they have that good dps
players i think we just if they go phoenix we can still kill
him i don't think he's going to be turning the final boss
just because he's on phoenix
even though the hero is insane oh that's annoying I'm way
more worried about to be honest than Phoenix or by Loki and
Loki you say I'm back that means anything yeah actually
actually good point yeah I like that make it very annoying
for them I think so it's a good idea and then save Jeff for
us a full dive Miro Hawkeye is pretty good into Loki legal
that they get away doing that maybe have to save mantis then
actually and just go triple with mantis and with yeah yeah
actually yeah i think we can do that yeah i think in the
future we do that supports and four bands on both sides yeah
kind of so what do i play if we can force the front to back
with like triple support group then we can just like play
that pool okay luna o'clock luna
I think we go dive again.
I don't see why it shouldn't be there.
If they spawn all, do you want to go like Groot?
Groot Storm?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I feel like that might just feed support ults.
I think we should go backline.
They also don't have that good supports.
You know, I think all their supports they have are super
dive room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They'll probably be on, like, cloak.
They can't.
Cloak is going to be on.
Or not cloaks.
Like, Invis Lunar or something.
It's going to be Invis Lunar or Invis Rock.
into or in with jeff and all of that is kind of led into us
so it's good yeah only question is if you don't want to jeff
i think you should jeff yeah yeah only question is what does
dap play angela maybe i need something to kill the archela
you need to go something that kills the angela thar i see
yeah four is actually i actually think four is good i see
angela no more no more no more More hella.
No more hella.
Wait, hella, hella, far left.
Hella, far left.
Chola, I'm on him.
I can't go in.
No bird, no bird, no bird, no bird.
No bird, no bird, no bird.
Three, two, one.
No, no, no, no bubble.
I can't kill him.
Yeah, hella, no bird, hella, no bird.
Hella, no bird, no bird.
I go for him.
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
Two,
one.
Yeah, no bird.
I can't heal you.
I can't, I'm dead in star.
One more low.
Alright, I'm back in.
Go wait, go wait, go wait.
Angie, Angie, Angie.
Angie low, Angie low.
Can I help you, Moxie?
Moxie, go Starlord or Starlord.
Yeah, okay, I can't.
I mean, I can play Starlord, I guess, maybe.
I think you need to just be quiet.
I'm gonna go behind.
I can go, I can go, I can go back.
You wanna go?
One.
Oh, Su-1, Jedi wanna hold.
We forced cooldowns, I think.
Just get out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, look, Angie, Angie.
He'll, he'll, he'll, he'll, he'll.
Angie one, Angie one, Angie one.
I'm lagging, bro.
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't play the game.
Resources, just wait.
Go left, go left, go left, just hide.
I can hit soon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can go back in.
Yeah, I'm walking.
Three, two, one, walking in.
Oh, no.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
Cut it, cut it, cut it.
Hit after you.
I'm trying to cut.
Oh, we're dead.
I'll go back in.
Two, one.
Go in.
Hela one.
Hello, Hela one, Hela one.
Oh, I don't think we can play this.
They're just playing Hela and Amor.
Go Angela.
Now, this is a hard winning matchup, I believe, but we just
need to play better.
I really think that there's nothing else we can play.
What do I do?
Just spin in the back?
No, just shoot them.
Just shoot them from me.
I have a goodwin Yeah, okay, I'll start with Give me two,
one, going Will there's one?
No more one, no more, no one In this one, there is the side,
there is that Angel , else Angel alive?
You're looking you're breaking, can you break it?
Susan, I'm not whole deal?
I was trying to shoot it, I'm not gonna catch it.
Yeah, yeah, break it, break it, yeah, break it, break it,
break it, break it, hit it, hit it I'm multi, I'm multi,
multi...
I can't.
All low, kill me two one zero hello hello hello angel
contesting i'm shooting angelic got me hello hello hello
hello angelic still on point look rocket look rocket portal
i'm coming back i'm coming back hello hello one hello one
hello one um I need lift.
Next fight, next fight, I think.
Yeah, wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
Winnaboo, winnaboo, winnaboo.
Hella, hella, hella, hella.
Broke it, broke it, broke it.
Broke it, broke it.
I killed Invis, I killed Invis.
Invis about it.
All I want.
Okay.
Invis, Invis, Invis, Invis.
You can't kill.
We can't kill.
Yeah, I go back in.
I go back in.
I go back.
I'm going.
Can we lift?
Can we live?
Heavy bubble.
Yeah, yeah.
Under that one.
Emma one.
More and more and more and more and more.
Emma, Emma, Emma instead.
Emma instead.
Oh, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma, Emma, Emma, only Emma, only Emma.
Only Emma, only Emma.
Break it, break it, break it, break it, break it, break it,
break it.
break it, break it, break that.
I'm not there.
In the slope.
I'm Angela on me.
Oh.
I will take it.
Yeah.
I'm gonna
put it facing us.
Yeah, I'm going to put it facing us.
Yeah, I'm going for two, one, taking it.
I've lost two.
We have little, we have little, no, let, let, let, let.
I'm trying.
I can't touch.
Oh, shit.
I'm not.
That's fucking Angela again.
I can't defend.
It's the only hero in the game.
It makes four people in my team useless.
And we can't hit because once you go in speedily, it just
needs one scoop and you're that.
And you have such a high punishment, though.
It's so insane.
I think he's marking you.
I he hasn't been on me like the moon.
See Martin you just no no bro.
He contest.
Guys, I do not play Starlord.
Like I'm gonna be honest.
I do not fucking play this.
Phoenix is okay.
I think we go triple.
I think we go triple here.
I actually think that just go close.
Close.
Cloak and dagger.
We are hope and fear.
Yeah, cloak, Adam triple.
Cloak, yeah, them.
Dead pool I think and with Groot.
Yeah, I like that.
Groot that pool.
I can heal.
back then when did you play oh man i can play yeah i can
play adam this one yeah it's fine but really yeah i mean i'm
basically i'm adam i can play adam bro
okay well now we know now we know it's only ryan robin yeah
i mean we need to ban angela just that's too much on the map
i think he controls the entire space my he marked me a
couple of times so I couldn't really do anything.
He just exists.
Where do you want to hold?
I'm gonna hold inside like...
Break it, break it.
Break the wall.
Break the walls.
They're playing sing.
They're gonna die.
They're gonna die with sing.
They're gonna go Moonlight Storm.
I can shoot him from behind.
Yeah they're gonna hit our backline.
No, no, no, no.
Stormlight.
I eat us.
They can't.
They can come in.
Two, two, two, two, two.
Two, two.
Okay, okay.
May we walk back up?
They know after.
Walk back up.
Two, one.
Moon at all, kill.
I'm dead.
Define, define.
Maybe we're not going to do it.
We can.
We can't.
Keep the storm.
Kid the storm, storm, storm, storm.
Stom, one, storm one.
Oh, yeah.
There's...
Oh, shit.
The cards are moving.
Yeah, they're surrounded, guys.
Go strange TPM.
I'm back to shed some light.
Can you TP?
Yeah, we're TPing.
Oh, shoot.
We have Loki here soon.
I'm gonna go DD.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hit back on.
Two, one.
Touch the point.
One rocker.
Yeah, I'm all.
Two one.
I'm lining.
Walk up with it then.
Oh, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, come back, come back.
He's gonna kill.
You're gonna die.
This is real.
Fear is a word.
that's okay
oh my god i got doubled double stunned there i'm on rocket
i'm a rocket i needed to play
If I play this hero, we actually just win.
I don't want to do anything.
I can't shoot them.
I need a character that can shoot in this matchup.
It's fine.
We need to ban Angela and then we can play full-dive.
Full-dive should be unspoken.
Is there any other team that is...
I don't think you guys want me on Starlord.
Yeah, but I feel I was cooking on Hawkeye.
No, it was terrible.
No, no, I got insta-pick.
You can play...
you can play you're gonna play dd then i can go star star
yeah maybe that i could try dare double uh every starter is
a free fight win normally because they have nothing to
respond they only have raccoon in this they just emalted me
i mean i guess but that still forces emerald and you get a
window to kill them no and we killed them through when we
started with it we actually won the fight the question is
how we won it after the angela touched the point for half an
hour we didn't clear him because we can't shoot him so we
need to ban it that's just how it goes can we play another
match against them yeah we play three games we can see if we
can ban it need to get better i think
tough matchups don't know what else to do like silo is good
into this but like they don't have a good response to ults
we can shoot them if i go dd maybe i can headshot the
raccoon three times then we just win of that i can't do that
i just one shot i think if they do the same bad line and
we're gonna like have access to raccoon or something we just
save mantis instead of saving jeff last and then we just
come for the group triple support and play hawkeye into it i
also think maybe we need to save raccoon first or save jeff
first and then it's like fine again just say raccoon first
yeah i'm not sure nah this is fine what we do right now i
think but i think we don't have to yeah Yeah, the problem is
like we don't have the option to go triple now or like go
like when Mantis is banned, right?
We could have saved Mantis last and then we could have went
triple with Mantis like with Adam Mantis and Cloak or
something.
But because we couldn't do that, there's like no options.
If you save Mantis last, they are forced to like ban Loki.
So then you still have the Jeff open and you just have like
two lines open.
You have triple support and then you have Jeff type.
I think so too.
Okay.
I'm done.
listening I don't think really I see nothing against you but
the problem is if we play full me no think me listen on on
Hawkeye you can't kill the Angela like it will just not
happen so I need you to play a character that can shoot the
Angela more consistently Bucky I mean that is fine but it's
not really that good because it doesn't support the dive
like optimally you would want to play a hero that supports
both the dive and counters the Angela Star and phoenix are
the only three options kinda in that case that's what we
need so that's what i meant wow i didn't i didn't hear the
phoenix call in the beginning of the game yeah that's fine
it's fine it's the hella nameau as well they just went hell
but hella name os to be beautiful if we get i'm telling you
like against that team i don't think we banned phoenix i
think we've been a la i don't even think we've had any dps
honestly i think we really just  yeah i think we're just
not beating I just keep listening to the same when we played
the j3 tournament it's too hard to beat that hero
how come we don't have an angela the gamer 275 hp i think
she needed it on top of a 14 seconds we can't do that why is
it us why can't why are we the ones getting by angela yeah
it's fine
can we play one more can we ask them well we're supposed to
yeah i think they're just who are they wait yeah give it two
or three minutes
we wait guys i made a little i mean i also play daredevil
but like speed you got like probably infinitely more scrim
time than i can on daredevil ever i got no scrim time oh
well i'm sure the past three months well you got the script
you got scrim time all right you can you can play daredevil
bro you got that Oh, yeah, I was gonna say Um I made a
little oopsie So remember like how Twitch has those Like
sponsor things you can take And then so I took three of them
And the deadline is in two days I took three of them in the
beginning of the month And the deadline is in two days So we
gotta We gotta like Turn them out in one go I'm gonna be
like Bam bam bam I'll be like sponsor sponsors You just play
it the same as me last time yeah because i'm always like
there's plenty of time i can get this done whenever i'm free
and then go in there you force cloak bubble and then
unfortunately um yeah i wasn't really free for a while and
then kill cloak or invis whichever one you see first check
check check
bro someone bro my chat is rage betting me so hard they said
shouldn't we play jeff rocket
Why didn't we play yeah, why didn't we play rocket?
Yeah, we should have just played rocket man But every
everyone has like always great ideas, but I mean what we
played is fine like we it was okay Two days we could have
made it closer.
I still have time Angela just stopped us twice.
I still have time And then we're fine because Angela's just
good into Jeff.
Angela's good into I still have time guys Angela's good into
stalling points, you know, so we need to get rid of it But
it's practically free money because one of them is rival And
then I'm streaming on YouTube so like that's a little oopsie
too, but don't worry.
Don't worry.
I still have time.
I still have two more days I still have two more days guys
before the deadline
Which one was this?
Oh
Yeah, I you can't keep doing this.
I can't help it.
I keep falling for it again
The good thing is we're always asking we're ready and
Phoenix is pretty broke.
We're ready someone pressed our for me i think so i think we
get in look okay i gotta pee again i'm sorry i've been
hydrating a lot because i've been coughing the last two days
has not been great for me coughing wise i'm i don't know why
i'm up it's pro wait is it a spotter map it's decent if they
have if they have wait this is a good spotter man map too
you should play spotter man no no this is asking i got pee
for real a lot because i'm i've been coughing a lot so
that's why i need to pee more we just need to keep force and
dive i think maybe we just go with cap venom next game and
we just find and we ban angela so we don't yeah it's just so
it's bro like well we ran some regular stuff with no dive
like last match no why not because we didn't have the
supports for it they banned every support that we could have
played check check check i mean we have to go open to be
honest you can play like cloak loki man
which hero do you think you want to be today problem is with
cap uh speedily i just go in and i just let legit get one
solid like just like yeah i know you also get one solid so
it's like like we can have the best timing for it but you
still get so i would rather play tank pool because then i
can shoot from range while still being in the fight you know
tank pool is just op yeah i was about to say like camp that
much better than tank pool because also on tank pool you you
give me like the the jeff team ups yeah i think so i think
we can play okay which heroes will get my conflict i'm back
once more once more log in nothing nothing is nothing is
lost i think we already lost this match No, but we can...
It's okay, round robin never matters.
We can win the third series.
Round robin actually doesn't matter, no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it doesn't matter.
Day two is where it's at.
Day one, we sandbag on purpose, so they think that that's
just a real comp.
Guys, we're even.
1-1.
No, Moxie.
First set, first set.
Last set, this set.
Oh, Moxie.
The game was not that bad for you to race.
basic.
Well, that man won one in the stats.
Wait did we not win the first set?
No, we did.
Yeah, we did.
I'm tripping out.
Cook them cloak here.
I don't really want to do that.
Fuck it.
Do we do it?
We do it.
Give them everything.
Okay.
save man's tip they're gonna have namo hella maybe should
have banned hella instead on namo namo probably better game
in the future
then they're gonna go phoenix hella you'll need a top-notch
team to win this one i think it's just cap venom you want dd
moxie i'll go sigh cap venom okay
well if you if if i don't play dd what i'm playing phoenix i
think we go phoenix i think we go phoenix dd i think we go
phoenix dd i trust the speedery dd talking about you have to
like luna again probably all right yeah it's annoying but
the only thing that you can play because rock and spin
yeah and that's also been so we can't go triple the triple
was open i would play triple here we did an ultron we need
to we need to drone me and trust me damage boost one shot I
think so.
So who plays Ultron?
Wait, so no chance, so no chance of Hawkeye here?
Trust.
I think if we left, I think if we left Cloak, we might go
Hawkeye, but Cloak's man.
Wait, so should we go triple with Moxie on Ultron?
No, no, no, no.
I think this is fine.
Oh, actually, actually.
No, no, no, no.
This is fine.
We'll play the old knife tank and we'll play Mac.
You don't want to play that?
Yeah, it's fine.
Go make that.
Got it.
Yeah, there's Phoenix.
I'm just gonna use the compound I follow Mom.
They have a Genome more.
They have a Giant more.
I'm gonna go top right.
He's on.
Wait, they're fighting us up right.
They're tough.
They're all fighting us.
Yeah, yeah.
I fought for like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, rocket, bubble fucked up.
Sposing point.
We'll just kill.
I'm on rocket.
Roger that.
I'm behind him.
Come on, Phoenix.
kwyo, can you hit?
Number one, number one, Chemo!
Enviz1!
Emviz1 to the back right, Emviz1!
I can kill it.
Yeah, yeah, I'll just tap the point, tap the point, tap the
point, shoot the cat.
Yeah yeah, just lift, just lift.
Okay, cap below, cap below.
Come on, cat, let's go.
This one, we still have nothing.
Cp.
Yeah, yeah.
No TP.
We can combine the Raccoon Mox unscathia on.
When we get it.
I swear.
Okay, yeah, I got one mole.
I'm on this Phoenix.
I can't get that.
No TP, no blink, no blink, no blink.
I have a good position.
I'm on Emma.
Yeah.
I go three, two, one.
Top.
Can you break Chris?
I'm on the Emma.
Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma, Emma.
Give us one.
Yeah, well, I'm on back.
I'm living.
Okay.
Shoot the cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
Oh, we're all dead somewhere.
Come back.
I can go back in.
I can go rocket.
I can look rocket.
You want me all?
I can all here.
One, I'm on rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Emma one, Emma one.
Okay, I'm on team.
Go ahead and hit me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, walk, walk.
Wait, go ahead, go ahead, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, come back, come back, live it,
live it, live it, live it, live, live.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Oh, I got pulled, I got pulled, I got pulled.
I got pulled.
Yeah, I'm going in.
Keep on, keep on, keep on, keep on, keep on.
No more, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'll watch you, I'll watch you, come to me, come to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, coming, coming, coming.
Come back, come back, come back, we can do it.
I'm probably not.
Just give, just give, just give.
No, I live, I live, I can use.
I can use the jump.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, look, see, look, see, look, see, look, see, look, see,
look, see, look.
Can you go, maybe?
Yeah, I can go.
I can go now, can you now, can you now?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, I'm on the bubble.
Yeah, I can go back, I'm in a sec.
All right, go back and I'm in a second.
I'm on rocket, I'm on rocket, rocket, rocket.
It's massive.
Wait, captain one!
Can we look on the room?
On the room inside, inside here, in tech here.
Rocket one, rocket head, rocket head.
Nice.
The registrar, Felix, Felix, Phoenix, Felix, what are we?
Nice, fine, nice, nice.
Okay, so I'm good.
Set up on the back.
Oh shit.
Okay, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going, I'm going.
Yeah, yeah.
Three, two, one.
I'll go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go.
Rocket one, rocket one, rocket one, rocket one.
Back it's one.
Oh, that's not that way.
Go next fight, go next fight.
Fight this long.
It's okay.
I killed the mark, come on, come on, we can win, we can win.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You're on, you're on, you're on.
That's good.
Back to my old self.
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm missing.
Get that vehicle moving again!
We're gonna get...
Oh shit.
Maybe if I'm ult for Rocket.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll go behind him.
I'm about it.
Yeah, I want to go DDL soon.
I'm ult soon.
I'm ulting 10.
Can we go?
Three, two.
We definitely have Rocket ult.
I don't have Venus.
Okay, okay.
Multi, multiple.
Yeah, yeah.
I almost have ult.
I'm out.
Wait, I'm out.
Yeah, I'm out.
We'll, uh, I love.
Uh, just chill, just chill.
We can wave a rocket.
Play slow and play for a rocket.
Just wait.
I'm not changing it.
We're low, layman, layman, layman, layman, hook him, hook
him, hook him, hook him.
I'm one, I'm one, I'm frozen, I'm frozen, I'm frozen.
I'm one, I'm one, I'm one.
Wait, change one, change one, change one, change one, change
one.
No more, no more, no more.
I'm all here.
The bubble, the bubble, the bubble.
I'm using for a raccoon.
I hit it three, two, one.
No more, no more, no more, no more, no more, no more.
Break it, break it, break it, break it, break it.
Yeah, break it, break it, break it.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma,
Emma.
They can't, they can't, they can't.
We go with my brother.
You just stay in your enemy backline forever.
Yeah, they should have, wait, Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They use rocket there, right?
Or no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We only have an ally and name our ice game.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I can look.
I can look.
Okay.
Hello.
Captain.
I'm on.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Yeah, shoot, shoot.
Captain, shoot, shoot.
Captain, shoot.
Rocket, one, rocket, one.
Yeah, look at rocket.
I can go too.
Oh, I'm one.
I'm dead.
I need to get out.
I almost are.
Just chill.
It's fine.
Run.
Yo, we can go back in with mine.
We can go back in with mine, okay?
Yep.
Can we go soon?
Three, two, one.
Cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, quarter, quarter,
quarter.
I killed one.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm wanting to be back.
Okay.
Can you aim more.
I got you there.
I think they're using everything, that's fine.
Yeah, okay, they use whale, they use helo.
Go, group up, next fight.
Yeah.
Without it, it's okay though.
They should only have cap and rocket.
They use everything else.
Don't have cap and rocket, yeah.
We have combo for racundo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who should I be hitting?
Anyone, to be honest.
I mean, I'll be on.
Just make sure.
Any squishy is fine.
I'm going left side, I'm going left side.
Yes, yes, yes, me too.
Okay, are you guys ready?
We're about to hit, we're about to hit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
i got you two one in one more and more and more mag low mag
low too i'm shooting my stealth oh they're also here they're
all we do some beautiful boots or do we just earn yeah we
wait for trapped we'll leap around go long i'm behind you
i'm frozen okay cap cap down cap behind get back oh we can
go back in we go back there i'm back i'm back i'm back we go
okay Hello, hello, hello!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Wake the rest.
I'm on hold!
Wait, wait, back, they're low in the back!
Low in the back!
Yeah, I'm living, living!
He didn't wait for a new one.
Oh yeah, he got deleted.
Go back, go back, go back, go back, go back.
Risa, reset.
Risa, up, group up.
Most fight.
Yeah.
They will have both defenses next fight.
You can have a combo for Ruckman.
They're gonna use Halo.
I go around.
I get it from Naira again.
Cap left, Cap left, Cap left.
Yeah, I'm on cap, Monk cap.
Yeah, he should lose HP here.
I'm looking for a...
He's diving here.
Cap, Chalk.
Cap, Chalk, Calk.
No bubble.
I go back then?
I'm turning hell.
Go back one, two back one.
I need heal.
I need to heal.
Torn walking.
What is!
Wait, hell no bird.
I should have the crowbar.
Only one.
Can I get it?
That one is mine too.
Can I do?
He has bubbles?
Hid it, hide it, hide it.
That one's mine.
I'm going three, two.
Come on.
Chuddy, shooting, shoot it!
Shoot it!
Oh, shoot it!
Yeah, you gotta shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot it,
shoot.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wow.
Yeah, that's fine.
Altitude.
Ooh.
It's okay, matchup, I think.
Matchup is good.
Just don't know what to do.
We touch it?
Oh.
They haven't rocket ulted ever.
Like, when do I use my Phoenix?
I tried to use it on my run, then they...
I don't know.
If you don't use it, I think that's feeling better, I don't
know.
I think we can yeah, or we can combo with the Rimbus and we
can damage with the Finns ult.
Do we not play Loki in defense?
What do we do?
What?
Do we not play Loki in defense?
You want to play Loki defense?
Are you sure?
I don't know, I think it's...
You want to do Groot mag?
Groot mag, Loki, I mean we can, I mean you guys can play
some Groot mag, but I'll just play Daredevil still.
I think it's fine.
I don't even see that.
I feel like I go Deadpool then.
Hawkeye or Phoenix?
Go Hawkeye.
Things is better about this go Hawkeye.
It smells worse than Namor's trunks in here.
I believe in you, Maxi.
I feel like I've just been marking the cap the whole game.
Yeah.
Throwing me in, like, I don't know.
It's not like you have to do Infinite, but...
That's what Tony used to say to me back in the day.
It's okay.
And this is like old value because like they have they only
have like two squirrels And I'm always gonna force one like
we just need to like kill to kill or like force the other
one Really good matchup just need to play it a bit.
Yeah, they have like a fucking their squirrels are pretty
bad It's like rocket.
Yeah, let's do Just wait and play slow.
All right I'm just a man
They have emma emma
Do they have cap?
Yes.
I don't know.
No, they don't.
I think they've held them more.
I think they scouted our comp.
Yeah, I think they might do it.
You still want to dive, right?
Yeah, it's still.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Three, two, one.
Oh, but wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Help him, help him, help him, help him.
I got no lumps.
I got a lump of damage.
Kill the, kill the...
That's fine.
I'll actually...
I curse nothing to do.
Maybe hook the guy in.
I'm going hell then.
Three, two...
Hey, there's one, there's one.
Come on, hella, hella, hella.
I don't know.
Emma's running these two goals.
Yeah.
And we go back full-dive.
I actually think full-dive, go back death, go back
full-dive.
I don't want to do it.
I don't see how it doesn't win this.
100 out of 100, oh, the matchup win.
Let's go group up and then go back full-dive.
I cannot swap spawn.
I have lucky one.
You can stay close.
I mean, you stay this for one.
You can stay this for one.
You can stay this for one more fight.
Okay.
I can still point.
I'm going to still point.
Hella main.
Hella main by himself.
One Hella.
I'm stunned.
Hear me.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Need to go back.
Look at him.
I'm here.
Yeah, P is.
You walk back out.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Walk back out.
Looky, top right.
Looky, looky, looky, looky, looky.
Looky, looky.
Your powers are mine.
I don't want to.
Can we, can we match?
Okay, walk it, walk it.
Don't walk it.
Hold it, hold it, hold it, hold it.
I'm blinded.
Three, two, one.
I don't know.
I don't have, I just had all of it.
It's okay.
Go next.
I also didn't really die.
Yeah.
It's good.
What's the chance are you doing?
Okay.
The matchup's 50%.
They're good.
Go back, Phoenix, I think, yeah.
Need to go, Phoenix.
I'm gonna go right side.
There's your stuffing left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll go right then.
I can go with my old.
There's Loki.
I'm going to Loki.
I'm going to, uh, Loki.
Three, two, one, one.
One, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, No, we're good.
Yeah, Saker, Saker, Saker, Saker.
Saker, Saker, Saker.
Oh, my, I don't know.
Sorry, I don't know.
It's okay.
Or maybe.
We take too many.
They go back in with the...
They went rocket in this.
I think we have to hit really early, by the way, like all
the way up here before they can get to point.
Yeah, I think so.
We can also hit the DPS.
Should be very hard for them.
Su, Su, walk into the maze, Su, walk into the maze.
We go Su, you go Su.
3, 2, 1, 1, 2, 2, 2, 2, 1.
Hello, one.
I go back.
I'm grabbing.
I'm grabbing him.
Oh, no.
Come back, come back.
We can wait him.
Just lift.
Give him a bit more.
I have my ult.
I can kill the Invis.
Get it.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
There's a captain behind us.
Invis one, in this one, in this one, in this one.
Invis low.
He'll do it.
I have a captain on me.
Can he help?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm on help.
I'm on help.
Cap, cap, cap.
One, one, one, one.
Shoot him, shoot him.
He can let the key heal.
He's out of the way.
I'm coming over.
Did they use anything?
Let's go back.
Just go back.
We play for high.
I'm here.
Okay.
I don't have Phoenix or from Rockett.
I'm sitting up up up.
I'm sitting up up.
Cap on the left.
You have far left or what?
Yeah, they're walking up.
Walking the main.
Can you go?
I can go.
There's someone.
There's Captain America to our left.
No good cooldowns.
No good cooldown.
Yeah, it's good.
Don't don't hit him.
Don't hit him in the bunker, please.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I can go on rocket.
I'm dead here.
I'm dead.
Break it, break it, break it, break it, break it, break it,
break it.
I'm dead here.
I'm living for you.
I'm living.
I can reheat.
Do I have to set up TB?
Maybe when it will actually, maybe when it will.
They pulled you.
Wait, look, see, look, see, see, see, see, see, see, see,
see, see, see that.
In this one.
What?
I don't know.
He's actually in the other one.
It's on TP.
You got it?
You're up here?
Yeah.
We're TPing, we're TPing, we're TPing.
Do I need a touch?
I need a suicide?
No, no, no, no, I think I can touch.
I think we'll get it.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, good.
One, one, one.
No stun, how about?
I'm ultimate one.
I hit with you.
I'm 95.
I need to get it.
Oh, we're dead.
Go next.
Okay.
go next okay sir played in front and farm this okay go mag
uh this one can you stay venom no okay oh angela angela's so
good here let's go angela i really think angela just went
automatically just exist on the map just play to punish we
can hit with phoenix ult here yeah hello right yeah i'm
gonna walk up i'm gonna walk up i'm gonna walk up i'm gonna
I can look, I can look.
Come on, hella, hella.
Hella, hella.
Two, two, two, two.
Two, two, one.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma,
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Two, two, two, two, two, two,
two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two.
I don't know.
I'm trying to hook Emma.
Emma, no, no, no, no.
I got her, I got her.
Okay, I'm trying to kill her.
Okay, she'll, she'll, she'll, she'll, she'll.
You're alone, trust me.
Care, care.
Don't get them or else when you collect them.
I got it.
Break it.
Just live.
I got it.
I can go back in.
Go in this.
I'm walking in.
I'm not shooting it.
Invis, Invis, Invis, Invis.
I blinded her.
Invis, Invis, Invis.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying to heal you.
Oh shit.
You have only focused.
Swing back.
Go next way.
Okay, I'll go die.
Try to live, try to live.
I'm trying to.
I can't go with my health care.
Yeah, I'm back.
I'm back.
Wait, hello, hello, bottom right.
Hello, bottom right.
Butter's off.
I got two.
But they used it.
Wait, wait take poke, poke, poke for a cloak.
They only have invisids!
I'm taking damage for invis.
I mean, four cloak.
Yeah, yeah, I'm taking damage.
I can get bowed easy.
i'm gonna set up raids for a time 86 yeah i can go rocky i
can go rocky go on you're on i have it i have it can you go
can you go here don't go that deep can okay don't go that
deep okay oh my god
Hang on.
I can't shoot him.
I'll set up deeply.
That's kind of where we need Phoenix ult, to be honest.
That's okay.
We used to fight before.
We had good setup.
I think I played this speedily and then we just went.
No, I think if we play this, we just actually, we just went.
I think we should have just played for Cloak Hult.
For Cloak Hult?
I mean, it was, I don't think so.
I think it was just lucky that we didn't die for.
They should have just killed us.
I don't know how I lived there.
I mean the damage reduction, 20% on Deadpool helped you live
there.
Oh shit, thanks.
Yeah.
I mean, it doesn't change the fact that we still had a bad
situation though.
You look at how we lost the fight.
There's multiple fights we could have won.
That was crazy that I lived still.
That's unlucky.
yeah him dying there there's nothing we could do you got to
agree so i always saved my old for rocket i feel like i had
to you can you can use aggressive too but i mean what do i
say it's like when you have wood you can like flank with it
if you want but in the last fight in example if we're all
playing to hit then we need like a structured hit we need
everyone there kind of and it'd be not so aggressive with
cloak i was like i'm going all the way in now i was like you
could have flanked that fight and you couldn't just like you
need to shoot the squids as well moxie more often i was like
i'm going all in and i'm like oopsie yeah it's on the far
left like do i play far right maybe i shouldn't have done
but when we set up a play when we set up a play it wasn't
development yeah then you can't just like flank and hit with
us no and then once the hit is done you just go back i don't
think even if i didn't do it too deep i think like if i
didn't do that it didn't matter we always try to stay in too
long it's okay as soon as our hit is out we have zero chance
of confirming the kill then we need to get the next best
thing out of it which is draining resources preventing them
i don't think like we would have won even if i did not go
deep that's kind of sad there's so much maybe we should have
paid engaged last fight speedily
yeah last five last five is my bad i just rolled yeah it's
kind of annoying yeah like they use all their resources to
try and kill me and it didn't work but we still lost it it's
pretty good
but yeah definitely i think like even if i if i like got
back to my team if i didn't alt that team i don't think it
would have changed anything i think we were i think we were
regardless list.
Because I think if I, like, alted back to my team, Namer
would have just altered our team.
Our entire team instead of alting me.
And then that would have killed all of us in general.
Like, he just solo altered me and I was still alive.
So I think that, yeah.
That Jeffskin, which one?
This one?
Oh, yeah, it's the Pixel one.
It's weird.
It's weird, right?
Today doesn't matter as well.
Tomorrow's more important.
Yeah.
you know now we know what they play it actually doesn't
matter you know pressure doesn't really create diamonds
today is only sitting yeah it's only seating it's only
bracket we still have one more team to fight and then we're
good to go we can disperse do we know what team no um i mean
look they haven't oh yeah they haven't said anything in the
captain chat i think we play against the nexus team now yeah
i think that's the last thing we haven't played
Like we have our own group, right?
Do we versus the people in the other bracket?
Yeah, I think so.
Who's winning in the other bracket?
The flats?
We don't know.
Probably is.
Seems pretty good.
Um...
yeah they fell held um and they were against uh they were
against sk's team i see such
an eights matchups really they just have everything against
us emma grab thing's done namor i guess i shouldn't bet
cloak the cloak band is not worth it i think but the angela
band is good i think we need i don't think they can't play
phoenix against us like this i really think if i played that
earlier yeah i think like i honestly think like i'd rather
play against phoenix than i mean at least for that team like
i think like being leaving phoenix open is fine do we still
want to let's change it it's always the uncirculated 50
damage from the squid that just kills us that's like so hard
one more game and And then we're all free.
I can't wait for next.
Okay, next.
Actually, next week.
Next two weeks.
I'm going to be so stressed out.
There's so much stuff.
Jeff, I'm still like, go for dive.
But we have, like, Mantis instead of, like, Phoenix or
something like that.
Wow.
And if they don't, and if they, but, like, instead of, like,
last saving Jeff.
That's why we had no schedule for this week.
This is literally a free-for-all.
I agree to that.
But, like, it sucks because, like, my cough is so bad the
last two days.
Yeah.
Or we can still play dive, but instead of Phoenix, we can
go.
mantis triple support with jeff yeah i see like with the
coffee it makes me so tired throughout the day because like
i've been like coughing myself awake and also like i'm just
like i know we can't just play what we played earlier like
hawk and triple mantis so it's like not great and it comes
and goes too because it's like it's like i would be okay
like if we had played three days ago and then suddenly i get
hit hard and then like the cough was so bad i was like
literally like it was not hot it was it was not the hot kind
of coffee i don't even know you can make it hot it was like
it's like when i'm coffee a hairball out yeah like i was
copying i was like yeah we need to punish the enemy yeah it
was not great it was not great yeah and then like and it was
like i believe angela is this good against full dive bro
trust me trust me who's we yeah is it me what i mean who's
we where you say shoot them more like with my gun no no we
need to push them more so they force resources like hella
bird and name or shift and then we need to kill them confirm
afterwards you know everyone needs to be yeah and then like
always not having the best time needs to go in with clap you
know whenever you have clap you play aggro and then you try
to one shot with clap and try to help us you know because we
want to get healed yeah we want to do damage at the same
time every time we dive i try to clap when no one when no
one in the enemy is meeting you in main then you want to
develop on the map and help us stage a hit right by hitting
the enemy hella hitting the name because you force a
situation where he doesn't have resources and you have
resources okay so basically i pull i so basically i don't
play main if they're not on cap or or something they're not
on cap yeah i mean If you don't have to touch card, then you
can develop.
Like, if they have no one to touch the card, you can just
help us in the dive.
Risky business, alright.
Even if they have someone to touch card, you still want to
play the high ground to give you the best opportunities, no?
Like, if they have...
Like, an example of the last map, you could have played the
high ground every fight, and it's very hard for them to
overcome.
On second point?
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like I was, dude.
You gotta watch it.
yeah when i have a cop make it to you how hard i need to do
some nice help and suddenly in the super chat thank you
thank you yeah every time i just make it once and then like
i can't do much about it just because you know you should
have infinite opportunities to i don't really i can't really
go go out yeah i don't think i was doing that well on attack
after i drink my tea as ggs it's over we just gotta watch
back and tell me look we can do that i don't mind doing that
after the next game or we can do it now if you want but
thank you super chat thingy thank you i even had the the
more is the card on stream the it's not like it's not the
black liquid just the chinese black liquid for yourself i
even had that i take it every day otherwise we just and then
the game right you just have infinite pressure on us like
here on second point you mean right i hope so too i hate it
defense i think one was what what's what's the longest i've
had the cough for guys now we need to watch the fight after
yeah paypal go we have a setup once the longest i've had the
cough because i've always had these coughs they kept my
record so it's fine if you play the high ground what's my
current record we already poke so like this situation
example in our matchup is pretty bad because look we have
five people that want to play for a hit and you already poke
so you need to like chill more wait for the hit and then you
keep it was a half of you know don't say that like don't
like one hp no don't say that how are we going yeah i'm
definitely not recovering with me screaming opportunity to
kill hella you see and now you can't do that because you afk
oh my god there's no way i had it for half a year we were
just normal right which happened there's no way you see no
it's with filtered water this time i got a filter I bought
like those filters Then you wait then you walk in this area
then you fire a stun in then we have a stun with us Oh,
yeah, but that was when during the phantom beat concert I
literally accidentally got back-to-back sick I like
accidentally I like went to rehearsal.
I think I don't remember.
I went to rehearsal at Atlanta and then I got sick from it
We want to hit again Like I was about to recover and then I
got double sick and then it like fucked me up But it's kind
of the same thing you see you you want to poke about too
much when you just should hide or take top Yeah, I was
playing on the back on the back damage, you know, like yeah,
but that's like Pokemon They have hello name or and you
don't have resources for it I think it's like in example
could be if we have Loki on the high ground too here Then
Loki can heal you on the high ground But then people would
have to play further up the fact that we don't have that and
the fact that like our only support is Togibird and she's in
main right now not on the high ground.
He's gonna heal you if you take damage So just the same
thing happens now.
If you take damage here, now our stun for the hit is gone
and you take damage, so now you can't fight.
And now we want to hit, right?
So just the same thing.
If you were with us here, no one will shoot you.
They can't develop on the map.
Then they go bottom here.
Then we have a killbox to hit here because then you can take
with us.
Now you can't do that, you see?
Now we go in, and you have no control on the map because you
didn't play for it.
you see so now we have to make which is fine you know and
then the same thing would apply now now we kind of need a
play because they're going to have ultimates so either we
match it or we kite it so either you go in like and take an
angle go here and match the angle of i'm gonna grab water
i'll be right back take the i finished another and try to
hit from behind because now you're in the same position
where the enemy hella can take you in his advantage you on
the high ground because both of you should just drop up here
right both of you should re-rotate the fact that you guys on
the high ground is just going to put pressure on all of us
which prevents us from hitting right so now they now they
want to walk up and we're still on the high ground and no
one can play as long as we don't have winnie develop in the
backline right now and jeff pierce like everyone is stopped
from development and we have three people like afk this is
the same thing when they have angela afk in the sense of you
guys get poked now then we hit and then you on collapse on
that look now we want to hit right but now you peek too
early so you once again in the same cycle where you can't
hit with us so now you just play to live and you die entry
because of that if you had played to live earlier and we
kite to kite to ulterior right because it was obvious they
were gonna do that then we have a situation after where we
can hit right and where we can win after now the situation
is not there so it's like super i'm listening broken it too
this is good like i really like the that deadpool ult by the
way speedily we always killed inverse it's so opi yeah this
was a very close situation fight here like this was winnable
and then the next fight moxie you just came back and you
died with ult i'm pretty sure no i didn't have all i was
like oh yeah it was like it was like well it was like yeah
yeah we say we have touch so you need to respect it and you
just take the opposite side go behind them and just shoot
then they have to match it if you shoot the if you go here
no one can control you just develop to the high ground here
go here and then you just shoot here forever with right hand
peak check check check go in just chill
also guys the server is up by the way that's good yeah but
these are like all the same fights though it's like legit
the same thing i did my captain job second point for so long
we really have to respect the enemy's position more i did my
job as captain we want to go in take the high ground from
them instantly clocked in you should get infinite thank you
i'm a very good captain now we have your job done job done
probably have to look back at job done this fight is more
important because we had good momentum here this is a fight
where i kind of would want to go at least not allow them to
play for free on point no you should definitely be on the
high ground already because now you take too long to take it
once again you play low ground you should be on the high
ground here yeah motivational speech stand the top here we
got look at the thing that we would have okay day one
doesn't matter we are just sad bagging guys we're just
giving them fake straps we're giving them comps that we're
definitely not playing tomorrow right the hell much longer
because these guys need to spend more time on healing each
other so we can stay in their backline much longer now that
we don't have a stun both me and speedily take way more
damage and I die for it right this is like the situation
right we just play too passive and it's the same thing here
too we want to hit and Doki needs to clap you clap a bit too
late and you don't clap us you should walk forward and clap
us because then when we hit here right same with Jeff
Pierce, we actually have a situation where we can stay in
the enemy backline longer forcing more resources from them
giving you guys more time to clear the people on point or
DAP to clear people on point and this is like every single
donkey bird mansion I didn't do my job like I just die and
we just lose even though we had two entry picks situation so
we let the guard move like like alone it's okay if we let
the card move alone if we want to clear i think clearing
here is more important so i think it's okay to let it move
uh so i definitely feel quite sad that i like die here i
don't know where winnie is on the opposite side of the map
yeah it's kind of mistimed it's kind of unlucky what i i get
in the i'm in the die so like now i feel like winnie you
shouldn't have went back i've never played yeah i think it's
curious about like i like keep going forward i like played
so much non-dive in rank because n a doesn't do dive this is
like always good for us nr doesn't do dive so i have no dive
experience at all this is like every time i play like the
last the only experience i've ever had would dive is like
literally this and then we like peek a bit i swear i swear i
like this is like my first time experiencing that and we do
know it away from us should always walk in if we play this
dive comp and then walk out once you don't have it anymore
but yeah the cloak was where the biggest problem honestly we
are not planning cloak anymore i think but we definitely no
and they hate that nobody plays dive i think i want to play
cap and if they have invest and i want to go a lot enough to
pick up so that's why i have like no experience i don't
really know how i don't have experience with dive because n
a is just bra back two minutes and eight people just like
the bra so like i'm very used to positioning myself in a bra
bra setting i don't know what the fuck i'm doing i i don't
know what the fuck i'm doing right now
i quit i took a break when dive was meta i was like that
shit You know when the support strike was going on?
I was like fuck that.
I'm out
But I was striking not because I felt like I was
underappreciated because you know I've been playing support
since Overwatch days like we're never gonna get appreciated.
I've learned that
I've realized that that that's always gonna be the case So I
was just like but then like but the last draw was when it
dive was meta and I was like fuck that shit I don't know I'm
playing dynasty warriors I just hate dive it's just not fun
it's fun for like the tanks and DPS but it's not fucking fun
for the supports you know why everyone's like but dive is so
fun yeah because you're you know like you're a tank or DPS
you're not on support ain't fun it's fun for the divers
being dope so i have zero experience playing with dab
like human torch meta was all right it's better than dab but
i do agree to you winnie i think we can save mantis last
year we also have a better opportunity you can do it
tomorrow okay because they also feel like we should play on
mox as a strength like if he wants to like play hawk eye i
think it's a little bit on hawk I'll just put him on
something comfortable.
He gets to play Hawkeye!
Yeah!
I'm down to just like keep playing that.
At least we're getting better on it.
He gets to play Hawkeye!
I mean, the problem is like our old cycle.
Like, I think if we just...
It's like we force out their support also, like, we need,
like, another, like, old combo or, like, another old that
can, like, guarantee like, a fight with.
Oh, my God.
He actually gets to play his character.
Maybe we try to like they they always support my my dd all
but then be like nothing after that yeah maybe we can try
against these guys to put mox on dd and then you can play
silo or star or star yeah yeah because i agree like if we
just have like another dps all which is like kill through
every single time yeah one day he will play spider-man one
day I'm back Welcome Matt Welcome back Thank you Moxie you
get to play Hawkeye Yeah you think so Yeah they just said Oh
never mind Oh come on Dude Matchup Matchup man Sorry I
baited you Fuck So you don't want my Spider-Man i broke it i
let him hope i let him hope for one second don't do this
thing it's very good though yeah but you're coordinated with
the trust me dives yeah but i think like it'll be good if
like we have like like another like guaranteed fight win or
like a star we can test it out for this game yeah we can
play at this game yeah
when will we see his spider-man though i know you guys said
it's good no i also think phoenix was it's pretty good
though i think it's like that's not spider-man trust me how
much are you not playing me on spider-man because it's bad
or because you think i'm bad on it i think it's just not
that good and too kept like we're not killing the captain
point it just never happens who's supposed to kill the
captain you know check check check the dap does 40 damage
per hit on mac he will never kill the cap damn he's using
logic against you he used logic against you maxi i'm just
just wondering
but i'm getting the idea of the phoenix now
you know his numbers it's over i don't know it feels like i
always need like when they're running like hello or
something i guess you guys go okay you got german german
efficiency right there but if you want to if you want to run
me on daredevil on koth i'm down to that because it's called
yes
snake case venom ban yeah i think they've gotten banned
venom well they've been protecting the venom wait drp give
trust the captain role you have captain
see guys i know this at this time job done protect venom
every game and then last protect spider-man job done i did
my job
oh we play triple but then we need to ban venom he's also
playing but he's also playing daredevil I don't think I'm
going to be like double negative in a rank.
Yeah, no, the interval on ping is so hard.
Like, you can't even react at all.
Because I don't think we got broadcast at all.
I think it's the only interview that broadcast matches and
we're not good enough.
They're like, this ain't cool.
This ain't, these matches aren't sick enough.
for you dying here I need to lock in yeah it is yeah good
yeah I'm gonna try my router I bought a router now I bought
a router that I hopefully can connect to my old router and
then from the old router I only use the telephones like the
telephone numbers and then from the new route I use the
internet and that would bro you Thomas Edison what the fuck
no chat GPT told me it might work so I'm gonna try it out
what else do I do otherwise I have to play with leg every
single 10 minutes and that's rough buddy it's pretty bad for
a pro what's your what's your speed the speed is not the
problem it's more like the fact that I have package loss
like every second and at one point it just becomes too much
so i have like one second leg every 10 minutes that's bad
yeah this is bad like it loses a fight in one of 100 fights
it's just lost because of it which they want you someone say
no all right we don't do no eu person says say no represent
yeah yeah that's it
holy we did it we denied their rights yeah fucking go
let's go the EU ain't good yeah see I had to have an EU
person say no you know it makes more sense an eu person say
no because then they're like oh you know like it's their own
kind like their own kind oppressed them not me you know so
it does yeah so it doesn't sound racist when an na person
says no exactly you know it exactly doesn't look as bad when
an na person unlike the long range one i think you're
playing air double buddy Oh shit.
I think so too.
It really be one of your own exactly.
Trust me, I feel you don't know my hero pool well enough,
dude.
I think I just play cap, huh?
I know you play me.
You have a mean wolf.
But...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, since when?
No?
I mean, me back in the day.
Maybe back in the day.
I mean, what do you play then?
Hawkeye only.
Hawkeye?
little bit of spider-man i could play i could play wolf
bucky but like bucky's up there then then daredevil then
mantis rocket cat and i'm safe okay they're not bad dd i
sure i can say it my friends are i didn't say it i didn't
say it the europeans denied the europeans the eu server I
didn't say it.
I was just like, nice.
Spider-Man, Ben, are you sure?
I was just a supporter.
I think Didi.
I actually think Didi.
Jeff, okay.
I think they played Jeff too.
Oh, we have Didi, so they can play Jeff.
And we still have Mantis.
I think this is the Mantis safe situation, right?
Yeah, I think so.
I think so, too.
good if people ban jeff against us it's just a free net to
save then yeah we've been
let's see what these i think they're local your inverse i
think i think rude really i think so no no they're not for
the playground all right go invest in go ban this it's okay
and then we say they they don't they don't play they have
snakey spinzy let us okay what do we play please you play
cloak okay it's gonna be a big problem though but it's fine
i guess bro i'm telling you they know they know don't put me
on star lord i think they re i think they rewatched that
particular part where you played star lord Where they were
gathering intel.
I know.
Pick your hero.
Hey, all you do on Starlord, just shoot tanks and then build
your ult.
You coach me speed.
Like, fuck, you gotta watch it back.
What was I doing?
I don't think he wants, I don't think he kill.
I mean, for legit anyone, like, you just shoot tanks the
whole game and then Starlord ult.
I think it's a trivia.
I think go...
Go Mantis speed.
Mantis?
I think we played, yeah.
Trooper with Mantis.
Gonna have to be careful against the Venomoult, though.
Venomoult's gonna be from DIP.
Are you here?
Yep.
We need to go back, I think.
Oh, is the worst soccer map on the mall?
I was gonna say, it's actually not the best.
Do we go dive here?
Uh...
I think we should.
That's good, Ivan.
Someone's might get going.
Go Invis Rocket.
Could have been mine, we would.
Invis Rocket.
I think it's...
Okay.
It's me?
Yeah.
I can also try Luna if you want.
But it can't be me.
My mic is good.
I would say if they played from the back, I would go, you
know, with another theme.
Is it still echoing?
It's like, it's like not that bad.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, because I muted myself.
So I don't, if you didn't hear it, then.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
I'll wait.
Be far.
I see Spidey.
Sorry, Spidey.
Are you tougher?
Yep.
Venom.
full dive yeah i'm on i'm should have uh backline or what
you just shoot Phoenix Adam name they have Adam I think
they've Adam Jeff oh venom's on us yeah oh sorry Karen okay
going in backward three wait 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21
21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21 21
there's res but I don't know if you're close to yet I got
him I got And where you will?
What the?
We pushed.
The shield is true.
I can't go back.
I'm going back lane.
Venom 1 is.
I'm looking.
Keep on.
I need to kill him.
I want a Phoenix mode.
Phoenix to the o point.
Let's go get Venom ult.
No.
Venom one, Venom one, Venom one.
Venom one.
Venom.
Venom trolling.
Nice.
I'm going to go back one.
When you want.
Yeah, yeah, I can.
I can.
Yeah, I can.
This is fighting me to go back then.
I need help.
I may have to help Jeff.
I can hold Jeff.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Jeff, Jeff.
Uh, you have me help?
I'm sorry.
I'm dead.
I got Spooner man.
Jeff, bottom right there, Fenix.
Phoenix, look, look Phoenix, look at right.
Look, Phoenix, look Phoenix, look Phoenix, look Phoenix.
for all right i can yield them here they have nothing they
have phoenix love do i just save it feeling fantastic i'm
gonna head them soon No cooldown.
I got their double random!
I don't have a...
Get all the support off for you, Maxxie.
I can go in in five, in five.
I'm going to hold those campfields actually.
I'm going to hold those campfields.
Tunnel is back.
Back up!
I have thelan LP.
I've got two-I've got two.
Boss, he has a shotgun!
Swag one, Swag one!
Ninth one, Swag one, Swag one.
Venom!
Venom up!
Venon up, Venom!
We can break it.
, yeah, okay, he's tagging it, he's tagging it.
We're breaking it.
We're breaking it, yeah.
I'm shooting Venom.
Venom one.
Venom One slow.
Venom once though.
Yeah.
Tap one.
Tap tap cap.
Tap tap.
Yeah.
That one looks like Venom one.
Venom one.
vole.
Killing staple one.
Kill them.
Kill that one.
Click.
He didn't.
He got nobody.
He got no one.
Nice.
Ivol.
That's right.
I dashed away.
The comparad on right side.
Captor on far.
Cap going forward.
Cap in Spider-Man, Cap Spider-Man, yeah.
Backline is nowhere.
Okay, no, main, main, main, main, main, main, main, main,
main, main, main, main, main, three, two, one.
I'm also holding.
There's a Captain America behind.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going for a cap.
Adam doesn't have cell.
Okay, they only have gestures.
Only have gestures.
I'm trying to save you.
Goodbye.
I like low.
Side one, side one.
Mega, mega.
I'm touching.
Do we see side or side?
I'm not sure.
No supports, no supports.
I'm throwing a res out though.
Wait, Venom 1, Venom 1, Venom 1, Venom 1, Venom 1.
I don't know if you get this res.
Cap 1, Cap 1, Cap 1.
Yeah.
Venom 1, Venom 1, a shield.
Venom 1, a shield.
Spidey, Spidey, Spidey, Spidey.
I'm going short.
Spidey 1.
Come on.
Thanks.
Cap low, Cap.
Venom 1, Spidey.
Spidey.
I go for Spidey.
Venom, Venom with J1, CAP1, CAP1, CAP1.
Can he heal?
Spidey, no cooldowns.
Catch, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap,
cap.
Got him.
DRES?
All right, can we get him?
Clear point, clear point, quick.
SAI, SAI, SAI, SAI, SAI.
SAI, Spidey, SPidey, no cooldown.
You got an ult, just got an ult.
Get a bottom right, Maxi.
I hear you.
I hear him, kill him.
No, go.
Huh?
Oh, what?
I threw my o-star.
Oh, okay.
I threw him out.
I thought you were still going to kill.
Oh, okay.
They have got venom, Jeff.
You guys should really kill the Jeff for free.
For sure.
I'm always on him.
Wait, did they...
Okay, they use Rez.
Did they have Jeff ult?
Probably, right?
I'm with your friend.
I can't lose.
You wanna go Jeff?
Me and... Me and Deer B combo.
I mean, I don't want to.
I don't want to point.
You look?
Okay, chill.
I'm gonna get their back claim.
I'm going back.
I have to get health back.
I can go spider.
No, no, no, no.
We have no supports.
They killed all of us.
Venom on a shield.
I'm dead.
C9.
Shevar.
I mean, this matchup is winning though, I think, but...
This feels like so...
I don't know.
Should I just be like going on supports the whole time?
You should be on the jet.
I think you can kill the jet for free.
goes into like the atom then like i don't know i think you
you go on i mean i could go i go jeff more i think my like
your damage is better on like the jeff and adam than mine
like i think my damage is better on like everyone else get
ready you're ready to go buy some skulls out there horn head
that depends do we know if our opponents are actually guilty
of anything do we stay this
We can go silly.
Yeah, Demi.
Do you want any good need more?
Yeah, I can.
I think it's better.
Two, one.
Proving Angela is good though.
They have the same comp.
They have same comp.
I better go on their side, Man.
Adam, Man, Adam Man.
I better go on their chest.
I can go Shark.
Okay, chill chill, chill.
I'm chilling.
I'm gonna go back up.
Three, two, one, go.
I'm gonna go.
I'm low.
I got touch.
Help me, help me, help me, help me, help me.
Oh my god.
I got Resna.
I think you get Res, yeah.
Yeah, Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch out for Spider-Man 4.
Come on, come on.
Res.
There's no way, aren't it?
It's just...
Can you go, uh, can you hit a back line?
I'm not shark.
Adam,
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Jeff now, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Spider-Man one, Spider-Man.
They have no heals.
They're stuck, stuck, stuck, stuck, stuck.
They still have no heals.
Okay, come on.
Nice, nice.
Just chill.
They might have cap built some.
We go with Invis first.
I think you can...
Any help, any help, any help.
Just look at them point when they try to push us with cap.
Okay.
Let them swing.
I'm gonna go Ageron.
I got you.
Appeal.
Cap is being here.
No res, no res, no res.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have my ult.
I can go with my ult.
I go with my ult.
Oh, I got hit, I got hit, I got hit.
He can, he can, he can, please.
Yeah, I will eat.
Cap one, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap,
cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
I'm coming back.
Okay, I'm way back in.
I'm coming down.
Nice one.
Nice all.
I'm coming back.
I think I'm a huge spy.
You have, uh...
What Spidey's left?
I can cancel Spidey mid Joo.
Yeah, I heard a slide and then...
Stop right.
I'm gonna, uh...
Yeah, I'm gonna stay back line.
What about?
I see both.
When in main.
Vindy on point, having a point.
Quip back and look.
Quip up, yeah.
Quip, cap, cap, cap.
Cap.
Cap, cap.
No shield.
I pulled one.
Sweet run.
I'm gonna back.
Oh, I need heals him back.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, self-walk, no dashes.
No dashes.
Play bubble, play bubble.
Kill the venom, kill the venom, no cooldown.
Venom dies, venom dies, venom dies.
One more, one more, one more.
I hit with you.
Fuck.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
Don't live.
I'm probably dead.
Nice, nice.
You see nine.
Good job.
Yeah, so he's red.
He's red at the end.
I don't know what he's doing.
That's fighting.
Probably not very fun for him.
I can't lie.
Yeah, he's playing Jeff.
Yeah, he's not very fun.
Like, he's dead deaths.
yo don't it's all part of his plan it's all i appreciate the
rocket it's all part of his plan yeah i think they're gonna
stop the comp yeah 30 seconds before you attack get ready i
think what else do we have uh close the sheriff on silo uh
silo play is gonna destroy us we kind of need to do
something before them you want me you want me to tp them and
then i come back on angela you guys should be able to live
just try to like save your cooldowns just walk up normally
and try to hit earlier than them just don't try to save a
squid moxie so you can throw the screen inside yeah i'll
just try to walk into the silo just try to try to save your
cooldowns backline for the silo you guys can definitely live
it i can make this work when i'm main shoot him out shoot
him he's top left he's top left top left top left yeah i go
they have loki they have loki now loki now i'm gonna go far
left I can't go back.
Venom off.
I can't go back.
I can go.
Three, two.
Okay, no.
They're blocking.
I need heal left.
Oh.
Venom in, Venom in, Venom in.
Venom one, Venom one.
I need heal.
Oh, Groolo, Groolo.
I can go back in.
I hit back line.
Ready?
Two, one.
Oh, he's not.
Oh, he's blocking me.
I can rest.
Good fun, good fun, good fun!
I'm on side, I'm on side.
I'm on side.
I'm gonna try to kill myself.
Yeah, me too.
I'm both chilling.
Kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him!
He's not, he's out, he's out.
I have mine, I have mine soon.
Three, two, one.
I push, I push, I push.
I can, I can, I can, I can, I can, I can.
Just try to solve, try to solve.
Nah, just go next, just go next.
Okay.
One.
Oh, good, two, two, two.
Just both dimples.
Both dimples.
Good boy swap.
You can go Hawkeye if you want, but it should be fine with
playing.
I think Hawkeye is good.
They have a Bucky and a fucking two Cloak folds.
I think I'll go with my ult and then I'm gonna swap.
Yeah, that's fine.
Me and you can combo Dior Priyoka.
Yeah, yeah, I can go now.
They have the hook.
Go!
Go out, go out, go out.
Yo, I'm fine.
I need heal main.
Let's go!
Let's go.
Try to try to think of defense.
Kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it, lamp,
lamp, lamp, only lamp.
Oh, that might have been too much.
It's fine, it's fine.
Venom got him point, nobody.
Kill Venom first, kill Venom first.
Good.
Let me hit this cloud.
They have side root, they have side root, copy.
I'm out.
We should get this grub gold.
I think we have to go really early.
Yes, yes, don't give them, don't shoot them too much, okay?
Do you want to go early then?
Do you want to go early?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, okay, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
Go, go, go, go.
Three, two, one, I'm on looky, looky, looky, looky, looky,
looky.
No lamp, looky, looky, looky, looky, looky, look, looky,
look, looky.
Clock one, clock one, clock dead.
Nice, nice, nice.
Live it, live it, live it, live it.
Big wall, big wall.
Wait, look, side, look side, look side.
Venom no cooldowns, Venom no cooldown.
Venom no cooldown.
Venom 1, no cooldown.
Yay!
Do it again, do it again.
Go early again.
They have a cloak hold this time, okay?
I can go.
Listen, we're diving early, force the cloak hold, and we
kite it, okay?
I can grab the grude off them now.
Siami, Siami, Siami.
Okay, I'm going down.
I'm on point.
No, no, no, no.
I'm living right now.
I'm living.
Okay, I'm gonna play.
I'm gonna play.
I need help though.
I need help.
I'm holding this.
I'm on Loki.
I got two.
I still play.
I'm living.
I'm on Loki.
I got two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm through the rest.
We should with people.
Keep in the spot.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm playing.
Two, one.
We're e-ing for you.
Stay in, stay in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lay them.
Lay them, they're all one.
They're all one.
I'm throwing my orbs.
Pick it up.
Nice orb.
Put them one on me.
Pick them up.
Okay, good.
Nice.
I got some.
Sorry.
Want to kill, sorry, kill, sorry.
She's one.
She's legit one.
Moxie, I believe.
They're gonna TP.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
perspective perspective, perspective, chill, chill, chill,
nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, no lamps, no lamps, no, I'm
out of the room, chill guys, yo, they only have one kill,
they only have one kill, they only kill me, I kill him, I
kill him, I kill him, I kill him, no more, no more, no
cooldowns, and one, let him no cooldowns, one, let him one,
kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill,
kill, He's trying to kill me.
Nice.
Yeah!
Moxie, you want to talk about that?
What did he do?
I was waiting for the stagger with my right click.
I saw he had double dashed you.
Okay, I can believe you.
You just thought you had it, you know, you got the 1v1.
That's it.
Yeah, this cupboard is bugged.
There you go.
Now this cupboard is bugged as fuck.
We're the better dive team, guys.
Well, I can't tell if you were trolling or not if you think
those call me.
That's me!
I did nothing but that's me!
Wait, didn't she live though?
No, she died.
Or did you kill her?
That's me, guys!
Let's distance save me!
Let's go!
The whale hit like four people.
I swear it was the whale hit like four people.
I swear it was the Angela's shield, to be honest.
That's crazy that you guys live.
I don't even know how you guys live that.
Oh,
yeah.
Wait, did it block the Venomal for like everyone?
Yeah, I think so.
Wow, that's crazy.
Yeah, I don't know what...
We would have definitely died.
No, there was also an Indus shield though.
But if we actually kite sooner that fight, we just win.
Like we had like a good setup again.
We just need to be expecting it more.
Like we play to force something, then we get out and then we
hit again.
Oh yeah, you did kill the SIE.
I didn't see it in my kill.
oh my
god we did it well they did it i was just chucking my balls
out catch the balls go catch it i'm gonna go pee now i'll be
right i don't even know how many pee breaks i've had i've
hydrated a lot i'll be back at the middle of the point he
couldn't get up that's good i mean angela's
uh zekra w forward meddy solid thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you thank you madden thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all right last two games two more i
mean if i don't bend that over there we just get rolled up i
need to bend it yeah i mean i had necro i'm not gonna lie
bro yeah i know might have went like one and seven in my
game earlier bro that's a fake bro that's her fake i'm
telling you I mean deaths are fake but one in seven is
Yeah, no high pink their double is not it's not a character
I hate it.
I hate it's like, you know, like You forgot what it's like
to like be not fucked up physically I'm like what did that
feel like work?
I just don't even have to aim What was that like back then
there's like that much speak of a difference between One oh
the courage score and the name was just pull it out.
I'm just like how did that?
yeah well i don't know if it was like i don't know if it was
like me or on phoenix or namor it's like i didn't know like
i didn't get the hit as hard like i didn't i didn't get like
okay like where do i don't care i don't play those yeah i
mean that's okay i think no one's doing that ranked okay
yeah true like i feel like a lot of it has to do if you set
up right if we set up for a hit then everyone's got to set
up for the hit you know especially if they have no
development at one point someone has to touch but dap can
always touch the the squids do make it easier so like if
they ever have like a cap and that type of oh my gosh
someone's talking about my mouse mice and i'll really okay i
saw this really cute one but i know it's like the thing is i
don't even know i don't even know like if it's a good mouse
or not let me say you're glad it's the one where it's Like,
it's not as straightforward.
I get it.
Oh, my God.
What did it?
I just think you, like, can't walk into the open.
I think you just, like, go all the way behind.
Oh, my God.
Bookmarked it.
And they're going to die.
But I don't remember what it's called.
It was like, it was like a mouse.
It was like a mouse that looked like a cat.
And it was cute.
And it was like the, it was like a final mouse type deal
where there's holes on it.
oh my god what was it look ah i don't want to search my
bookmarks i have too many bookmarks because like i
bookmarked so many things yeah but i bookmarked so many
things because i'm like okay i'm gonna remember this and
look at it later and then i never remember it that's my bad
where is i'm gonna try to find it's so cute i've been
bookmarking some oh i found it this look at this it's so
cute i might go snackies or something are so cute it comes
in different colors it looks like a it looks like a gamer
mouse because it has holes in it melee tech on dd where you
try to like get your fury back doesn't it when there's holes
on it there's so much damage w wl yeah when there's holes on
it that means it's a good mouse right i used to do that but
like the left click like raw left does so much damage oh my
god the usb is a cat that is so the usb is a cat do you guys
see it look yeah in the beginning it was kind of lost yeah
they were diving no it's a good mouse when there's holes in
it their comp is like so much oh my god they can dive with
tanks but i don't think we do because i should really want
want i don't know i'm watching your stream dude let me know
let me know you're all so cute um
it's all they're all really cute i don't even know which
color i would want the thing is i've been on logitech i've
had logitech for the rest of my life running you down i feel
like in the beginning i was like going like they're deaf
like adam siloac or who was it we're like lot of resources
on me like yeah he ready for me i delegated it job done i
delegated my work i just think like my like my character
yeah like i've been with like i've been playing with
logitech mouse my entire life the unless it called super pro
whatever the fuck it's called so it's like i don't know how
it's gonna feel pro wireless yeah my g pro wireless so i
don't know I don't know how it's gonna be like That swap but
it has holes in it So that would increase my gamer cred
right That's how it goes The more holes your mouse has the
more Gamer cred you get I'm gonna be like top 10 or some
shit Oh my god There's grip tape Oh my the grip tape is Cat
paws Wait the glass gates are cat paws Oh my god Yeah it's
more arrow dynamic Yeah yeah yeah that's what yeah oh my god
they know their target audience oh wait it's sold out maybe
okay this one is cute the neko one i think cypher
understands that full dive is very strong gotta count it now
okay look at this one and look at the purple one the sold
out purple one i'm the target audience i am i don't know
maybe i'll try out new mice all right i want to try out new
mice in general funny look at it look at the purple look at
the neko one it's so cute no way that's good i'm the target
audience i'm very inf like normally you would want to be
easy to influence anyway but they don't want that so that's
okay okay i i really like the cat one i want place in order
for that gambit then we just win what's the strider holy
look at the strider one the strider one sick they're blokey
though can we go to river with gambit or is triple with
gambit bet what's the game nice man i'm having two defense
with gambitles oh show me all of them yo yeah they've been
doing that what about the keyboards is there a cute keyboard
i've been i've been bookmarking a lot i haven't been in my
keyboard hobby in a long time i like how they're like
theorizing i'm here looking at mice like what i have no
input on this what am i gonna provide i'm literally a
make-a-wish kid for these guys oh my god look at this too i
don't yeah let me show you guys all the cute shit i
bookmarked with another support look at this i really want
to get this yeah okay but look at look at this keycap look
at these keycaps though this these keycaps look so fucking
sick it looks like those transparent like game boy and some
moxie target band yeah these guys are mostly playing my
daredevil too you can also go triple with grute if you want
but i would prefer playing all right i'm shooting back in go
gambit and rocket no go just wait i think isn't wait isn't
hawkaii i'm pretty sure we go hawkaii like hawkaii gambit is
legit like thanos yeah it's pretty good what do i play kills
kills through every support all i go rogue i go rocket
rocket all right rocket here oh yeah wait we have a rogue to
wait we share a compass then us rocket over cloak yeah i
think so you kind of want a little gambit like should i just
let the gambit heal sorry should i just let my gambit heal
and not give a fuck yeah bro if they go if they go loki you
should go side if they go if they don't then who's they
start all right i think They have a side.
Yeah.
Let me think.
They have a side too.
Is he better than you?
By the way.
They have Angela, Angela, Venom, Loki.
No, I have Spider-Man probably.
Yeah, Spider-Man.
Can you break those clones?
Can I do a Spider-Man grab?
He's gonna go for it.
Spidey one, Spidey one.
Yeah.
Venom out Venom in the shield I grab Venom Spiderman out one
I grab NG, NG, NG
Yeah, I'm shooting her Venom, Venom, Venom, turn Venom Oni
Karin Karin Karin Spidey, Spidey low Thank you Mother of
Cuts Take the point, take the point Venom, Venom, Venom
Yeah, shoot Venom, shoot Venom, shoot Venom out Should have
been about.
Buddy behind, buddy behind, guys.
Buddy behind.
Come on, Angie.
Angie 1, Angie 1, Angie 1, Angie 1.
I made your ult.
No res, I'm in position res.
Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie.
I can grab Angie.
I'm trying to.
Saddle again.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
No res, no res, no res, no res.
There's no laps, there's no laps.
Just go back.
Find the house.
Wait, side one, side one, side one, side one, side one.
Can you try to go like, right now before they have lamps?
They're not lantern now.
I want to go really, really fast right now.
I can go Gamba as well.
Let it go.
Three, two, one in front of him.
Oh, wow.shire.
Oh, shit.
Side one, save one, save one.
Mine here, burry.
Just live, just live, just live, just live.
Let's go.
Okay.
I'm dead deep.
I died.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
Okay.
I go in.
Spider-Man in this quarter.
Yeah, I see him.
I see him.
We shoot Venom.
Got me.
I'm not good.
Venom knows.
I'm not sure.
I'm good.
I can't kill.
Just live, just live, just live, just live.
Just live.
Come back, come back.
I'm gonna get some revenge.
I look for him, I look for him.
He's one, he's one, he's one, he's one, he's one.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
He's die, he's dead.
Venom, Venom.
I should go Bucky, I think.
Yeah, you can if you want.
They have Invis.
I can too, I can too.
Okay.
Uh, is Venom on us?
We can, we can, we can, we can, we can.
Okay.
I could help.
Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie.
It's good, it's good.
No more, no more, no more.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm on Loki, I'm on Loki.
I'm on Loki in the back.
Venom there's also Venom and Angela behind us yeah Angela's
at some point, Angela's still on point yeah yeah they're TP
get the tempo can we kill Angela he's behind he's done TP
out that's bad it's bad it's bad kill the Venom instead
Venom's dead no res firemen got the res look online look see
look see looks She's dead!
She's dead.
Only 60 seconds left!
How do you care?
How do you look?
Hello kid.
I showed you.
I got hit by Spider-Man.
No lights!
No lights .
I can all!
I'm shooting, I'm shooting Venom.
Venom No!
Venom in the shield.
Nice.
Nice, no nuts!
Look at it.
Look at it!
Change one.
Change one Shrpawn.
Right.
That's two.
We're scaling too.
We're scaling.
We can always go triple and just damage please me.
Moxie with Mantis.
Yeah, I think it would help with the Spider-Man too.
I think I'll go Mantis next to that.
Do you want to play?
Yeah, they're probably coming.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm probably dead.
No, I got the gun.
Yeah, I'm done.
I'll go Mantis.
just wait i could go meds too if we wanted to bucky they
gave us they gave us hurt i can't go low key can someone
write the goal to the back i can't do it yeah yeah Who will
help?
Just wait.
We can go with our gambit on the back line.
Yeah, we can go through.
Three, two, one.
No damage.
Come on, Envis, Envis.
See that's you dead.
Nice.
I got you, Envis.
Angelus behind us, by the way.
I had to, I got rid of the, I got rid of Rose.
Was that Loki or somewhere?
Yeah, Loki from left, I think.
You kill Loki, kill Loki, kill Loki.
I can't, I can't.
I don't think.
He's still top left.
I don't have dash.
I kill, I kill, I kill.
No lamps, no lamps.
They got my res.
Behind us.
There's a sidelock behind us.
Build a sidelock.
There's one, there's one.
Spider-Man low.
Suits or one?
There's one.
Sidelcov, Sidelcov, Sidelcov.
I got her.
I'm gonna live.
Oh, we'll just winnable, winnable, actually.
I should see you too, yeah.
I have my ult if we can force lamps.
Force lamps.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, we can maybe kill him, no?
Wait, I'm on Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie.
Yeah, kill Angie, kill Angie.
Try to get lamps out, I can ult.
Yeah, I go back.
Can you hit back lamp?
Yeah, yeah, I'm looking, looking.
Three, two, one.
I was in Angie here.
Angie one, Angie one, Angie one, Angie one, Angie one, Angie
one.
Hit the left, hit the left.
Shoot them, shoot them, shoot them, shoot them.
I'm trying to get you.
It's right about one, it's right one, it's right one.
Multi-multi?
I can't, I can't.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
Hot, Venom Heart, vote.
No ,, wait.
Boxing you first right.
I'll mend this.
I'll make it.
I miss the slot, Invis and's low.
Man, I cannot.
Don't, don't, don't.
I'm broken, I'll dead, I will be dead, I'm on.
Uh, Venom, Venom is behind us.
Venom low, Venom!
I have the heals, I have the heals.
I have a heal.
Venom low, Venom one.
Oh, he got the res, so he saw the way back.
They're they are they are cheaping they are cheaping those
fighting for it.
No risk.
Oh, they only have one support.
Wait what?
Oh, he kills me.
I can't find him.
He doesn't spawn.
They have a rocket.
They got the combo.
Come on.
I'm trying.
I'm trying now, try.
Rocky one.
Rof one.
I'm feeling her.
Okay, I don't think I can heal.
Yeah.
Fuck,
this is not good.
We get Gambit, but they get Gambit too.
They just copy.
Yeah, they get Gambit too.
I mean, the neutral should be good for us though.
Time to switch things up, including which side you're on.
Do you want to spawn on them?
I think it was spawn for they got no big enough.
I think so.
I think we go spawner with Gambit now and go Groot.
Groot Mac, I guess.
Someone go Mac.
Yeah.
With Gambit and Rocket.
No.
Go Cloak, I guess.
This one.
Okay.
I can go Cloak?
Yeah.
I think the Dome is very important to not die to Spider-Man.
Then where do I go?
Mantis now.
And then has Spiridly Go 10.
Isn't Rogue?
Isn't Rogue with Gambit.
Yeah, but I give 20% damage reduction, so I would rather
play that.
It's not really that OP because all of them just avoid my
hits.
Like I need to shoot them at least.
I don't have a weapon to shoot them one cloak, one rope.
I tried in the first two minutes, it was wasted time.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's wait.
Yeah, I was able to say, do you want to play until left?
Yeah, yeah, I think I'll do that.
How fast?
Where do we play?
They're going to be on dive again, but like slightly in
here.
So you guys play in the room, probably.
Okay.
Which room?
Like back there?
Oh, you want to play this room?
Yeah, I think I'm making play left.
I think we play left.
So you guys play in this room.
This room.
On the left.
If they dive you guys, we can help you too.
Yeah, I'll give you my units.
Okay, just walk outside of the room.
Walk outside of the room.
We need to walk outside of here.
I'm walking like this.
Wait, Muna 1, Muna 1, Muna 1.
Can you help me?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I need your point.
Let me break one.
Yeah.
I will.
Come on.
Spider-Man 1, Spider-Man 1.
There's two.
Venom better go.
Venom gonna go with.
You live it, you live it.
Spider-Man 1, Spider-Man 1.
I need help here.
I need help.
You need help point.
You help point.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I'll keep you back.
Spider-Man 1, Spider-Man 1.
Spider-Man 1.
Just die on point, die point, die point, die point if you're
gonna die.
Let's get into some good trouble.
I have my health, by the way.
Is he trying to cancel?
No, no, no, no, he might be now.
He might be now.
Okay, no, no, he's still with me.
He's still with me.
Okay, I'm about to put it down.
I'm about to put it down.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Just chill, just chill.
Wait, wait.
You're ready to fade it.
I don't want to fade it.
No, he's not, he's not.
I'm putting it on card, okay?
I'm putting it on card before we go in.
Three, okay.
Three, two, one.
i'm putting it for you the car to the right car to the right
wait wait i'm gonna look for you live can you live live it
live it live it you you have no support yeah no yeah we're
coming back coming back i had to i cloak off into the point
i'm dying i'm dying come back come back come back we can
help you we can help you yeah i'm good did they spider-man
oh i'll see i go around i go around i go around i go from
behind two one okay one i have touch i have touch guys don't
die i'll be late i'll be late i have touch i have touch i
have touch Oh, we got...
One hit.
Guys, lift, lift, lift.
We got Rural, too.
Oh.
Hey, dude.
I touched for very long, maybe we can make it back.
I mean, I can touch, but I'll die.
I think our venom can touch.
Our venom can touch.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You touch.
I'm breaking this wall up top.
I'm shining at you.
I'm gonna die.
I'm on Loki.
Look at him!
Oh, there's a wall, there's a wall, yeah.
I'm distracted, okay.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Spider-Man 1!
I have no sleep for Spider-Man.
I'm 1.
Ah, next fight.
It's okay.
Always play to live in these situations.
Guys, Cloakult, we're not killing Fru.
Always live, okay?
Always live.
Never fight it.
Always play to live.
Need next fight.
We have Cloakult.
We have, uh, Gambit.
I feel like myself again.
We'll just go, okay?
Yeah, we can just kill.
Kill the Groot, ready?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
One.
Can we lift?
I haven't touched.
Yeah, I'm trying to help our gambit.
I'm just gonna go in.
I'll go in, go to me, go to me, go to me.
I can use speed.
Wait, grid troll.
Grid troll, like grid trolling.
I'm trying to help you, monster.
There's a Moon Knight on me.
There's a waltz for waltz.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
I couldn't.
I got ulted.
Oh, I think it's...
We have...
Just die, Karik.
We're gonna die.
We have full health as well.
I almost have made this, I'll come back.
I'll be like first.
Yeah, I need to come back.
Yeah, I'll hold first.
I need a touch, I need a touch, I need a hop, I need a hop,
I need a hop.
Need a move, need a move, need a move, move, move, move,
move, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm going in, I'm going in.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going in now.
Yes, it is.
Your B has touch.
I kill back lands, guys.
campaign on.
Can Munnet ult?
We need something else.
Okay, I can have Munnet at.
Groove on, Groove on, Groove on.
Oh, output.
Thanks, though.
I got hit.
Can you break the line?
Break the line?
Break the line.
I'm trying.
I got Munnet.
I can't.
TP back, go.
We got TP.
Munet's left.
Munnet's left.
I'm on point.
You're strange on point.
Yeah.
You see how about Git?
walk through
walk by walk
walk up walk up kite this kite this cat let me come back we
have 300 we have kafal we have kapal we have kapal ?
I'm trying i hit batman ready 3 2 1 they're gonna go next
level i touch let me touch let me touch Everyone got off
everyone Let me talk I have two super I support Spider-Man
on him Oh my boy, I'm on boy.
I'm on boy.
Lookie lookie lookie lookie lookie.
I was a stranger.
I'm also what's one thing?
standing down coming back I didn't I still a chance to stop
that Fucking cloak boy.
I just had Spider-Man and cloak chasing after me wherever I
go.
I'm trying to show him.
That's why?
play this hero i don't it's just like 30 seconds of support
ults i can't kill anything yeah no we have to just pray that
we live i'm gonna go toilet i'll be right what can i do
because like the spy match is actually a heavy chasing after
me with someone else yeah and i just get like i just get
blown up even with other supports healing me
i don't know what to do I'm like, I exist and then I blow
up.
I'm like, we have to trade the enemy back then.
That's like, what we can do.
See, I hate dive.
I fucking hate dive.
I don't know what to do.
I feel like I just exist just to blow up.
I think we have tried it, but look, you look.
No, they want me to save it for them.
So it's like, I can't really save it.
it for myself because like they want me to use it to like
use it to save them i feel like if i don't use it because
like i got yelled at for using myself in the past it's just
impossible to kill
i mean i can use it on myself but i'm worried that they
they'll explode
I'm not gonna ash again It's like in the J3 tournament When
during scrims I got yelled at For using bubbles On myself
Because they have to use it more Defensively on my team So
now I'm like second guessing On how to use it Any more ban,
huh?
It's deadly Like why shouldn't I have gone Bucky there?
should i just save my dome for myself because i feel like
yeah yeah you have to when you're playing yeah you have to
okay i think maybe you can play wolf here as well okay we
got our answer we play selfish especially we have like silo
all right we're gonna be selfish fuck my team i live be on
the tanks of the game yeah fuck my team okay
It is what it is.
It's just hard, hard dive me.
So I'll just be like, I die.
Okay, what is the plan?
I think the plan is we ban Loki too.
Yeah, I think we instead of cap, we just ban Loki.
Yeah, I think so.
Also, I think if they go ban on Groot, which is like with
the dive DPS, we just put Moxie on Wolf, no?
Yeah, you just go Phoenix Wolf and go Mac.
that'll be fine yeah i just don't know what to do when i'm
on rocket when that happens to me because i literally saved
my dashes and it feels like it didn't work on phoenix
map is it central park central park it's good dd map i don't
know like what to do like i don't know what to do with
rocket rocket like i dashed away but i still why not go
bucky trust me i mean I don't think we're killing the Bucky.
I don't think we're killing the crew with Bucky in Canada.
If I live on the walls, they know they can spy me instantly.
I think living on the walls is not a smart idea, only
because their DPS, their hit scan will just shoot me down.
And their hit scan is literally Delana.
Their hit scan is literally number one team in NA hit scan
play.
It's not like it rank where I can believe and them not
hitting their shots they put i was just low-key listening
dude i don't know i meant this i know i know and then just
grab just grab so it's not like they'll miss or anything
yeah like you can either play like super defensive and just
sit on your backline and be like the venom or you can just
probably walk on the grid because they have a spidey silo i
do stick too close to my team but it's like they spoke they
had they just burst fire me like did you guys see that part
in the front, we're at the front, and then like, I was
literally in my team and then the Spider-Man Venom walked
in, and then I died.
I exploded in front of my entire six-man team.
We can't win with the best, we can't lose with the best
character in the game.
After DD.
It's alright, it's alright.
We got this.
Yeah, I was just like, I'm, okay.
I was just like, I'm with my team.
I'm not with my team.
I die.
I mean, then we're just not at the top of the building.
Yeah, but then that makes let's the corner me faster.
I feel like that gives them an opportunity to corner me
easily with Spider-Man because I'm not with my team.
I think we give cap.
No, I'd rather have a pro player on Gambit than me.
I'd rather play against the cap than a fucking Angela too.
A pro player will have more impact on Gambit than I would.
Because the thing is, I'm the only well me and moxie me and
moxie that's fine like i don't think moxie ever played pro i
don't necros has played pro in overwatch but like all of
like me and moxie are the only ones that have have never
played pro before so this is like hard this is harder
because these guys actually know what the fuck they're doing
it's definitely a lot harder i think i think you've been sue
i think you've been sue i think it's like hey dive fuck dive
if this was this is the yeah it's inside bill fuck dive room
droplet yeah if they go like the same romp as last time
loving dive because it is the best comp bro i mean we have
no brains let me unga Bunga!
With Jeff.
So how do we stop the Jeff?
Starlord?
Oh, the Starlord.
They can't like Lambert.
God damn EU players so smart that they can do dive.
That's how they eliminated all the NA players that land.
You don't fucking know what we're doing.
That's fine.
You'll need a top notch team.
It's kind of annoying.
Oh, Starlord.
Why do I try to go pro?
Because I don't want to be depressed.
I don't want to be depressed.
Yeah, I think Starlord, Starlord Phoenix looks like it to
me.
They don't really have that good support against it.
And I'll just go dive character.
I think I'll go cap and we get a rocket.
I mean, like what supports can they even play?
They have to play like Rocket Dash, then they're just going
to show him by like their own.
Every ult possible.
Yeah, I think so.
I think if you go, we just cap and sit on the jab, like it's
unplayable for him.
So nothing will change.
Yeah, but then I'd be more depressed.
I'm just going to get a good ult here.
There's a limit.
If they have Groot, I would rather play that.
I think...
They don't have that good support.
I'd rather minimize my depression, guys.
Guys, I'd rather minimize it.
We also have Angie.
We also have Angie open versus like...
No, no, no.
I have plans.
Just swap it mid-round if you think it's good.
I can go with two.
I can go Venom, is it?
I'm going to go behind them.
I think Angelo is better against full dive.
If they have Rocket or Jeff, Angelo is more consistent.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Save Sigh.
Wait, Cap left.
Cap left.
Yeah, Venom Cap, Venom Cap.
Venom Cap Rocket or something.
They're farming Sportal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
I'm dead.
He's on the back.
Nice, nice, nice, chill, chill, chill, chill.
He arrest.
What's the idea?
Play slow, play slow, play slow, we're down support.
Side one, side one, side one.
We can't do anything yet.
Just wait, just wait.
Oh, Moxie is dead.
Venom.
De de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de
de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de
de de de I'm trying to help you
They're the one they're the one low I'll break it I break it
They have no support guys they have no support I'm gonna
Venom low Venom half Venom one They got a TP they got a TP
They're not, they're not, they're not, they're not.
They use most of the portals.
Yeah, they only have a Psyus.
Yeah, they still have Phoenix all.
They don't do that now.
You're right, DJ right, DJ right.
I think I'm going to use Phoenix early since they just
rocketed me.
Rock one, rock one, rock one.
Luna main.
Luna is super valuable, but it's same as rock one.
Yeah, can we try to go aggro with our rocket all once we get
it?
Yeah, I have it.
Oh, already popped.
Oh, okay.
That's nice.
They have point, they got point, they got point Yeah, I'm
going back there Luna point.
Luna card, Luna card.
Luna point.
I gone faucet.
Oh my stop!
I'm done.
Cap got low on the AF, on the right, On the right.
He's high, he's very high, cap half, cap half.
They play the skip.
Side one, side one.
Where is Rocket?
Side one behind.
Side one, like, like back main I think, back main.
Oh Cap, Cap can die, come.
He's on the other pack, he's on the up flag, Right, right,
right.
I can make the res for you.
No cooldowns.
Cap, cap, cap, cap.
I broke it.
I outed it.
DDD, DDD, DDD, DDD.
Cap it's set.
Cap it, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, one, one, one, one, run on, run on, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, Venom, no cooldowns.
Venom no cooldowns.
Venom won.
No cooldowns won.
He's still won.
The cab's touching cart.
Okay, they're gonna stop the cart.
I'm ready all.
Did he top left?
Venom on cart.
Venom card, Venom card.
Come on, Venom.
Venom.
Come on.
Come back.
You walked my health.
He walked my health.
Three, two, one.
Did he won.
I'm holding the background.
Three, two, one.
Venom on cart!
Venom and cap on cart!
I'm shooting cart.
Cancel, cancel, cancel, cancel.
We need cap.
We need to shoot the Venom on point.
It's Venom and cap.
Yeah, we can't do anything about it.
They have no gills though, you guys should really kill them.
Yeah.
They're number one!
Go Phoenix, go Phoenix.
Go Angela, Angela.
Go Angie, go Angie, go Angie, trust.
Yeah, yeah, I need it.
Me!
Wait, look, look, look, Phoenix.
Look, Phoenix.
Look, look, look.
Look up.
Come on, this Venom.
Shoot the Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom!
Venom!
Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap,
Cap, Cap, Cap, Cap, I push back.
I push back.
Venom, I have Venom!
Venom on cart!
Yeah, any heal, any heal?
Oh.
I get a rest.
Okay.
That's good.
Can you break?
Oh, he almost broke.
Yeah.
I couldn't get out of that.
You and Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven,
Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, Ven, one, one,
one, one, DD.
DD, DD, no need to fight.
Phoenix won.
I push Phoenix.
I need to live.
Just chill.
I'm killing him.
He's on.
Okay, we got Riz, we got Riz.
One and multiple, one Okay.
Walk my out, walk my out!
I am ready to go.
I can ... I can two.
I can heal them after this.
I can kill them.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Wait, rocket!
Rocket, Rocket!
Trey, Trey, Trey!
Two, one, Fenix one, Treenix one, Fdire.
I'm shooting card.
Drow's in.
He'll try to get to you.
I need him, you're on pasley.
Hercook him.
He got you.
Fennek, wait, go.
Okay.
Walk.
Okay, walk.
Thanks.
Go back, come back, back, finally.
Very slow.
I can't, okay, okay.
Venom, Venom on cart.
Venom one, Venom one.
Rocket one, Rocket one.
Captain, Captain Mirka on cart.
Chill him point, chill him point.
I can't cancel TP.
I'm in a really bad spot.
I can't really cancel TP.
Just chill, just chill.
And he can, he can.
No TP, no TP.
He can, he can, he can, please.
I'm gonna grab this.
Okay.
Shoot the cart, shoot the cart, shoot the cart, shoot the
cart, shoot the cart.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
Bro.
No support.
No supports.
You do me.
You do one.
I'm 75 on all.
I'm trying to get close to.
I'm trying to 80, 80.
I'm only 80.
I'm trying to 80.
I guess I'm fine.
I can't stay fine.
I can stay fine.
Uh, I can, you know, touch, touch, touch.
I can all tap right.
I'll tap right.
I need that one.
I need heal me, heal me, heal me, heal me.
He'll be.
Fuck me.
Really?
Uh...
Point, point, point, point.
I got it, guys.
I got it.
No heals, no more.
They have no heals.
I am so low.
Play the bubble.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tap, tap, tap, tap.
Tap.
You have TP here.
Come on, I'm on, man.
Stay on, stand.
Need a stand.
I'm off, I'm off, I'm off.
I really needed that.
I'm going to be close to Gambit, if you want to come back.
I'm on Rocket, bottom right?
Oh my god, I got...
Oh my god, the Phoenix.
Rocket's one bottom right.
Nice, tank.
You have Gambit on.
Luna on point.
One, one, one, one.
Yeah, Phoenix, Phoenix, Phoenix, Phoenix.
Look, bottom right, look bottom right, backline.
He'll point, I'll heal point, heal point, heal point.
There it is.
That counts.
I don't know.
I mean, they're just holding points forever.
I mean, we do the same, I think.
No?
I think...
Go triple again, no?
I think triple with mech, go triple with mech then.
They just rotate stars with Captain and Venom.
I think I'll go Emma.
Yeah, I'll go Emma.
It's fine.
But if they have Cloak, you should go back.
I died less, guys.
I did it.
I didn't go behind the wall.
I don't think you can hit.
I mean, I can hit anything.
Yeah, but you at least were forced to go off of all the
supports.
I don't know what to say.
Like, the matchup should be fine.
I think Angela is also fine.
I really think Angela was good.
see namo is open no play namo no it's bad oh gg then go
phoenix go phoenix that's fine phoenix well i feel i'm
damaging i don't know i mean they just need to die more they
might just pump clock out and go with it i got you sorry but
your one-eyed warrior isn't even playable yet i mean full
dive is meta so it's like hard to beat it's normal but the
leak is online i can lose
five four three two one let's see what they have phoenix
phoenix venom venice the main i think they have cloak yeah
grew yeah grew they're just gonna farm cloak all by the way
yeah if you're not shooting then wait do i let you i'll just
let you farm gambit out then why did you fire me i hear
someone's here let's wait phoenix the main top left DD!
Look DD!
DDD!
DD one, DD one, DD one!
D1, D1.
You should get res, you should get res.
Dude, I have one!
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good.
With my E, I don't want you, buddy!
D, D, D, D, D, I help him.
I'm with you, with you, with you, with you.
I have a DD behind us.
DD's just shooting behind us.
You just touch while TPing.
I'm trying.
I can't touch.
Go.
Just go Venom or Cap, I think, no?
Angela, just go Angela.
Angela is so good, yeah.
I think Angela.
And Daredevil just flagged this from behind.
Sidewalk is good.
I guess I'll find it.
I don't know.
Maybe I actually go Cap and just go on point.
Okay.
Okay, DD LinkedIn is vulnerable.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
Venom, Venom.
Venom dies.
Wait, we're top left.
Hey, touch.
We need to touch, yeah.
Someone needs to touch points.
I'm going, I'm going.
You're me, top left.
He's in null.
I'm not gonna win.
I can ult after.
Yeah, yeah, I can ult here too.
Yeah
I'm trying to we're trying Yeah Oh nice I'm trying I'm
trying Our gambit needs help Check out mistaken.
Draw one.
True one.
Okay.
Venom one, Venom one.
No cool downs.
One one.
There's a spider in the bag by me.
Spy one, spider one, spy one.
Spidey one!
Relay deployed!
No cool downs, Venom.
No cool down, Venom.
He's one.
Yeah, he's standing.
Try to lock him up, try him.
He's still one.
Is he still one?
That's right.
One, one, one, one, one, one.
Spider one, one.
Ok, instead of you one of them.
You can heal you from there.
Yeah, I'm trying to see him, man.
Just chill.
Just hold again.
I'm gonna try and get you, give you all.
Just lift, just lift.
I'm gonna try and give you all.
That's better.
They're on cap again.
They pull half.
Dead ever in the right side, dead ever in the right side.
I'm not healing, I'm letting you heal.
Yeah, DD top right.
Just don't let him get in.
On cap.
DD remain.
I'm dying.
I don't know if he sees it.
Dead.
Did you want me?
We're about now?
Don't even fly.
I think we...
Go.
Dd1, Dd1.
Dd1, D1, D1, D1, D1, D1.
Do not, do not.
Just check?
Just check check.
Duff on.
Copt.
I have mine.
They have total, too.
I wanna go early.
I think we have to go for a first try to kill through.
with Gordon Gambit's eye.
Oh, that's good.
LUNA, LUNA, LUNA, LUNA, LUNA.
LUNA one.
I can ult after each.
I can see you.
I can use my ult as well.
Improves him.
I'm alt now.
Migleton.
I got two, I got two.
I can ult after.
He can heal me in the back maybe.
I can.
I'll touch.
I'll touch, guys.
What do you want to see?
They're the one, they're the one, no they're the one.
He's the one.
Just chill, just chill.
Can you live, can you live finally?
I can.
Where is he being?
We are fatigue.
I have I have losses.
Okay.
They have no support ults.
They's both.
You can cancel.
Ooh yeah, baby.
He's on the way.
Phoenix long.
Just wait.
Dave, cap kill.
Dave cap kill.
Can I have enemol?
I think someone's flanking.
I think someone's flanking fine.
I hit backline.
Yeah, Daredevil.
Daredevil, Daredevil, Daredevil.
I see him.
I touch.
I touch guys.
No, no res, no res.
I'm dead.
I get res still, I think.
No, no, no, no.
The Daredevil got the res.
The Daredevil.
We're backline.
Our backline.
Please help.
Phoenix up.
I need to grab health though, if you guys install.
I don't know.
Final score.
Should have been kept, I guess.
i mean it's just full dive it's the best comp in the game so
it's like so hard to live i guess maybe needed to go with
the strip again and try to win instead yeah like yeah we
were healing each other but no that was last and then it's
and then it's tomorrow bracket because like the gam and i
were healing each other but it wasn't enough we can't out
heal the I don't know what I'm supposed to do first point,
by the way.
Like, if I shoot my gun, they're going to get Cloakle.
And if I don't shoot my gun, they take the whole map.
So, I don't know.
It was over, dude.
Oh, my God.
I don't know what to do either.
I swear I did so much.
I don't know how to do more.
Like, I need to play Angelo there.
What do we do when me and the Gambit were getting jumped
there?
Because, like, we were both healing each other.
But, like, we can't out-heal the full damage in the end.
Oh, no one's sitting.
say anything okay i guess i'll never learn i can't the data
is doing infinite i can't play the game he goes into my
background we can never clear him we can't it's all right as
a as the tokens i'm not gonna lie like i guess thanks guys
see like the damage i don't know no that's why full time is
okay you know we can't stop it there's nothing that changes
the ep maybe goes doesn't stop it yeah just now die and i'm
like bro me and the other support we just heal each other i
don't think thing changes anything there they're still gonna
have they're like quiet you lowest rank no rights and i'm
like you're right especially then even less well i think
last map like we're just like not like getting value out of
bad olds like we're just like not we didn't like win a
single side also impossible to get a value out of gambit
olds because you can't really like it doesn't matter they
still touch cards like the problem is we gambit old we walk
on backline but they touch card like bro they show it's also
no it's over it's ggs yeah yeah we're done we did three
games yeah
kid.
I mean, it's hard.
I mean, maybe just need to change the band there.
I mean, DD is just too good in the full dive, I think.
And they just play Cap Venom, so they're just like they
never die.
Yeah, I don't know.
There's no other... I mean, what they're playing is exactly
what I would want to play.
Cypher is very aware of that, so...
They're also like...
Oh, man.
Cypher calling out, like, every support ult, like, to just
farm it, it's just so AIDS.
And then they just go in with it, have time like to start.
The Sepulfa didn't win them really the game.
It's just more like the neutral game with the cap, I think.
Yeah, the stall was...
Yeah, like we never really killed them when they were
stalling.
I think maybe we all just turn around when they start
stalling or...
You got to shoot, you got to shoot through.
Yeah, I was shooting as well.
But it was like me, Moxie and Winy both shooting the cap and
venom, but they just rotate so we can't do anything about it
they're always 1 HP Gambit Mirror because Gambit Mirror is
also losing against Sidebeach it's just better so it's like
we got Venom and Cap 1 HP so many times like us three but no
one capitalized on it
it's alright literally like me and Moxie are like Cap slow
Venom slow and then our front line didn't shoot silence
crickets I was like oh sorry my opinion doesn't matter I
don't know what to change actually like normally we should
win this we just need to shoot them
harder I don't know what to say other than that the matchup
looks good we discord the enemy cap control the entire map
we won't shoot everyone with Phoenix I don't know I mean the
DD did too much I think honestly looking at it that's all
right They know more than me.
I feel like my opinion is really much.
Because I don't really know what, I guess I don't know what
I'm talking about.
I mean, I'm going over all the options.
I think for tomorrow we have different vans than we're fine,
but other than that.
We're also now versing these same teams tomorrow, I don't
think.
But I think we've versed the other bracket now.
Yeah, the other bracket, yeah.
I'm going to head out for now though.
Gigi's today.
Gigi's.
everyone ggs ggs ggs see you see you that's all right i just
think like they're all like the pros they're all just like
in their own heads about what they should do and what they
shouldn't do i feel like because of that the tunnel vision
on stuff so like what the things i bring up they're just
like oh you're just a little baby the adults are talking
Yeah, they're like, little baby, the adults are talking
right now.
Yeah.
They didn't say it, but it did sort of felt like it, but,
you know, it's like, I don't know.
I don't know if I should give my opinions on stuff here,
because it's like...
I feel like it's not worth much because like it's just met
with silence and I'm just like okay I'll just talk to my
chat then
I don't know every time I feel like every time I give my
opinion on something I just get ignored so I feel like I
don't know it's just like the one time the one time I was
like what can I do I don't know who it was.
But someone's like, yeah, just use your dome for yourself.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if I should speak up again.
Because it sucks, you know?
Getting ignored.
Like, like, it's not a good feeling.
So I'm like, what's the point of talking if I just keep
getting ignored?
You know?
yeah i i feel like i speak loud enough i feel like yeah
i feel like i like i'm speaking as loud as i can and the
loudest i can would just literally be yelling at them but
like i don't want to yell
it's not super low though i have it i haven't at my usual
volume.
I'm just speaking much more soft.
I guess I'm speaking more softer.
I just don't think I need a screen to be not ignored because
that's not productive.
Because it's like um like the thing is, Wynie also brought
it up too, but he was also getting ignored and Moxie was
also bringing it up but he was also getting ignored.
So it's like Like the three of us were just like, what do we
do?
Because we're literally like, like I would hear Wani yelling
being like, guys, come back.
Come back.
And it's just me and Moxie coming back.
Like, like literally.
Literally, it's just me and Moxie that would turn around and
come back.
Because Wani would like, Wani would like yell it.
And then like, I mean, my rock y'all was also pretty bad
too.
yeah and moxie was also trying to talk a lot too i maybe
it's just synergy issues honestly it is what it is like
that's what drafting is it's hard to build synergy in
general but you know ggs ggs tomorrow is a new day um we
gotta remember we gotta remember that you know for me okay i
don't sad that vibes got ruined i'm still trying but i'm i'm
vibing along while i'm trying yeah
it is what it is i want to say vibes but then everyone sees
it as a negative connotation now it sucks but i'm still
trying i'm still trying i'm still trying my best um yeah but
it's like they killed the word i'm still trying to go in
with positive vibes it was frustrating just being ignored
like me and my other support being ignored a lot um because
like i don't know i don't know what to do like i feel like i
do i like i'm trying to play for my life but like it's not
working i don't know what to do
yeah like me and my other support we are trying to play for
our lives but it's it's so frustrating too we did we did
whiny and i did we were like i don't know what i i mentioned
it so many times too and moxie is with me too the peel but
like there's not much you can do yeah
uh we all have to fight for our lives and i'm just like If
I, like, piece away too far, too, from my gambit, I, we die,
because we have, we can't move away too much.
Yeah.
Like, we mentioned several times that we need help, but I
don't know.
Maybe that's just dive meta.
We're, like, it's just, fuck it.
Goodbye supports.
It's like, the supports just live long enough to fucking
die, I guess.
Maybe, I don't know.
I don't play dive meta.
maybe that's just that's just what dive meta is like you
just for like let the supports just collapse and just hope
that you get they killed them before they kill us yeah yeah
moxie helped a lot moxie was trying to help us yeah i'm not
used to dive and i'm not but like this is a dive team
super chat thank you thank you
i don't know i'll talk to boga about it later
i don't know i'm not used to that meta i guess maybe it's
just my experience too yeah i'm trying to shake off the
shake off the negativity right now i'm trying to go back to
happy-dokie
no I just wanted to ask him what I can do to be like to just
be like guess happier
you know I was like what I can do to be happier How do I be
happy?
You should, oh I should.
How to be happy.
I want to go to Clauboring Club.
Oh yeah, do you guys see Clauboring Club?
I know what I can do to make myself happy.
Watch this.
It was just frustrating, I guess.
I was clobbering club.
Did you guys see it?
It's like, it's literally a parody of Fight Club.
I'm surprised they were able.
Okay, this is what I do.
There's a lot of console players.
I looked at it last night.
All right, Diamond.
Okay.
oh there she is all right all right where is that where are
they oh there you are
okay if they don't accept don't worry i was doing this last
night oh shit all right probably a shit on what am i i feel
like they're just gonna go tank I'm just gonna get shit on.
Alright.
Fuck it.
If I get shit on by a silver, it is what it is.
Guys, most likely I'm gonna get karma in my ass and he's
gonna play fucking tank or some shit.
And...
My order is sharp.
My mind is sharper.
Bro, he's gonna play tank or something.
And then I'm gonna get my ass beat.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
I'm gonna get my ass beat.
Oh my god.
What do I do?
I have so little HP.
I'm gonna get my ass beat.
Whoa.
Oh my god, this is actually unfair.
You smart.
He knows.
Here we go.
Yeah, that's right!
Alright.
Alright, let's...
Now I don't know what to play.
Honestly, that was the only DPS I know how to play.
Alright.
Let me... wait.
Let's go Call of Duty.
Oh, shit.
Hello.
I will stay here.
Yeah!
This brings me...
See, maybe that's the secret of happiness.
I think I found it.
It is what it is.
Alright, back to...
Gotta scout it out now.
I gotta scout out my next victim.
Alright.
Where is he?
You.
Come on.
Let's go.
This isn't the way.
It's the only way.
I bring my grief on to others.
Me sad.
Now you sad.
I look at you differently after this.
Me sad.
You sad.
Oh my god, what if it is a smurf?
Oh my god, I think you quit.
Okay, there we go.
It's okay.
I didn't die to a bronze.
I didn't die to...
It's okay.
I didn't die to a bronze guy.
It's a spy.
What if I'm in the sky?
Do I have fly down?
I don't know.
Oh, it's time to find out.
Oh.
There we go.
Yay, I flew up.
Yay!
Yeah, we did it.
All right, one more.
One more just to be happy.
Is that correct?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
One more.
All right, over here.
Hi there.
Hi there, guys.
Hey, everybody.
season data oh where are you where are you
no not you i pick i picked up my clients
i pick my clients what
is this not too high Nah.
Nah.
We're on my bronzes and silvers.
Ah.
Ah!
Devil's flower?
Where are you?
You are here somewhere.
Is that the guy fighting?
right now?
No.
Where's Devil's Flower?
How am I supposed to fight?
Okay.
Oh, he's over here.
Oh, he's up here.
Alright.
I'm Logan Paul right now.
I had a bad day.
And now I'm scouting.
Alright, this is the only thing that can help my bad day.
Nelly pudding?
Ooh, Nelly.
Oh, did we make it?
Oh, we're entering the Clobbering Club.
Who accepted?
Oh, shit.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, this might be harder.
She's gold.
This might be harder.
She's gold, guys.
She might fuck me up.
Oh, no, I've upgraded.
From toddler to child.
Alright, she's gonna jump into Invis, isn't she?
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Oh my god, she plays like a pussy.
really does here we go my turn you know what i can do that
too look who's talking
says you oh look oh not look
I'll do the thing that she did.
She's like, where is she?
Where is she?
Oh, where is she?
Oh my god, is that actually karma?
There's no way.
Karma doesn't exist for me.
Oh my god, is that actually karma?
No, it's not.
Karma doesn't exist for me.
Yay!
We did it.
Never punished.
Alright, one more.
One more.
I gotta find my next...
Alright.
Is there a fault for having...
a public pro wow jokie now you're victim blaming all right
we're hey they could have kept their profile private they
went to clobbering club with public profile their hair hey
don't run away
Um, they had a public profile.
I'm legally allowed to challenge them based off their rank.
See, they could have kept their profile private like this
guy.
Oh, Platt.
That might be a little too high.
Ooh, that's like an adolescent.
I don't know if I like that.
It's not as fun.
They have to be a...
Oh.
Where is he?
Oh, this gap.
All right.
What about you guys?
I'll take anyone.
I'll let anyone fight me.
But only if your rank is low.
Only if you have a low rank.
I'll take anyone.
I see penguin.
Oh, no, plat.
Nah.
Too hot.
Diamond.
Radmaster.
Where are the babies?
Did I beat up too many babies?
Ooh, sticky.
Where are you?
Where is he?
I'll find you.
Don't worry.
I gotta fly, though.
We're sticky.
Okay, best game.
His name was Sticky, something, something.
Where is he?
Oh, Sticky.
Wait, he's not here.
Oh, there you are.
Hey, Sticky.
One of them will say yes.
One of them will let me fight.
I found him oh
no they kicked out all the kids
all the kids are gone i beat up too many children wait i see
pet no i don't understand maybe here all the kids left
Wait, I'll find...
All the children left!
Oh wait, nice.
Here.
I'm not gonna fight my own level.
I literally just lost like, I literally lost two matches.
Fuck that shit.
This is the only way I can win.
Because even though my opinions didn't matter, didn't
matter, I know here that I rank above the kids.
At least I know, at least I know that I rank above these
children.
My opinion matters here.
I'm just reclaiming what I lost.
Forever, Rex.
Where's Forever, Rex?
Oh my god, there's too many.
Oh my god, I actually don't like that.
There's too many flashes.
Where is he?
Forever, Rex.
I know you're here.
I saw your rank and it's perfect.
There's too many high rank players.
Well, high rank as in like, there's too many adolescents.
I'm here to beat up the children, not the actual adults.
Or like, well, more like teenagers, I would say.
Oh, GXR.
GXR, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I'm coming.
Wait, did I fought this person before?
I don't remember.
I lost.
Did all the kids blend in together?
All the kids actually blend in together.
Yeah!
Will I get Carmen again?
I'm the biggest kid on the playground.
That's me!
Oh my gosh, she's playing Phoenix.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
She hit that.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh no, she's bad.
Okay, I was just like, Wait a minute.
She's hitting shots.
I don't know if I like that.
Alright.
Alright, I got closer and then she didn't know what to do.
Okay, this is one of my worst characters.
So maybe...
Oh shit, okay, maybe she'll...
Maybe she'll fuck me up.
I don't know.
This is actually my worst cut.
I mean, it's point and shoot.
Well, it's not my worst, but like, you know what I mean.
If I'm like not... Oh, it doesn't...
I was just gonna say, damn, GG.
Thanks.
Yeah!
One more.
I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling it now.
Alright, where are...
Alright, more victims.
More victims.
um hello I wish you could challenge them from here Oh shark
bait Where is he oh there you are
You see I don't want to do a pub public duel because I'm not
here to give my money away
This is a real player what do you mean?
This is a real player Oh, yeah, you know what time it is,
kids.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Even though they're silver, they're just as real as you and
I.
Are you trying to say silver players don't have rights?
They're just as real as you and I.
Oh, my God.
Not the rogue.
I've never played against a rogue before.
Like, DPS.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Yay.
Update.
Guys, they accepted that duel.
Oh, fuck.
No, I can't actually can't.
I don't know if I fight against a spot or met.
They didn't have to accept that duel.
Oh, my God.
I actually got...
I don't know.
know how to fight that's actually a shitty matchup for me
all right
all right i think i actually might get karma i'm gonna lose
to a child oh no don't look don't oh okay
don't look don't look guys
This is bad.
This is actually...
He went dead!
What the f- It's okay.
It's okay.
It's just one of...
He was smurfing, guys.
Guys, he was smurfing.
He was smurfing.
He was smurfing everyone.
This is like when you're going death match and the guy pulls
up a fucking diva.
It's just like that.
That's it.
another guy I'm picking another child that's fucking it okay
that gots to that's it I'm finding a bronze player guys he
was smurfing guys God I can't believe you would smurf in I
can't believe people was fucking smurf in Dua I can't
believe it.
Do they have no honor?
No honor at all.
That's how I'm picking tank.
I've learned my lesson.
No!
I actually don't know how to play tank, so this is going to
be interesting.
I don't know, How do you play tank?
Actually.
I've never actually played tank before.
Fuck it.
Is this cheating?
Oh.
That's right.
This is why I picked you.
Oh my god, how do you play this character?
I can never die.
My HP is so high.
Yeah!
I figured it out.
I figured the system.
All right, one more.
One more with my new strat.
I figure out the strat, guys.
This is the last one for real.
It's called my...
It's called the tank strat.
It's literally...
It's literally deathmatch where you some fucker will play
Diva in a deathmatch.
Pizza rules for me.
Where is the guy?
where is he pizza rules for me oh shit I got kicked up
where's pizza rules for me there's no one up top where are
you oh he's gone
I need, like...
Alright, last one.
This one's for real.
Where is that?
Oh, there you are, little Jeff.
Come on.
Oh!
What?
He closed it?
Why are you here?
Why are you here if you're not here to duel?
Like, you might as well uninstall.
He knows.
Coward.
I say as I'm here beating up children.
No, but he's the coward, guys.
Not me.
I'm willingly choosing this.
Did I beat up Cookie God yet?
Whiskey in a can.
Where is he?
Where is this man?
He's silver.
Oh, there he is.
Yeah!
Come on.
Take my challenge.
There's no one want to fight me no more.
I don't understand.
That's it.
I'm rerunning it.
It's okay.
I can find a I have a new identity.
I grabbed a new identity.
Alright.
They have yet to hear my tails.
Where is he?
Let's see.
Oh, there he is.
He has yet to hear of my tails.
Okay.
He doesn't know yet.
He has not.
He doesn't know my legacy.
My record.
The red idiot.
I don't understand.
I just want to one silly duel.
I'm not here to hurt nobody.
Just a one tiny silly duel.
Alright, don't worry.
There's more.
There's more people here.
I think I fought.
this guy before oh
there you go where is he the shooter 69 oh there you go oh
my god sidelock and her fucking jeffs
old one why are none of them accepting my doors do you think
they know
Don't ask me to fight.
I'm just watching.
Wait, Shulk got...
He's like, leave me alone.
Why are you just watching?
Don't you want to see what it's like?
Aren't you curious?
What is it like, the thrill of it?
You have a chance to win.
It's not like you're gonna lose or anything.
It's all, you know, everyone has a chance.
That's the best part Man knows what he wants.
He just wants to watch
Also, it's surprising a lot of people do not put pub do not
private their profiles
This area is no fun no fun
I just One game Come on, one more And I'm done I just need
one more to get my fix You know
Just one more And then I'll be okay I just need to get my
fix The last one Oh, this guy Wait, did I not duel him
right?
God damn it You're like private Okay No, gold is...
Oh, I don't want to beat up an adolescent.
I don't want to beat up a preteen.
Because I don't know.
Preteens are like a wild ball.
Preteens and teenagers are wild balls.
It's like an actual that anything can happen.
Flat.
I'm gonna actually have to go with a gold.
Oh my god, there's too many gamers.
I might have to refresh.
I need to find...
Don't worry.
This is my last fix.
Broken bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There we go.
Wait, this is so empty.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's nobody here.
It's okay.
I will find someone.
Oh, I...
No, he's gold.
Never mind.
Oh.
That other motherfucker.
Where is he?
Where's that other motherfucker?
Wait, he walked by us.
Oh my god, you're so tiny.
Who are you?
Oh, no, you're flat.
Where's that other motherfucker?
He walked by me.
Nobody wants to pay for a duel.
Wait Uncle oh there you you you I'll say yes, right?
Yeah
All right, here we go Last one for real guys last one And
now I'll reset myself Yeah
Hello, child.
I'm going to teach you a lesson today.
Never accept invites from random strangers.
Because they're going through a lot right now.
Oh, he's also playing Tink.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Never work, Shep.
Bam!
Never accept invites from random people.
Alright.
I don't know.
That's Thor.
How do I play with Thor?
We're going to learn a tank here.
I know Thor is like strong, but I literally don't know any
of his movesets.
Oh, shit.
I actually don't know any of his movesets, by the way.
I've never played this guy before in my life.
I'm learning here.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh my god, how the fuck?
I'm low.
Where is she?
Yeah!
Yay!
Oh my god, I didn't even use this.
This would have been so strong.
I didn't even use this because I didn't even...
That's right, that's BM.
Boom!
I didn't even need a use F.
Yeah!
I didn't even need to use it.
I literally nerfed myself.
You know what?
I'm going to fight the first person I see.
That's how confident I am.
Right here.
I'm going to fight the second person I see.
Yeah, fuck it.
I'll do it.
Where is he?
Oh, what?
I'm gonna fight you.
I don't even know you're ranked.
I just went and asked for it.
Look at that.
Yeah!
Okay, LG, for real.
For real this time.
Oh, yeah.
He could be smurfing.
You don't know that.
You know, unless we do.
I literally went up to the first guy I saw.
Oh, Squirrel Girl is like her favorite character.
Oh, that is sad.
Hey.
You can't handle the cute Oh
Oh Alright You know what?
Let's do it Let's do it How am I monster?
She agreed to the door I'm just going up to random people Oh
shit Wait a minute Oh I'm literally going up to random
people.
How am I the monster?
I don't know
I'm pushing this.
I'm grabbing a shield for myself.
I need a shield.
There you go.
Oh shit, he's using a shotgun.
I forgot.
Never do close range against a Punisher.
My box.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Did you want to level something?
Now they know how I felt when I'm, like, the non-pro player
at this tournament.
Now they know how I feel as a non-pro player in this
tournament.
I will never, I will not stop the cycle.
I continue the cycle.
Look, how is this?
He didn't rival me.
Alright, what is your E though, actually?
Look, see?
I'm willing to challenge a level...
A level...
A diamond player.
I'm literally...
Challenging a teenager right now.
Look at that.
This guy's Grandmaster.
Alright.
See?
I'm literally fighting someone that's a Grandmaster now.
Look, I'm not bullying children.
I swear to God, he plays tank though.
It's sharper.
This is an actual 1v1 now.
Oh my god, Scarlet Witch, really?
Oh my god, wait, it counters.
Scarlet Witch is a counter of Scythe.
Oh shit, wait, I was supposed to do his...
Wait, am I late to his totemachi?
Oh my god, tell him I'm beating up children right now.
Now I'll join the VC.
I forgot I was supposed to show up.
up okay wait what time is it oh it's okay i'm not i'm not
late i'm not late
i forgot okay it's okay we'll get this done quick almost
forgot wait hold on i'm not late i'm not late that's not
fair he's fed him
Wait, this is not fair!
Oh my god, I almost...
Fuck it.
What do you have, mom?
There!
Hey, what?
Tank!
We cheated!
He fucking cheated!
That should not be...
I feel like you should ban tanks, honestly.
Or, like, it should be, like...
Like, if it's tank versus tank...
oh my god wait wait I actually might lose this
it's because I was off the vibes he actually just walked
away I should have just played DBS he walked away slowly
from me I don't play tank god I actually can't god damn it I
want to play more but I'm actually wait what time is the
totemachi what time am i at oh shit okay oh my god i is me
next oh my god oh my god okay all right i gotta go all right
guys tomorrow day two as always everybody say hi to you
pause check it out and move around get that blood flow as
always everybody say hi you say for me head to bed cause you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys